Und eines sage ich Ihnen, Leipzig hat 4-1 gewonnen. Wir haben neben Dortmund einen zweiten Feind, den wir jetzt endlich wieder attackieren können.
Diese Firma, diese Maße nicht anzepten, das hätte ja auch keine Tradition über längere Zeit, aber sie haben sich halt den Standort ausgesucht, wo sie gesagt haben, sie können Feld bestellen.
Wir konzentrieren uns auf uns und auf unseren Weg. Wir haben klare Vorstellungen, wie der aussehen soll und ob andere Vereine das jetzt gut finden oder schlecht finden, hat keinen Einfluss auf unsere Arbeit.
Da ist ein Fußballklub und da ist eine Firma.
Ich kann nur für mich reden. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, auch keine einzige Sekunde, dass alles, was ich hier tue und den Aufwand, den ich hier treibe, auch nur einen einzigen Gedanken daran zu verschwenden, dass das nur dazu dienen soll, eine Getränkedose zu vermarkten. Also ich habe ganz andere Gefühle hier, wenn ich hier jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehe. Ich sehe die Menschen, die sich begeistern für uns. Ich sehe die Euphorie, die wir erzeugen, mit unserer Art, Fußball zu spielen und die Freude, die wir den Menschen bereiten. Man soll uns schon eine Chance geben, mit unserer Art, Menschen glücklich zu machen. Und das tun wir auf diese Art und Weise. Und wenn das der einzige Grund wäre, warum wir das hier machen, dann wäre das schade.
Den gibt es noch. Die spielen jetzt auch wieder in dem Stadion, also die erste Herren, in dem RB seine ersten Jahre zugebracht hat, hier in Leipzig. Und die haben natürlich diese Chance, die ihnen da geboten wurde, angenommen. Also die haben das Geld nicht irgendwie verschlenkert. Vielleicht steht da jetzt auch irgendwo ein Jacuzzi im Keller, das weiß ich nicht. Aber die haben auf jeden Fall insofern auch nachhaltig von diesem Tauschgeschäft gewissermaßen, oder von diesem Geschäft, wenn Geld als Mittel fließt, muss man ja nicht von Tauschen sprechen, sondern das ist einfach ein Geschäft. Die haben von diesem Geschäft schon profitiert, haben sich gut aufgestellt. Und meiner Wahrnehmung nach sind sie jetzt ein bisschen weiter oben, als sie es vorher waren. Ich kann das aber ehrlich gesagt nicht jetzt mit irgendwelchen Langzeit-Trends in der Tabellenposition untermauern. Aber sie sind auf jeden Fall jetzt präsenter.
Also eigentlich spielen sie genau an der selben Stelle wie 2009 beim Einstieg. Ich glaube damals waren sie so ein bisschen drauf und dran, in die Regionalliga mal aufzusteigen, in die Vierte Liga, was für sie so ein bisschen der Höhepunkt der Vereinsgeschichte gewesen wäre. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Höhe, in der Oberliga rumzuspielen. Vielleicht doch mal ein bisschen weiter oben, was sie immer noch sind. Ich muss aber dazu sagen, dass sie aufgrund ihres – wer weiß gar nicht, was er ist – Präsident und Geldgebers finanziert, der das hauptsächlich stemmt, der da so ein bisschen Probleme hat mit seiner Firma, auch so ein bisschen finanziell am knappsten sind inzwischen.
Jetzt ist das ganze Jahr schon acht unfassbare Jahre her. Jens, kannst du dich noch erinnern, wann das Thema bei euch in der aktiven Fanszene von Borussia Dortmund aufgeploppt ist? Denn ihr wart eine der ersten Fankruppierungen, die gegen Rasenballsport Leipzig demonstriert hat in Stadien, obwohl man damals noch ganz, ganz viele Ligen voneinander getrennt war.
Ich meine, das war in der Tat auch schon 2005 Thema hier, weil es relativ – also es ist natürlich auf persönlicher Ebene und mich betrifft es jetzt zum Beispiel nicht, aber es gibt halt Verflechtungen nach Salzburg und dieses Schicksal in Salzburg hat uns halt auch alle irgendwie so ein bisschen erreicht und mitgenommen. Und wir waren, glaube ich, zum Teil gab es auch Leute bei uns, die dann an der Neugründung mitbeteiligt waren in Salzburg und so weiter. Und es gab viele, viele, viele Besuche in der Anfangszeit. Das ist, glaube ich, mittlerweile ein bisschen eingeschlafen, weil der BVB dann selber ein bisschen erfolgreicher wurde und man nicht mehr so viel Ersatzbefriedigung brauchte, weil die Samstage dann relativ langweilig waren. Und deshalb war durch diese Salzburg-Geschichte einfach Red Bull bei uns allen auf dem Schirm. Und das wurde, glaube ich, von vornherein irgendwie kritisch begutachtet und dann entsprechend auch mitgenommen. Ich erinnere mich noch, ich war mal – ich habe Familie in Leipzig und bin dann sogar irgendwann mal auf dem Weg zum Besuch da vorbeigefahren, habe mir das angeguckt und war total erstaunt. Oder, ja, wenig erstaunt, aber so ein bisschen angeekelt ist auch das falsche Wort. Aber ich fand das negativ beeindruckend, dass Red Bull da direkt so einen riesigen Kanister hingestellt hätte, so ein Glasbaukasten, wo wirklich alles verglast und überall diese rote Bulle drauf war kurz nach der Übernahme an diesem wirklich alten, paarhundert-Mann-Stadion, was der SSV Markranstädt hat. Ich habe dann auch ein paar Fotos gemacht und wurde dann von einem Ordner zurückfotografiert. Das waren ziemlich lustige Geschichten, weil die damals schon, zumindest regional, sehr darunter litten, dass die Leute damit nicht einverstanden waren. In Dortmund war das dann entsprechend durch die Salzburger Geschichte schon von vorne rein Thema. Ich wünsche mir im Nachhinein, dass das auch beim DFB so gewesen wäre.
Ja, über die Rolle des DFB werden wir noch sprechen. Der SSV Mark-Granstädt hat das direkt nach der Lizenzübernahme schon gemerkt. Der Rasen wurde mit Säure verunstaltet. Es gab, glaube ich, Farbbeutelwürfe und noch anderes. Da hat man sofort die negativen Auswirkungen gespürt. Aber Jens, eine Sache würde mich noch interessieren. Warum findest du es gar so negativ, wenn jemand, der einen Verein übernimmt, einen tollen Glaskasten hinstellt? Haben dich die roten Bullen drauf gestört als Sponsorenlogo oder generell?
Es war so unnatürlich.
Ist es nicht etwas Gutes, wenn die dann auch gleich investieren?
Ja, aber es war ja ein Glaskasten. Ich weiß gar nicht, was da drin war. Aber es passte so gar nicht. Ich war ja da am Stadion und es war so ein bisschen weltliche Umgebung und eigentlich ganz schön schnuckelig. So ein Groundhopper würde sich freuen.
Was ist denn eine weltliche Umgebung?
Ja, so Bäume und das ist so ein bisschen auf dem Land. Wald. Und es ist eigentlich ganz niedlich da. Und dann steht da dieser wirklich, ja dieser Red Bull Klotz, dieser Glaskasten mit dem roten Bullen in dunkelblau und mit diesem gelben Kreis und so. Und es passte nicht. Es war fremd. Es war künstlich.
Ein UFO, das gelandet war.
Das war sie. Und das war halt einfach so, weiß ich nicht. Es war auch einfach von der Ausstattung. Das war ein Fünftligaklub und du kommst da hin und denkst, okay, hier geil ist altes Stadion und dann steht da so ein hochmodernes irgendwas am anderen Ende des Spielfelds. Das passte einfach nicht. Das war unnatürlich. Ich glaube, das ist bei mir persönlich auch einer dieser größten Kritikpunkte an diesem gesamten Konstrukt. Neben dem Marketingfaktor einfach dieses unnatürliche Aufblähen, weshalb, glaube ich, in Dortmund auch mit Hoffenheim schon immer so ein bisschen Problem bestand, da wurde ja auch einfach sehr viel Geld reingesteckt, was dieser Verein niemals hätte erwirtschaften können aus eigener Kraft.
Weil du das Logo schon erwähnt hast, das ist ganz interessantes Logo von Rasenballsport, wurde vorerst nicht genehmigt und dann hat man es einfach als Sponsoren- Logo ganz dick auf die Brust gemacht, noch viel, viel größer, als man es eigentlich verwendet hätte. Eine typische Red Bull Lösung, wenn ihr mich fragt. Später wurde es mit leichten Änderungen durchgewunken. Über das Logo werden wir dann auch noch sprechen, wenn es dann auch um den Aufstieg geht und wenn dann auch die DFL irgendwann mal die Lizenz verteilen musste und nicht nur erstmal nur der Fußballverband der Region. Jetzt haben wir ganz viel über den Einstieg, den Beginn von Rasenballsport Leipzig gesprochen, auch schon mehrfach diesen schönen Namen in den Mund genommen. Das ist auch noch eine eigene Geschichte, die wir noch aufrollen können später. Aber wollen wir jetzt mal kurz auf die sportliche Entwicklung gucken? Und da hätte ich gehofft, Matthias, dass du uns da so ein bisschen durchführen kannst im Schnelldurchlauf. Wie waren denn die ersten Jahre sportlich von Leipzig?
Super erfolgreich, nur Erfolge.
Da habe ich aber anderes gelesen. 4 Jahre Regionalliga, 3 Jahre Regionalliga?
Ja, es gab so das erste Jahr, das war halt so dieses 5. Liga, Oberliga Jahr und das Konzept war relativ, also das war ja sehr aus dem Boden gestampft. Es gab ja nicht viel Vorlauf, weil sie sind da irgendwie, glaube ich, im Mai irgendwann angekommen, Juni, und haben dann irgendwie aus dem Nichts irgendwie so eine Mannschaft versucht, Tor zu zimmern und das war halt so, okay, wir graßen mal irgendwie sämtliche Leute über 30 ab, die irgendwo vielleicht gerade keinen Vertrag haben und die man holen kann. Und das war dann halt so die Ingo Herd, kennt man vielleicht, oder einen Klesener, der, glaube ich, mal Bescheid gespielt hat, Lars Müller, der muss doch mal, war der nicht mal in Dortmund? Und da gab es halt so einige Leute, die man dann eher aus dem älteren Bereich geholt hat, so viel Erfahrung geholt. Und ja, die haben dann mit einem Verwalter als Trainer, Timo Vogel damals, der war in der Situation, dass er vorher Trainer beim SSV Markranstädt war und tatsächlich übernommen wurde, womit eigentlich niemand gerechnet hat. Der durfte dann die Mannschaft zum Aufstieg führen, der, glaube ich, nach 22 von 30 Spieltagen klar war. Und das war eigentlich eher so eine Saison. Die erste Saison hat man ja noch in Markranstädt gespielt tatsächlich und nicht in Leipzig, da hat man nur die Derbys in Leipzig gespielt. Da gab es ja vier gegen FC Sachsen und Block. Und das war halt eher so eine Saison, die auch relativ schnell, so sage ich mal, an der Öffentlichkeit vorbeigezogen ist oder an der Wahrnehmung der Öffentlichkeit. Die ersten Spiele waren noch ganz interessant, da sind die Leute noch rausgefahren, weil was war das Neue? Und irgendwann haben sie sich dann auf einem Zuschauerschnitt wahrscheinlich von, ich weiß nicht mehr, 800, 900 Leuten eingepegelt, weil es sportlich einfach völlig irrelevant war. Und die tatsächlich wenig Strahlkraft hatte, da irgendwie in einem Dorf 20 Kilometer vor Leipzig zu kicken. Außer man ist Groundtopper. Und das war halt der Aufstieg. Und dann gab es halt so, nach diesem Aufstieg war inzwischen war ja die Marbeyersdorfer quasi das, was dann später Ralph Rangnick wurde. Derjenige, der dann Salzburg und Leipzig quasi managen sollte parallel. Und dann gab es halt so ein bisschen so einen Wechsel in der Strategie, sage ich mal, der Spielerverpflichtung. Also eher auch wieder junge Spieler holen, Perspektive ins Team holen. Da kam dann ein Daniel Frahn damals sehr jung, ein Karsten Kamlok sehr jung. Also da gab es so ein paar – Stefan Kutschke ist damals auch gekommen – da gab es so ein paar Leute, die relativ jung waren. Und wo man geguckt hat, dass man sich für auch damals relativ viel Geld aber eher in einem unteren Alterssegment verstärkt. Und das war jetzt so das im ersten Jahr das große Problem, das erste Jahr Regionalliga war das große Problem, dass du, du hattest 50 Prozent der Mannschaft, die war irgendwie so 30 und älter. Und die anderen 50 Prozent war irgendwie zwischen 20 und 23. Und das war halt so, dazwischen gab es dann irgendwie drei Spieler, die das vermitteln sollten, aber das nicht hinkriegten. Und das, Thomas Ora war damals Trainer, der hatte das irgendwie, war es jetzt auch nicht derjenige, der solche Situation geschickt managt. Und deswegen war das eigentlich so, ja, kann ich sagen, von Anfang an zum Scheitern verurteilt, aber das war schon eine Konstellation, die, wenn man so mit den Leuten gesprochen hat, damals nicht funktionieren konnte und die ja relativ schnell gescheitert ist, auch mannschaftsintern, vom Klima her, von der Hierarchie her. So, und dann gab es, weil Misserfolg immer bedeutet, alle rauszuschmeißen, hat man dann Peter Pakowold. Ja, es war es damals tatsächlich noch so ein bisschen, es gibt diese Geschichte von Peter Pakowold, dass er dann irgendwann mal mit Dietrich Mataschitz weintrinken war und Mataschitz war begeistert und den wollte er dann als Trainer haben, aber intern wollte Dietmar Beiersdorfer auch gerne über den Trainer mitbestimmen und Thomas Linke, der zu der Zeit Sportdirektor in Leipzig war, dann einen installiert. Die hätten auch gerne ein bisschen was mitgesagt und kriegten dann aber Peter Pakowold und das hieß dann, irgendjemand sitzt dann kurz zum Hebel. Und die sehr unkluge Entscheidung damals war, dass man irgendwie die gesamte Struktur, die man sich aufgebaut hatte, über so einen Chef, Dietmar Bayersdorfer, der diesen Fußballbereich als Komplex verantwortet und irgendwie versucht, Dinge anzuschieben, dass man dann so diese übergeordnete Struktur mal eben von jeden Tag auf den anderen komplett kickt. Und dafür halt so einen Peter Pakowold Alleinherrscher-Trainer in Leipzig installiert, der sich dann irgendwie so einen Alibi-Sportdirektor noch mitbringt und dann irgendwie versucht, sein Ding zu machen. Und das war halt von so einer ganzen Strukturidee, war das, ich sag mal, überspitzt gesagt von Anfang an ziemlich hirnrissig, aber das wurde halt so durchgezogen. Und der Effekt war halt, dass man dann auch im zweiten Jahr mit einer diesmal zumindest alterstechnisch ganz gut ausbalancierten Mannschaft nicht aus der Regionalliga aufgestiegen ist. Und dann kam halt das dritte Jahr Regionalliga, das ist dann 2012 gewesen. Und da kam Leipzig zugute, dass es in Salzburg ziemlich Stress gab und dort irgendwie die ganzen Strukturen über den Haufen geworfen wurden und Trainer weg und was machen wir jetzt Neues? Und dann kam dann halt Ralf Rangnick offensichtlich ins Visier, den man sich dann irgendwie geholt hat mit dem Versprechen, dass er Salzburg und Leipzig gleichzeitig machen kann. Und weil vorher war tatsächlich die Idee nicht, weil Packold ja tatsächlich so ein bisschen guten Draht zum Matthas Schütz hatte, war eigentlich nicht die Idee, Packold abzuschießen, sondern mit ihm in eine 2. Regionalliga-Saison zu gehen. Und als Rangnick dann installiert war, war relativ schnell klar, dass er in seiner Art natürlich bei beiden Vereinen keinen Stein auf dem anderen lässt und tatsächlich die Leute installiert, die fußballerisch das umsetzen, was er sich vorstellt. Und da wusste man, wenn weniger Stunden als Rangnick da war, dass das nicht Packold sein wird.
Wusste das Packold dann auch innerhalb weniger Stunden?
Ich glaube, er hat sich noch so ein bisschen geziert und gesagt, mit mir hat noch niemand geredet, aber ich glaube, er hat auch die Pressekonferenzen von Rangnick in Salzburg gesehen und wusste sehr schnell, dass das Thema durch ist und war dann immer noch hinterher pikiert, dass ihm die Kündigung nicht persönlich mitgeteilt wurde, etc. Weil es gab so ein paar Geschichten.
Moment mal, hat Ralf Rangnick über SMS Schluss gemacht, oder was?
Ich glaube, er hat es über Mathe-Shits ausrichten lassen. Das war eine Geschichte, wo dann Pacult immer gesagt hat, er hätte doch persönlich mit mir reden sollen. Und das hat er nicht gemacht. Und das nimmt er dem Rangnick noch heute übel. Und das war das löwische Modell der Entlassung von Rangnick. Nicht ausgesprochen, aber trotzdem entlassen. Genau, und das war halt so der Beginn dessen, wo tatsächlich wieder eine Struktur hergestellt wurde, nachdem Bayersdorfer irgendwie schon über einem Jahr her war. Also du hattest diese Figur Rangnick als übergeordnete Person, der eine Strategie umsetzen soll und umsetzt. Und du hattest dann auf so einer unteren Ebene Leute, die an dieser Strategie arbeiten konnten, aber auch tatsächlich im Hintergrund die entsprechenden Leute hatten, die ihnen helfen konnten. Wir hatten unter Thomas Ohr irgendwie einen dreiviertel Jahr lang keinen Sportdirektor und Thomas Ohr stand hier irgendwie rum und musste irgendwie mit allem umgehen und er hätte dringend einen Sportdirektor gebraucht und man hat ihm aber keinen gegeben, weil man sagte, das schaffst du schon alleine so. In der Struktur war es nicht gestimmt. Das gab es bei Rangnick halt nicht. Der war präsent, der hat irgendwie die Sachen angeschoben und der, als wenn irgendwie klar war, der braucht was, dann hat er das hingestellt. Und von daher, das war dann so dieser Moment, wo Alexander Zorniger mit der Mannschaft durch die Regionalliga, ich glaube ungeschlagen, durchmarschiert ist und sich dann in knappen, aber auch ungeschlagenen Spielen gegen Lotte durchgesetzt hat. Die Kurzzusammenfassung bis zur dritten Liga, weil dann geht es halt langsam in die DFB. Oder soll ich noch weitermachen?
Ist das richtig, wenn man sagt, dass das, was wir jetzt sportlich von Rasenball-Sport Leipzig sehen in der ersten Liga, ist ja ein ganz eigenes Stil des Fußballs und hat auch viel mit Attributenzutun, die man auch der Marke Red Bull anheften kann. Also das wirkt schon nah beieinander. Ein sehr schneller Fußball, überfallartig, viele Sprints, sehr offensiv, sehr aggressiv, spielfreudig und so weiter. Würdest du sagen, das ist tatsächlich auch alles erst mit Rangnick gekommen oder war das vorher schon angelegt und bloß nicht gut umgesetzt?
Nee, das war vorher überhaupt nicht angelegt. Das war vorher, also Packold ist so ein klassischer 4-4-2, spielt den beide auf dem Flügel und dann gucken wir, dass jemand die Linie runterrennt, Trainer gewesen. Sehr, sehr schwierig anzusehen. Thomas Oral hat vielleicht der eine oder andere in den letzten Jahren doch verfolgt. Karlsruhe SCF ist von Frankfurt. Ist jetzt in vielerlei Hinsicht auch nicht wirklich der perfekte Trainer. Er hat das irgendwann so ein bisschen rausgehabt, sich auf Regionalliga einzustellen. Er hat dann so ein bisschen durchaus robusten Regionalliga-Fußball spielen lassen, was dann irgendwie am Ende der Saison ganz gut funktionierte, wo er dann auch noch den Sachsenpokal gewonnen hat. Aber das war auf jeden Fall nicht angelegt. Ich tue mir schwer, das irgendwie als Red Bull-System zu tun. Ich glaube, das ist eher Zufall, dass man diese Analogie bilden könnte. Aber diese Spielweise war nie angelegt im Verein. Die kamen tatsächlich mit Rangnick.
Interessant, dass das nicht von Anfang an deckungsgleich war mit der Ostrichtung. Wir werden später über Red Bulls Sponsoring auch so generell sprechen. Ich dachte immer, das wäre ein Ziel gewesen, dass man Fußball auch neu definiert. Aber andererseits hat das auch nicht zusammengepasst, damit, dass Franz Beckenbauer und Dietrich Mateschitz wesentlich in seiner Fußballstrategie beraten hat. Irgendwie habe ich diese beiden Welten sowieso in meinem Kopf nicht zusammenbekommen.
Nee, aber das ist ja auch tatsächlich – du hast ja in Salzburg – das habe ich ja vorhin schon gesagt – diese langen Jahre, wo man versucht hat, irgendwie Stars einzukaufen und irgendwie – überhaupt steht jemand mit dem Namen an der Linie und was weiß ich, Kurt Jarer, wer da alles trainiert hat. Das hat man in Leipzig genauso gemacht. Da standen erst mal drei Jahre lang Leute an der Linie, die irgendwie halbwegs einen Namen hatten oder wo man gegluckt hat, die sind die Richtigen für die Liga, weil die, die schon kennen. Und da war es so strategisch, fußballstrategisch nicht so richtig viel dahinter. Das war als eher so, ah, der ist verfügbar, den holen wir. Und der macht das auch. Also ich glaube, da fehlt da halt tatsächlich jemand, der wie gesagt so einen Rang legt, der in die Zeit, okay, das wollen wir, welche Leute brauche ich dafür? So und das gab es halt als Idee nicht, sondern da gab es, okay, welche Leute sind verfügbar, die holen wir. So und das ist halt schon ein extremer Umkehr in der ganzen Idee gewesen, wie man die Fußballvereine, letztlich war es ja unter Rang legt noch besser, wie man die aufstellt.
Okay, und jetzt dann Durchmarsch in die 2. Liga und wir sprechen jetzt im Jahr 2017 miteinander. Da hat es Leipzig dann auch schon in die 1. Liga geschafft. Und wenn ich richtig informiert bin, auch schneller als das ursprünglich geplant war.
Ja, wollte ich mal was fragen. Matthias, danke erst mal für die Darstellung, weil ich glaube, dieser Rang legg Wechsel, also was der da reingebracht hat und diese Attribute, die Max aufgezählt hat, das sind ja für mich eigentlich Attribute von Rang legg Fußball. So attraktiver, ballorientierter Offensivfußball, wobei Rang legg das ja selber eigentlich als eine Defensivvariante versteht, vorne früh drauf zu gehen. Und dann eben so junge, entwicklungsfähige, hungrige Spieler, das hat er ja mit abstrichenden Ulmen, aber auf jeden Fall in Hoffenheim auch schon so gemacht, haben die dann, weil das so gut lief, den Prozess beschleunigt, weil ursprünglich wollten sie ja mal erst dieses Jahr aufsteigen, wäre okay gewesen. Und haben die irgendwann angefangen, schon dann im Laufe dieser Drittligasaison zu sagen, okay, nächstes Jahr nehmen wir ein bisschen mehr Geld in die Hand und weil jetzt beim Schritt in die Erste Liga weiß ich, dass sie dann, dass sie dann noch mehr Geld ausgegeben haben, als sie eigentlich wollten. Aber das habe ich gar nicht so auf dem Schirm, ob das damals bei dem Übergang in die Zweite Liga schon quasi beschlossen wurde, dass man das jetzt alles ein bisschen schneller macht.
Ja, also grundsätzlich reden wir über Ralf Rangnick. Und selbst bei allem, was er nach außen sagt, war glaube ich in jeder Liga klar am Anfang der Saison, er würde gerne am Ende aufsteigen. So egal, wie viel Understatement man reingepackt hat und egal, wie viele reale Geschichten in dem Understatement tatsächlich auch drinsteckten, das war glaube ich aus Rangnick Perspektive immer klar, okay, ich bin im Jahr eigentlich aus der Liga raus. Und es gibt von Josef Pausen die schöne Geschichte, der irgendwie gesagt hat, der wurde in die Dritte Liga geholt mit der Ansage, nächstes Jahr spielen wir Zweite Liga. Und das war tatsächlich bei recht geringen Investitionssummen am Anfang der Dritten Liga noch. Da war jetzt nicht so, dass da irgendwie die ganz großen Kracherverpflichtungen geholt wurden. Das ist ja quasi mit dem Regionalligateam hochgegangen in die Dritte Liga und hat dann Pausen dazu geholt. Kimmich hat dann irgendwie gespielt als Leier, der war aber als Achtung. Aber du hattest jetzt nicht wirklich ein Team, wo du sagst, das muss jetzt aufsteigen. Und das war aber so das Versprechen, mit dem Rang Nick dann Pausen geholt hat. Er hat gesagt, okay, nächstes Jahr spielen wir Zweite Liga. Ist dann aufgegangen, ja. Aber es war eigentlich tatsächlich eher so, wo man im Nachhinein denkt, oh, das ist auch tatsächlich ordentlich. Und ich glaube, so diese Geldpanik oder so dieser Versuch, irgendwie Dinge über Geld, über sehr viel Geld zu lösen, über mehr Geld als vorher, war tatsächlich in der ersten Winterpause der zweiten Liga, wo man dann irgendwie so auf Platz Vier stand oder Platz Fünf so noch ein bisschen in Reichweite, der Aufstiegsplätze, und wo man so ein bisschen all-in gegangen ist und gesagt hat, oder da irgendwie so 20 Millionen aus dem Fenster geschmissen hat. Also tatsächlich aus dem Fenster geschmissen, weil von den irgendwie Vieren, die man geholt hat, ist bloß noch Emil Forsberg übrig geblieben. Und das war so ein Moment, wo man, wo sie tatsächlich so ein bisschen von der Linie vorher abgewichen sind, schon auch mit so einem Ziel, den Durchmarsch zu erzwingen, an einer Stelle, wo es eigentlich keinen Sinn gemacht hat, den zu erzwingen. Also es war halt so, man hatte eine gute Saison gespielt, das Team funktionierte ein bisschen, man hat schon gesehen, wo irgendwie so Stellstrauben sind, aber es gab jetzt irgendwie nicht so einen Grund, bis so diese ganze Hierarchie so zu, komplett zusammenbrechen zu lassen. Das war letztlich ja auch so das Thema dann in der Rückrunde, nachdem dann Zorniger weg war, dass so diese Hierarchie der Mannschaft zusammengebrochen ist, dass so die alten Spieler sich irgendwie zurückgesetzt fühlten, fragen und so und auf der Tribüne saßen und aber die neuen Oma Damari, Jordi Rehner, über die keiner mehr redet, oder den Rodney, die das gar nicht auffangen konnten. Also die waren gar nicht in der Lage, irgendwie diese Situation anzugehen und zu sagen, okay, wir sind jetzt hier die neuen Macher des Teams, weil die waren einfach nicht an der Stelle. Und deswegen war es dann strategisch völlig sinnlos, die 20 Millionen da rauszupulbern. Also gut, man hat dann irgendwie inzwischen Amy Forsberg hat man behalten und den für relativ billig Geld kriegt im Vergleich zu dem, was er wahrscheinlich heute wert ist. Aber ansonsten war das in dem Zeit schon eher Panik, ein bisschen Panikkaufmäßig. Also tatsächlich untypisch im Vergleich mit den anderthalb Jahren zuvor, wo man relativ gezielt und auch gut funktionierend Leute zuholt hat.
Weißt du, woran mich das ganz krass erinnert, Matthias? An die Situation in Hoffenheim, wo man auch gesagt hat, ne, also wir verfolgen hier vor allem unseren regionalen Ansatz und mit jungen Spielern und jetzt gucken wir halt mal, was in der zweiten Liga geht. Und dann hat man, glaube ich, die ersten vier Spiele nicht so positiv bestritten. Das Transferfenster war noch offen und zack, waren Demba Bar und Obasi da. Für damals unglaublich, ich glaube auch insgesamt 20 Millionen. Also war damals waren das auch die Rekord-Transfers der zweiten Liga. Bis dann eben Leipzig noch umgekommen ist.
Und das Ganze auch noch – Kann man hier noch Carlos Eduardo für richtig viel sagen?
Ja, richtig, genau, Carlos Eduardo auch noch. Also kennen wir irgendwo hier dieses Muster, das man dann in eine Panik verfällt, die ich aber deutlich in Anführungszeichen setzen möchte. Da sieht man schon, dass der Blick oder die Maßstäbe, in denen Leipzig denkt, einfach andere sind. Weil natürlich ein Aussteiger, der auf Platz vier oder fünf in die Winterpause geht, der dann unzufrieden ist, der muss einen anderen Planungshorizont haben als ganz, ganz viele andere Aufsteige, die es so gibt.
Ja, ich glaube, es war halt auch so der letzte, dieser letzte Funken, wo so dieses Verhältnis zu Rangnick Zorniger, was vorher schon so ein bisschen auch kompliziert war, weil sie unterschiedliche Ideen hatten, wie sich der Verein entwickelt, dann so irgendwie so endgültig nochmal geknackst ist, weil das waren tatsächlich vielleicht bis auf Vorspec alles nicht Zornigerspieler. Also ja, Ante Rebitsch hat die schöne Geschichte erzählt, dass er nach Leipzig gekommen ist und in der Kabine gesessen hat. Dann kam Alexander Zorniger und hat ihn gefragt, wie er denn ist, weil er von der Verpflichtung offensichtlich nicht wusste. Das war aber nicht in der Winterpause, das war schon am Anfang der Saison. Den hat man ja damals quasi so als Leihgabe dazu gekriegt zum Compeertransfer. Und es ist dann schon irgendwie so ein deutliches Zeichen, da hat offensichtlich in den ganzen Abläufen und Ideen und was passiert, denke ich, gerade nicht so richtig viel gestimmt in der Zeit.
Sind ja Dortmunder Verhältnisse, hätte ich fast gesagt, Jens. Entschuldigung, ich musste mir bei Auf der Ohren so viele Stiche dahin anhören, da wollte ich mir diesen einen Stich jetzt hier rausnehmen.
Das ist voll okay. Ich bin nur bei dem Namen Marvin Compeer gerade so ein bisschen hängen geblieben und dann habe ich nochmal zurückgedacht an das, was du gerade sagtest von wegen, das war alles irgendwie gezielt und nicht mit viel Geld und dann denke ich an Namen wie Marvin Compeer oder Davy Selke, die aus der Bundesliga in die zweite wechseln und das haben sie nicht getan, weil die sportliche Perspektive besser war.
Davy Selke war tatsächlich erst nach dem 2. Jahr, also im 2. Jahr. Ja gut, aber auch auf Marvin Compeer, der glaube ich Nationalspieler war, oder? Nein, zu der Zeit nicht, aber der kam ja von Florenz, wo er auf der Bank gesessen hat und dann irgendwie da weg wollte. Das war zum Anfang der 2. Jahre, ich glaube so auch relativ spät in der Transferperiode im Sommer, weil dann irgendwie doch noch ein Verteidiger fehlte. Und das war tatsächlich zu der Zeit auch so ein bisschen so vom Alter her so ein untypischer Transfer, weil er auch schon 28 war oder so und man dann doch 3 Millionen gezahlt hat. Und ja, das war auch ein Transfer, der hat auch relativ lange nur wenig gespielt unter Zorniga, weil er irgendwie das vielleicht auch nicht sein idealer Transfer war. Aber ja, klar, ich bin auch der Letzte, der wegdiskutiert, dass Geld investiert wurde. Ich sag nur, dass es bis zu dieser Winterpause nicht so eine Form gab von, wir müssen jetzt hier irgendwie auf Teufel kommen raus, Leute aus Salzburg und irgendwo holen, damit wir irgendwie diesen Durchmarsch schaffen. Bis zu dieser Winterpause war das alles ok, auch der Sommer mit Comper, das hat Sinn gemacht, weil man braucht auf der Position jemanden und der kannte Rang nicht, der kannte das System, der konnte irgendwie als erfahrener Spieler irgendwie andere anleiten. In seiner internen Logik hat das schon alles gut funktioniert und er hat sich da ja ins Team auch gut eingepasst. Das war noch nicht ein Panik-Transfer. Die kamen dann erst im Winter, wo man dann so, ich sag's immer noch, Oma Damari für 7 Millionen Euro Gold hat, der glaube ich bis dahin eine halbe gute Saison in Österreich bei, ich glaube, Austria Wien hatte und ich glaube, die freuen sich immer noch darüber, dass sie 7 Millionen gekriegt haben.
Eines der wenigen Dinge, über das man sich bei Austria Wien freuen konnte in diesem Zeitraum. Dann kam auch die Phase, in der Ralf Rangel gesagt hat, er sucht noch nach einem weiteren Trainer, er will es eigentlich machen und er wurde dann Trainer und hat dann den Aufstieg geschafft und dann kommen wir schon in der ersten Liga an. Wie hast du die Phase erlebt?
Den Aufstieg in die erste Liga oder die zwei Liga, sagen die da hingeführt hat? Ja, eine sehr rangige Fahrt. Wie habe ich das erlebt? Ich glaube, das klingt dann irgendwie so alles recht schnell. Es ist auch so eine unwirkliche Geschichte gewesen. Also es war ja schon auch ein Jahr, wo man immer hinterher denkt, ja, die sind da so durchmarschiert, sind sie natürlich nicht, weil so auch relativ viele glückliche Sieger hatten. Gerade in der Hinrunde, wenn ich so an Führten denke, wo sie in der 89. den Ausweg kriegen und dann in der 91. noch gewinnen. Also es gab so mehrere Schlüsselmomente da drin und letztlich hattest du so einen klassischen Fall von, die Hinrunde war extrem gut und ich stand auf Platz eins zur Winterpause und dann hat sich so diese Rückrunde so ein bisschen gezogen und das war so ein Ewiges, da kam Nürnberg von hinten und dann aber zum Schluss haben sich dann Nürnberg und Leipzig dann so ein Schneckenrennen geliefert, wo dann irgendwie keiner mehr gewinnen wollte. Und man hat sich dann eher so zu diesem Aufstieg so hingemurkelt. Es gab so mehrere Chancen aufzusteigen und dann hat es dann doch irgendwie bis zum vorletzten Spieltag gedauert und es war irgendwie so – es war gar nicht so richtig euphorisch, glaube ich, lange, weil es einfach so diese Hinrunde zu überlegen war und in der Rückrunde sind dann so irgendwie diese seltsamen Spiele da in Freiburg, St. Pauli, Nürnberg etc. und es dann so ein Hinlaufen auf irgendwas, wo man irgendwie schon seit Ewigkeiten darauf gewartet hat war. Und ja, da fühlte sich glaube ich damals so ein bisschen seltsam an.
Ja, wobei ich das seit Ewigkeiten darauf gewartet habe, kurz relativieren möchte, da kannst du mit anderen Fans von Drittligisten sprechen, die warten da noch länger. Aber ich glaube, wir wissen, wie du es gemeint hast. In dieser Phase ist ja auch die mediale Berichterstattung immer größer geworden. Klar, wir sprechen jetzt hier schon über die zweite Liga und über eine Mannschaft, die mit hohen Investitionen dann eben versucht, in die erste Liga zu kommen. Und in dieser Phase hat zum nach meinem Dafürhalten auch die Berichterstattung über Proteste zugenommen von anderen Fans. Was waren denn das so für Spieler? Also wir haben ja zum Beispiel im Intro gehört Ewald Lienen, der sich damals dafür gerechtfertigt hat, warum St. Pauli nicht das Logo von Rasenballsport zeigen wollte, weil man eben keine Werbung für dieses Produkt machen wollte. Das ist ja nur ein Beispiel von vielen, wie in der zweiten Liga mit Leipzig umgegangen wurde.
Ja, nimmst du das von außen so wahr, dass das dann damals so in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung mehr ankam?
Also auf meinem Radar war es wesentlich mehr als noch in den Drittliga-Zeiten, wo ich ehrlich gesagt das Thema so nach dem zweiten verpassten Aufstieg dann so ein bisschen auf die lange Bank geschoben habe mental, nachdem das nicht gleich geklappt hat, hochzuspringen in die zweite Liga. Und ich habe das so wahrgenommen. Und würdest du eben sagen, da hat sich gar nicht so viel verändert?
Ja, wahrscheinlich aus so einer Leipziger Perspektive nicht viel, weil du hast wahrscheinlich auch schon in Rostock, da hat es ja die Geschichten in Rostock, was da dann so im Stadion hinten in der Halbzeitpause abging oder Halle, wo dann der Mannschaftsbus irgendwie eine Scheibe verloren hat. Also es gab ja vorher schon auch mal Geschichten, die zumindest regional Wellen geschlagen haben. Von daher ist das vielleicht so eine Wahrnehmung von außen, wo das dann noch mal mehr ankam oder mehr thematisiert wurde. Oder gab es ja dann diese Karlsruhe-Geschichte ja auch, wo dann irgendwie so diese legendäre Hotel besuchen, was dann da draus gemacht wurde.
Das musst du noch kurz den Hörern erklären, weil das ja nicht alle vor Augen haben.
Ich finde es schön, wie du die Hörer sagst, wenn du dich selber meinst.
Moment mal, das waren doch einfach nur zwei Leute, die da gepöbelt haben und danach wurden da Hooligans draus gemacht, die den Frühstückssaal gestürmt haben. Das ist doch die Geschichte, oder?
Ja, es gibt mehrere Versionen der Geschichte. Es waren auf jeden Fall nicht zwei, aber irgendwie 50, die da irgendwie vor dem Hotel standen. Und ja, sag mal, anwesend war, das Hotel besucht haben, unterschiedliche Geschichtspersonen mehr oder weniger rein wollten oder gar nicht rein wollten. Und daraus wurde dann so ein großer Angriff auf das Hotel, etc. gestrickt. Und die typische mediale, was ja bei RB immer recht auffällig ist, mediale Berichterstattung ist, dass sobald irgendwas jenseits des Sportlichen passiert, ist es halt immer ein Thema. Im Positiven wie im Negativen ist das halt irgendwas, was Schlagzeilen bringt und was dann über Tage erst mal so ein bisschen perpetuiert wird. Und da spielte damals auch Ralph Rangnick so ein bisschen eine Rolle, der dann irgendwie so vor dem Mikrofon vom schlimmsten Erlebnis ever oder irgendwas gesprochen hat und das noch so ein bisschen hochgeschaukelt hat. Und das tobte dann so ein bisschen über so ein paar Tage in sämtlichen Medien, wo dann jeder irgendwie was dazu sagen durfte oder nicht sagen durfte.
Ihr habt ja auch eine gewisse Routine dann in solchen kritischen Äußerungen und auch der Berichterstattung darüber bekommen. Aber jetzt möchte ich als Referenz nochmal Alex dazu holen, der ja bei Jens wissen wir, er hatte das Thema schon ganz früh auf dem Schirm, Andreas logischerweise auch. Alex, wie war es bei dir? Hast du es auch so empfunden, wie ich das so sage? In der zweiten Liga ging es dann mehr damit los, dass man das auch als nicht Leipzig-nahe Fan mitbekommen hat, was da passiert an Kritik?
Ja, auch da stimme ich dir zu, genau wie eben. Natürlich ist es da stärker in den Fokus der Öffentlichkeit gerückt. Hängt natürlich auch damit zusammen, dass das halt eine DFL-Spielklasse ist und dass RB Leipzig dann aus der OPPO des DFB sozusagen in die OPPO der DFL kam. Und natürlich hat man mitbekommen, den ganzen Streit, wenn wir ja noch darüber sprechen, den ganzen Streit um das Logo und die anderen Auflagen, die es da gegeben hat. Natürlich ist die zweite Bundesliga nochmal ganz anders im Fokus als die dritte Liga und insbesondere als die Regionalliga. Und klar hat es dann einfach Ereignisse gegeben. Matthias hat ja Karlsruhe schon angesprochen, die stärker präsent dann einfach waren in den Medien, aber sicherlich auch in den Fanforen. Karlsruhe war ja nicht nur die Geschichte mit dem Sturm oder auch nicht da aufs Mannschaftshotel, sondern da ging es ja auch um diese Geschichte, dass da die ganze Kurve irgendwie den Mundschutz getragen hat von den Karlsruhen und ein Transparent aufgehängt, auf dem drauf stand, die Gegend gerade schützt sich vor der Bullenseuche. Matthias selbst hat das damals ja auch kommentiert für Zeit Online, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, und ein paar Worte dazu verloren, wie das Ganze sozusagen ideologisch einzusortieren ist. Und ich erinnere mich da an mehrere Aktionen, die es gab. Heidenheim gab es, glaube ich, noch diese Geschichte mit den Geldscheinen, wo Matteschitz drauf zu sehen war, mit der Hakennase beispielsweise, September 2015, Union Berlin mit den Schädlingsbekämpfern, Schädlingsbekämpfer T-Shirts beispielsweise, Erzgebirge Auer mit dem Nazi-Vergleich. Und das häufte sich dann so ein bisschen. Vielleicht gar nicht stärker als in der dritten Liga, das kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau beurteilen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall stärker in den Fokus der Öffentlichkeit gerückt. Und das spielt natürlich auch eine Rolle, wenn es stärker wahrgenommen wird und reproduziert sich sicherlich auch nochmal selbst und verstärkt sich dann auch nochmal selbst, wenn solche Dinge passieren, die dann wesentlich stärker in den Medien wahrgenommen werden.
Ich glaube, dass das vielleicht auch so eine Rolle spielt, was mir einfällt, ist tatsächlich, dass sich ja dann so zur zweiten Liga auch diese Nein zur RB-Kampagne – jetzt mal inhaltlich abgesehen – aber die sich dann so gründete und die natürlich auch nochmal so ein bisschen so gerade am Anfang zur Öffentlichkeitswerbung und zu stadienübergreifenden Aktionen gemacht hat, was natürlich auch nochmal so ein bisschen so in Fokus nochmal so neu gesetzt hat, auch so ein bisschen ich sag mal für Medienvertreter interessant war, dass da irgendwie Sachen passieren, über die man berichten kann. Also die, ja, das gab es tatsächlich ja vorher auch nicht.
Na ja, und es ist einfach bedeutungsvoller natürlich. Das muss man ja auch dazu sagen. Ob jetzt eine Mannschaft in der dritten Liga spielt oder in der zweiten Liga ist einfach nochmal ein Unterschied. Das heißt, das Mehr an medialer Aufmerksamkeit ist da ja nur noch vollkommen gerechtfertigt. Ob das nun eine Steigerung war in der Zahl der Vorfälle oder nicht, finde ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt zweitrangig. Es ist definitiv präsenter gewesen, weil es auch eine höhere Spielklasse ist. Mehr Leute daran beteiligt sind, dass mehr Leute mitbekommen haben. Völlig normaler Vorgang, der an der Stelle natürlich dann auch ein ganz anderes Gewicht hat. Das steht für mich außer Frage und ist auch vollkommen legitim.
Es stimmt natürlich auch. Wenn ich nochmal drüber nachdenke, ist das schon auch so eine Form gewesen, diese neue Liga von… Da hat das ja tatsächlich auch so angefangen, aus meinem Gefühl heraus, dass so Fans sehen, auch so ein bisschen, ich sag mal, sie sich versucht haben, zu überbieten oder so auf andere Aktionen mit Aufgesprungen zu sein. Das hat es ja natürlich vorher in der Form nicht. Also ich sag mal so, der Darmstadt 98 war in der dritten Liga, da war eigentlich recht wenig an Protest bei den Spielen. Und das ging dann halt mit der zweiten Liga, die 9-2-RB-Kampagne kam ja dann auch aus Darmstadt sehr zentral, ging das auch dort los. Und das ist halt so dieser Sprung von, okay, wir sind der zweite Liga, wir müssen jetzt auch was dazu machen. Dann kommt die nächste Fansin. Okay, wie gehen wir mit dem Verein und wir müssen auch was dazu machen. Das ist ja dann auch so ein bisschen so ein Selbstläufer geworden, dass du eigentlich, ich sag mal, als gute Fanszene mit einem guten Ruf auch irgendwas dazu machen musst. Du kannst nicht irgendwie dich hinstellen und sagen, wir machen nichts dazu, weil dann schrei mal, warum macht ihr nichts dazu? Das gab ja dann auch so diese Seiten von, wir haben nachgezählt, wer hat projkottiert, wer nicht. Dann gab es halt diese Diskussion, ob wir projkottieren oder nicht. Das hat ja dann auch so einen gewissen Selbstläufer-Effekt manchmal.
Ja, ich glaube, da spielt auch ganz viel, in Anführungsstrichen, Arroganz der Fanszenen eine Rolle. Und vielleicht auch ein bisschen Blindheit, dass man sich einfach jahrelang nicht damit beschäftigt hat, weil es einen ja nicht betroffen hat. Und plötzlich stehen die halt bei dir in der Liga und du merkst, okay, kacke, die nehmen mir den Platz weg. Wenn es doof läuft, stecke ich jetzt ab, weil die jetzt hier sind. Und dann muss man sich halt damit auseinandersetzen. Und ich glaube, da waren halt viele Fanszenen vielleicht ein bisschen zu lange und haben sich so ein bisschen zu lange einfach passieren lassen, ohne sich damit auseinanderzusetzen und dann erst gemeckert, als es quasi schon zu spät war. Vielleicht auch ein Thema, was man jetzt fanszenenmäßig bei teuren Eintrittskarten oder sowas miterlebt, wo ja dann auch bei vielen jetzt irgendwie das Gefühl vorherrscht, also meiner Meinung nach, dass man eh nichts mehr machen kann, weil man halt einfach zu lange gewartet hat.
Ja, wir werden auch über die ganze Kritik der Fans, denke ich, später noch ein Wort verlieren. Da hat ja auch Alex schon ja hier auch schon an dieser Stelle angekündigt, dass er sich damit auch sehr auseinandergesetzt hat und ist ja auch ein Teil dieser ganzen Diskussion rund um RB Leipzig, wie die Kritik geäußert wurde und wie auch die Medien darüber berichtet haben. Aber wir stellen fest, nach kaum anderthalb Stunden sind wir jetzt in der ersten Liga angekommen. Rasenballsport hat das geschafft, was man sich vorgenommen hat, also eines von zwei Zielen. Das erste Ziel war der Erstliga-Aufstieg und das zweite Ziel war das Erreichen der Champions League. Und das sieht ja zumindest Stand heute, wo wir aufnehmen, im April 2017 auch sehr gut aus für Leipzig. Und das unterscheidet auch im Wesentlichen Leipzig von Salzburg übrigens, wo man dieses Ziel nicht erreicht hat, was auch seine Konsequenzen hat.
Wobei man da Salzburg glaube ich nicht so viel vorwurfen kann, außer halt diese Playoffs-Spiele. Da können wir jetzt glaube ich eher Richtung UEFA pöbeln, dass sich der österreichische Meister noch durch drei Playoff-Runden prügeln muss, während Deutschland demnächst vier Mannschaften fest qualifiziert sind. Aber hey, als Kritiker von Red Bull, ich freue mich. Alles gut. Hauptsache Salzburg ist nicht dabei gewesen.
Und damit sind wir angekommen beim interessanten Teil dieses Podcasts, noch interessanter als alles bisherige, was ihr gehört habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn jetzt wollen wir uns mal mit den verschiedenen Kritikpunkten an Rasenballsport Leipzig auseinandersetzen und die so in all ihren Facetten ergründen. Jeder soll die Möglichkeit bekommen, seine Meinung dazu loszuwerden. Und dann könnt ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen, eure eigene Meinung formen. Und einer der am häufigsten vorgebrachten Kritikpunkte am ganzen Konstrukt Rasenballsport Leipzig. Und da kann Jens vielleicht mal anfangen, das zu elaborieren, ist, dass Leipzig bzw. Red Bull diesen Verein nur dafür nutzt, um ihn als Marketinginstrument einzusetzen.
Ja, was soll ich da elaborieren? Du hast das doch wunderbar ausgeführt gerade. Mehr als diesen Satz braucht man ja auch nicht.
Ja, aber welche Dimensionen hat denn das für dich? Also was meinst du damit? Vorhin haben wir schon davon gesprochen, dass da ein UFO im Wald steht.
Ja, ich glaube, das wurde mir persönlich gerade auch nochmal bewusst, als du dieses gesamte Thema Ghana und New York und keine Ahnung was aufgeführt hast. Ghana zum Beispiel hatte ich gar nicht mehr auf dem Schirm. Das war mir schon komplett empfahlen. Brasilien und New York wusste ich. Ich sehe irgendwie keinen anderen Grund, weshalb man einen Verein wie Austria Salzburg, der fast ein Jahrhundert Geschichte hat, dermaßen einstampfen will, als dass man dann sagt, okay, wir wollen nicht nur Partner sein. Bei uns geht es darum, Red Bull oder nichts. Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie ich das groß elaborieren soll. Ich finde, das ist ziemlich offensichtlich, dass da halt so kompromisslos vorgegangen wird. Während sich andere Sponsoren im Fußball immer damit schmücken wollten, was der Verein für Erfolge hatte und dann auch so ein bisschen ein Geben und Nehmen entstanden ist, war es bei Red Bull halt nur Red Bull oder nichts. Der normale Weg eines Fußballvereins ist, es gibt 15, 20 Leute, die Fußball spielen und die werden irgendwann besser und dann werden die Leute ausgetauscht und die steigen immer weiter auf. Und irgendwann kommen halt Unternehmen, die sagen, hey, was ihr macht, das finde ich cool, ich gebe euch ein bisschen Geld, dann könnt ihr das noch besser machen. Und genau das war ja genau andersrum bei Red Bull. Bei Red Bull, die sind halt hingegangen und haben gesagt, okay, was würde ganz gut unsere Magenwerte vermitteln und womit würden wir international Aufmerksamkeit erregen, was ist der größte Sport der Welt? Hey, Fußball! Dann sollten wir uns doch jetzt eine Mannschaft suchen, die erfolgreich Fußball spielt und die sponsoren. Und genau das haben sie eben nicht getan, sondern sie haben sich dann eine richtig schlechte Mannschaft gesucht in einer Liga, in der der DFB keine Zukunft mehr hatte. Und haben da alles auf links gedreht und eben nicht eine erfolgreiche Mannschaft gesponsert, sondern mit ihrem Geld etwas, das vorher mittelmäßig erfolgreich war, einfach so weit nach oben geschoben, dass jetzt die Markensichtbarkeit da ist, die in der fünften Liga nicht da gewesen wäre oder die sie auch mit Salzburg nicht erreicht haben, weil das immer in der Champions-League-Qualifikation gescheitert ist.
Man kann es auch noch mal historisch so ein bisschen rahmen. Da gab es halt 2005, da haben sie ja nicht nur Austria-Salzburg übernommen, sondern da haben sie ja auch dieses Formel-1-Team übernommen und dann anderthalb Jahre später das nächste, weil da eine Lizenz frei wurde, da haben die sich einfach wirklich ganz gezielt entschieden, in diese sogenannten, in diese Biermärkte reinzugehen. Also diese klassischen Sportarten, wo sonst so Krombacher und sowas irgendwie so die klassischen Hauptsponsoren sind. Und ja, da ist ein ganz deutlicher Shift in der Marketingstrategie von Red Bull zu erkennen. Und da haben sie ja auch wirklich eine eigene Kompetenz aufgebaut in Sportmarketing. Sie sind ja, glaube ich, mittlerweile, wenn man mal so das, ich bin jetzt kein Experte, der da irgendwie quantitative Analysen macht, aber ich glaube, wenn man jetzt so global fragt, wofür ist Red Bull bekannt, dann ist das Getränk, glaube ich, ja gar nicht mehr irgendwie unbedingt die Nummer eins, sondern eben Stratosferensprung, Motorsport, Extremsport und eben jetzt auch Fußball. Und diese zwei Facetten – Sonntag 14 Uhr, Formel 1 und jetzt eben auch noch Samstag 15.30 Fußball oder 18.30 und bald auch Mittwoch 20.45 – das hat man vor zwölf Jahren als neues Ziel formuliert und ausgegeben und wird das jetzt also offenbar dieses Jahr erreichen dann.
Aber Marketing im Fußball kennen wir doch schon ewig. Alex, da kannst du uns bestimmt auch noch einiges dazu erzählen. An sich ist das ja nicht neu, dass sich ein Unternehmen an einen Fußballverein dranhängt und sich in dessen sportlichen Erfolg sonnen möchte.
Ne, das ist überhaupt keine neue Entwicklung, das ist völlig richtig. Da fällt einem natürlich immer zuallererst die Trikotwerbung ein. Und wenn man da so ein bisschen recherchiert, stellt man fest, dass es tatsächlich gar nicht Eintracht Braunschweig gewesen ist, wie viele glauben, wie ich auch geglaubt habe, vor Beginn der Recherche, die 1973 die Trikotwerbung in die Bundesliga gebracht haben, sondern das ist sogar noch ein paar Jährchen früher, war nämlich 1967 und da, wo Marzia Worms, die aufgelaufen sind bei einem Spiel gegen Alsenborn mit dem Schriftzug der Firma Caterpillar. Das Interessante finde ich daran, das ist natürlich auch eine amerikanische Firma. Und noch interessanter ist es, holen wir ein bisschen weiter aus, ganz bewusst sich dann mal anzuschauen, das hat dankenswerterweise so ein bisschen das Archiv von Marzia Worms erledigt oder jemand, der fürs Archiv von Marzia Worms arbeitet und das jedenfalls mal so ein bisschen nachgeschaut hat. Da hat jemand Pressestimmen zusammengetragen. Pressestimmen zusammengetragen nach diesem Coup von Marzia Worms, also mit dem Schriftzug der amerikanischen Firma Caterpillar aufzulaufen in der damaligen Oberliga. Und wenn man sich das anschaut, liest man so zwei, drei Zitate und hat dann das Gefühl, man ist eigentlich fast schon in der Jetztzeit, nur eben mit völlig anderen Namen. Also möchte einfach mal so ein paar, das habe ich mir extra rausgesucht, ein paar Sachen jetzt zitieren. Da heißt es zum Beispiel im trierischen Volksfreund, auch ein ganz wunderbarer Name für eine Zeitung im Übrigen, Sportkleidung kann über die Werbung für den Namen des eigenen Vereins hinaus nun einmal kein guter Werbeträger sein, denn als sich die sportlichen Erfolge während der ersten drei Spiele nicht einstellen wollten, bedauerte und belachte man nicht nur die Spieler, sondern zwangsläufig auch das Produkt. Der trierische Volksfreund stellt also in Frage, dass das irgendwie so eine gute Idee sein könnte. Bildzeitung hat geschrieben, das war dann allerdings schon nach dem Verbot des Deutschen Fußballbundes, muss man dazu sagen, dass es dann gegeben hat, hat die Bildzeitung geschrieben, der Albtraum, dass bald ein Werbekicker für Kaugummi gegen einen Reklametorwart für Zahnprothesen zum Elfmeter-Duell antritt, ist damit ausgeträumt. Das Verbot war zu erwarten. WM wird keine Nachfolger haben. Die Welt hat geschrieben, was in Worms geschah, ist die konsequente Entwicklung in der Welt der Athleten unserer Tage. Die Gefahr ist leicht benannt, verlangt eine Firma, die für Haarwuchspräparat wirbt, vom Trainer mit Erfolg, der großartige, aber glatzköpfige Linksaußen sei durch einen vollen Lockenkopf zu ersetzen. Dann hat sich der Sport prostituiert. Und andere, das ist ganz wunderbar natürlich, weil das auch so schön in die damalige Zeit passt und auch schon unfreiwillig komisch wirkt. Natürlich, Wormser Zeitung hat geschrieben, wer das will, also die völlige Kommerzialisierung des Fußballs, 1967, wer das will, muss es offen sagen und sich auch im Namen seines Vereins offen zu seinem Mäzenen bekennen. Bei Wormatia Worms denkt wohl niemand daran, in Zukunft unter Caterpillar Worms zu firmieren. Und irgendeine andere Zeitung hat noch geschrieben, irgendwann wird jemand kommen und einen Verein mit Haut und Ahnen besitzen. Also ich habe das jetzt deswegen auch so ausführlich zitiert, weil man daran sieht, es hat schon 1967, zumindest ein Teil der Medien, den Fußball untergehen sehen, weil eine Mannschaft Trikotwerbung hatte. Und danach kam, darauf hast du sicherlich abgestellt mit deiner Frage, danach kam Eintracht Braunschweig 1973 mit dem damaligen Großmerzen Günther Mast, Chef des Likörherstellers Jägermeister, bekanntlich. Und der hatte die Idee, das Logo seines Likörers auf das Trikot von Eintracht Braunschweig irgendwie zu bringen. Das ging aber nicht, weil der DFB damals gesagt hat...
Du bezeichnest Jägermeister als Likör, Entschuldigung.
Das hat man damals als Jägermeister nicht, das ist wahrscheinlich eher ein Schnaps, klar, aber das hat man glaube ich damals unter Liköre gefasst, so ganz allgemein, also als Oberbegriff. Aber eigentlich stelle ich mir darunter eher so Verporten vor oder sowas. Ich glaube, ich habe in meinem Leben allerdings noch nicht allzu viele Liköre getrunken.
Also für mich ist Jägermeister...
Wenn noch einer Energiedrinks sieht, aufzeigen, wenn wir gerade schon bei Getränken sind, Monster, wie heißen sie noch alle? Wenn wir schon Getränkewerbung machen, dann doch auch vollumfänglich, oder?
Wir kommen gleich zur Werbung. Für mich ist Jägermeister immer nur das gewesen, was man am Schluss auf der Party getrunken hat, wenn nichts mehr da war. Und diese Werbung mache ich gerne für Jägermeister, denn sie kommt von Herzen. Ihr habt einige meiner schlimmsten Kater verursacht, ihr Säcke.
So, der sogenannte Hirschtee. So heißt das in Schiedsrichterkreisen übrigens.
Ah, interessant.
Um mal ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen zu plaudern. Also, Mast wollte seinen Hirschen auf das Trikot von Eintracht Braunschweig bringen. Da hat der DFB gesagt, das geht nicht auf dem Trikot. Darf nur das Vereinslogo prangeln. Hinten natürlich die Rückennummer. Klar, vielleicht die Vereinsbezeichnung. Und dann hat Günther Mast und hat Jägermeister gesagt, dann machen wir das Ganze anders. Dann versuchen wir doch mal, das Logo, also unser Hersteller-Logo, ins Vereinslogo einfach zu bringen. Dann kann der DFB nämlich nicht anders. Also man sieht, man hat versucht, zu tricksen. Ich sage das auch natürlich mit Blick darauf, dass es ja auch gleich darum gehen wird, wie hat RB Leipzig getrickset bzw. wie hat RB Leipzig versucht, irgendwelche Vorschriften auszunutzen. Der DFB hat dann sein Veto eingelegt. Das ist dann zu einem Rechtsstreit gekommen, bis der DFB dann zugestimmt hat. Mast hat damals 100.000 Mark an den Verein gezahlt. Das war 1973 eine ganze Menge Geld. Und so kam es dann, dass Eintracht Braunschweig – das habe ich auch nicht vergessen – am 24. März 1973 gegen Schalke nur vier mit diesem neuen Trikot aufgelaufen ist. Der Schriftzugjägermeister durfte nicht mit aufs Trikot. Noch nicht, muss man sagen. Und das Schönste war – Stichwort Vorschrift – das Logo durfte nicht größer als 14 Zentimeter sein. Das waren die Vorgaben des DFB. Und tatsächlich hat der Schiedsrichter des damaligen Spiels Franz Xaver Wengenmaier ganz genau nachgemessen, hat noch telefoniert mit dem DFB und hat dadurch versucht, sich beglaubigen zu lassen, dass er das Spiel auch wirklich anpfeifen darf. So waren die Zeiten 1973. Später dann kaum jemand noch über Trikotwerbung gespielt. Also der Fußball hat das tatsächlich überlebt. Diese ersten Attacken der Kommerzialisierung. Aber man hat den Fußball auch schon wirklich untergehen sehen. Günter Maas ist ja später verschwunden. Also er wollte ja, wie man weiß, den Verein damals auch umbenennen. Der Verein sollte heißen Eintracht Jägermeister Braunschweig. Der DFB hat das dann damals verboten. Das ist bekannt, was glaube ich weniger bekannt ist, ist, dass das eigentlich in seiner Satzung damals gar nicht so klar gestanden hat. Und das wollte dann Günter Maas auch feststellen lassen, hat geklagt. Das ist auch so gewesen. Übrigens, dass die Rechtsinstanzen immer diejenigen gewesen, die sozusagen, wenn man das jetzt marktliberal betrachten will, sozusagen ein bisschen fortschrittlicher waren. Also gesagt, nee, das kann der DFB nicht einfach so verbieten. Wobei ihr Punkt war, das steht beim DFB gar nicht in der Satzung drin. Wir haben also kein Urteil darüber fallen wollen, dürfen die das jetzt mit Eintracht-Jäger Meister Braunschweig oder nicht, sondern nur gesagt, das steht überhaupt nicht in der DFB-Satzung drin, das hat der DFB dann geändert. Daraufhin wurde das Ganze dann verboten und wie man weiß hat Günther Maas den Club dann später auch verlassen. Das war 1986. Gut, die weitere Geschichte von Eintracht Braunschweig braucht man hier glaube ich nicht zu diskutieren. Dann gab es noch solche wunderbaren Volten wie 1987. Das ist eigentlich meine Lieblingsgeschichte im Zusammenhang mit der Kommerzialisierung des Fußballs. Die Älteren dürften sich noch daran erinnern, dass es damals den FC 08 Homburg gegeben hat, der tatsächlich in der Bundesliga gespielt hat aus dem Saarland. Die haben geworben für den Kondomhersteller London. Das widersprach den sittlichen Ansichten des Deutschen Fußballbundes. Deshalb hat er das damals untersagen wollte. Der FC Homburg hat das Beste gemacht, was man aus so einer Situation machen kann. Er hat einfach einen schwarzen Balken drüber geklebt. Das war natürlich quasi die Portion extra Werbung. Das ist dann auch wieder gekippt worden. Dann durfte der FC Homburg wieder für Kondome werben. Auf dem Trikot, wie gesagt, 1987. Also der DFB hat da immer so ein bisschen versucht, als Bremse zu wirken. Hat auch versucht, sich anbahrend oder auf Fortschreit der Kommerzialisierung so ein bisschen zu bremsen. Das Ganze ist dann immer so ein bisschen von den Gerichten korrigiert worden, von den Gerichten gekippt worden.
Von den nicht-Sport-Gerichten?
Nein, nicht von den Sportgerichten. Sondern von ordentlichen Gerichten. Denn vor die ist es dann natürlich gebracht worden. Das ist ja auch nicht ganz richtig. Ohne da jetzt schon um das vorwegnehmen zu wollen, muss man ja sagen, wenn man diese ganzen Stadien der Kommerzialisierungsgeschichte verfolgt. Ich habe ja nur drei Beispiele aus dem deutschen Fußball genannt. Man kann noch viel weiter zurückgehen und drüber sprechen, wie sich das Ganze so ausgeweitet hat, auch mit Bandenwerbung und so weiter, was dieses ganze Mesenatentum bedeutet. Wir können auch darüber sprechen, dass der Fußball sich natürlich auch andere Wege gesucht hat, später die Kommerzialisierung einfach auch ganz konkret zu organisieren, sprich Gründung der DFL, Ausgliederung der Vereine Kapitalgesellschaften, würde ich auch später ganz gerne das eine oder andere dazu sagen. Aber man hat immer sozusagen zum einen Formen gesucht, diese Kommerzialisierung voranzutreiben. Das hing natürlich auch immer damit zusammen, wie sich sozusagen der Kapitalismus und die Gesellschaft in ihm in dem Moment weiterentwickelt hat. Und es hat zu jeder Zeit, gab es immer Leute, die gesagt haben, nun ist aber das Ende der Fahnenstange fast schon erreicht. Nun ist der Fußball aber ganz fest in den Händen des Kommerzes, in den Händen der Unternehmen, in den Händen fußballfremder, fußballfeindlicher Gestalten vielleicht sogar. Er hat aber bis heute überlebt. Und in der heutigen Debatte frage ich mich manchmal, waren diese Änderungen alle schlecht? Waren sie nicht mindestens ambivalent? Und warum sagt man eigentlich heute, warum sagen die DRB-Kritiker heute, dass der Fußball jetzt aber ganz bestimmt untergehen muss und dass wir irgendwie nie wieder was von ihm haben werden, wie das irgendwie alles mal war? Und ob man diese guten alten Zeiten wirklich so glorifizieren sollte, steht natürlich nochmal auf dem anderen Blatt. Aber dazu werden wir vielleicht auch noch kommen.
Es war auf jeden Fall das erste Must-Have der Bundesliga-Geschichte, die Trikots von Eintracht Braunschweig unter Günter Mast. War ein Riesen-Gag, auf den jetzt keiner von euch eingesprungen ist. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Ich hasse jetzt alle von euch. Ich würde allerdings jetzt auch nicht unterstützen, Alex zu sagen, also du unterstellst jetzt natürlich auch den Kritikern von RB. Sie würden alle den Untergang des Fußballabendlandes heraufbeschwören. Das ja nun auch nicht. Also man darf ja schon auch kritisieren. Aber dieser Punkt ist schon interessant, denn wenn wir darüber sprechen, dass Rasenballsport Leipzig als Marketing-Instrument eingesetzt wird, dann sprechen wir von einer neuen Dimension. Und ich finde es ganz interessant, da auf Zeiten zurück zu gucken, wo man genau diese Formulierung schon mal verwendet hat, wo man gesagt hat, das ist jetzt aber wirklich was Neues. Und da gab es ja noch ein paar weitere Stufen, du hast es ja schon angedeutet. Und so ist es jetzt auch, dass man sagt, naja, die neue Dimension ist quasi, dass wir hier nicht einen existierenden Verein haben, an dessen sportlichen Erfolg ich meinen Unternehmen als Marketingmaßnahme dranpappe, sondern ich gründe einen Verein, ich kaufe mir eine Lizenz allein mit dem Ziel, um Marketing zu betreiben. Das ist ja die eigentliche neue Dimension.
Ja, und da an der Stelle würde ich die Frage stellen, ist das wirklich so eine neue Dimension? Also natürlich ist es organisationstechnisch gesehen ein Unterschied, überhaupt keine Frage, aber wenn man das irgendwie, wenn man es gesellschaftspolitisch oder auch gesellschaftskritisch vielleicht betrachten will, ist das dann wirklich so was komplett Neues? Also ändert das die Sache dann wirklich vollständig? Oder ist es nicht so, dass der Fußball natürlich einfach im Laufe der gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung insgesamt zur Ware geworden ist und auch wahrscheinlich gar nicht anders konnte? Also ich muss dazu sagen, wenn ich das jetzt sowieso konstatiere, geht damit zunächst mal überhaupt keine Wertung einher. Also keine Wertung, ob das jetzt gut oder schlecht ist, sondern das soll zunächst mal nur eine Feststellung sein. Also ist das, was heute verkauft wird? Und es ist ja so, dass die meisten Bundesliga-Clubs, auch in der zweiten Liga ist es ja vielfach so, ihre Profi-Abteilung ja längst ausgeliedert haben in irgendwelche Kapitalgesellschaften, GmbH und Cocagees und was der gleiche mehr ist. Also das ist ja ein Schritt gewesen, der so dann um die Jahrtausendwende und ein bisschen später vollzogen worden ist. Und damit ist ja auch eine neue Organisationsform gefunden worden.
Aber das ist ja ein anderes Thema, Alex. Also zu den Ausgliederungen und den Kapitalströmen und den Gesellschaftsstrukturen hinter den Vereinen kommen wir noch. Aber jetzt geht es ja tatsächlich darum, wir nehmen Fußball als Marketing. Und da hat er jetzt erstmal in der Ausgliederung nicht konkret mitzutun.
Also ich meine, um jetzt Ausliederungen, ich finde der BVB ist da immer dieses strahlende und negative Beispiel. Vielleicht kann ich da deshalb dann aus eigener Erfahrung ein bisschen was zu sagen. Auch wenn der BVB eine Kapitalgesellschaft gegründet hat, die er dann später auch an die Börse gebracht hat, um Geld einzunehmen, war es immer noch die Marke Borussia Dortmund, die da verkauft wurde. Und der Verein Borussia Dortmund, der dahinter stand und das Produkt Fußball, was im Fokus stand. Und das ist etwas, was für mich bei Rabah einfach komplett andersrum ist. Da war Fußball für mich immer nur Mittel zum Zweck. Und das ist dann für mich als Fußballfan, der wegen des Fußballs ins Stadion geht, irgendwie falsch. Das gehört sich so nicht. Also da wird dann mein, der mir heilige Sport quasi einfach Zweck entfremdet und einfach nur noch als Mittel zum Zweck der Werbung benutzt und nicht zum Selbsterhaltungstrieb. Natürlich, das muss ich mir als BVB-Fan in dem Kontext immer anhören, natürlich ist da einfach unfassbar viel Geld drin. Und natürlich hat auch der BVB Sponsoren. Der BVB hat auch hunderttausende Anteilseigner und drei davon sind sehr groß. Das ist die Signal Iduna, das ist Puma und das ist Evonik. Gibt es beim FC Bayern zum Beispiel ja auch. Da ist aber immer noch der BVB das, was unterstützt wird und nicht andersrum. Also wenn sich dann Evonik irgendwann entscheidet, ok, wir haben unsere Werbeziele erreicht, wir möchten nicht mehr weiter Partner des BVB sein, wird der BVB weiter existieren.
Aber da möchte ich gerne nochmal reingerätschen, weil ich möchte eins vorwegschicken. Ich bin natürlich auch Fußballfan und muss aber trotzdem die Frage stellen, wenn wir schon bei der gesellschaftlichen Dimension angelangt sind, inwieweit setzt man nicht auch in gewisser Weise natürlich einen höchst freiwilligen Selbstbetrug da auf. Wenn du jetzt sagst, für dich fühlt sich das falsch an und es geht dir immer noch um den Sport als solchen. Klar, ich gucke auch Fußball, weil ich den Sport sehen will. Aber wenn man sich jetzt mal die äußere Form anschaut, da frage ich mich halt, ob das wirklich so ein großer Unterschied sind. Der Unterschied ist, die meisten Profiklubs sind ja de facto selbst Konzerne geworden, Fußballkonzerne sozusagen. Diese Konzerne betreiben das, was man vielleicht Marxistisch als Profitmaximierung bezeichnen könnte. Und ihre Funktionäre sind ja letzten Endes nichts anderes als Unternehmer. Ich weiß, ich klingle jetzt selbst wie einer, aber ich will gar nicht wie ein Unternehmer klingen, sondern ich möchte einfach nur versuchen, der Sache auf den Grund zu gehen, einfach mal festzustellen, wem jubeln wir dazu, was gucken wir uns da eigentlich an? Und diese Fußballkonzerne, diese Unternehmer im Fußball verkaufen keine Getränkedosen, sondern die verkaufen die Ware Fußball und suchen sich eben zu diesem Zweck potente Sponsoren. Und sie brauchen, genau wie Red Bull und jedes andere Unternehmen, auch natürlich Kunden, die ihr Produkt kaufen. Einfach nur, wie gesagt, auf der Oberfläche rein äußerlich. Wenn jetzt diese Kundschaft aus Fans besteht, aus Fans, die davon ausgehen, dass der eigentliche Daseinszweck ihres Lieblingsvereins immer noch das Fußballspiel als solches ist und eben nicht die Kapitalvermehrung, das macht das Marketing dann natürlich einfacher, weil diese emotionale Bindung, und diese emotionale Bindung verläuft eben auch über den Verweis auf Traditionen und Fan-Kultur und so weiter, dass diese emotionale Bindung umsatzfördernd ist. Und das klingt natürlich total rational und kalt und herzlos. Und das ist natürlich das, was mich als Fußballspiel manchmal auch zerreißt. Aber die kapitalistische Vergesellschaftung, den Begriff möchte ich dann doch gerne mal einführen, hat ja eine Form von Totalität. Und da ist der Fußball natürlich schon drin eingeschlossen. Und deswegen bin ich eben nicht so sicher, ob es wirklich einen grundlegenden Unterschied gibt zwischen einem Fußballverein, der quasi zur Gewinnmehrung eines Unternehmens ins Leben gerufen worden ist, und einer Kapitalgesellschaft, deren Zweck die Vermarktung der wahre Fußball ist. Und ich glaube, dass es im Kapitalismus diesen Unterschied nicht wirklich gibt und dass deswegen die Gerichte natürlich auch entsprechend entscheiden, Stichwort-Bossmann-Urteil beispielsweise oder die Abschaffung der Restriktionen für Ausländer im Fußball. Ich glaube, dass es so eine Bestandsaufnahme überhaupt erst mal braucht, um sich klarzuwerden, wem jubelt man da eigentlich zu und ob es wirklich noch der eigentliche Daseinszweck ist, da wirklich Sport zu betreiben oder ob das nicht nur noch längst noch eine äußere Form ist. Das würde ich dann eben doch ganz gerne mal zur Diskussion stellen und deswegen denke ich, dass es den Unterschied so, dass der Unterschied so gravierend eigentlich gar nicht ist, wie es vielfach angenommen wird.
Ich glaube, die Frage, die du stellst, Alex, ist ja sozusagen, ist das jetzt das, was RB Leipzig darstellt im Vergleich zu den anderen Profiklubs? Ist das ein gradueller Unterschied? Also ist das einfach nur ein weiterer Schritt, so wie damals eben die erste Trikotwerbung und ein bisschen zur Kondomtrikotwerbung später? Oder ist das eben eine neue Qualität? Das hast du ja so ein bisschen verquickt auch zugespitzt mit der Frage, steht damit jetzt der Fußball als Ganter zur Disposition? Und dazu möchte ich kurz was sagen, weil ich glaube, die Grunddiagnose, die teile ich. Also dass man sagt, Fußball, Profifußball zumal, kann man sich in unserer Gesellschaft und wie das organisiert ist und auch in der globalen Wertschöpfungskette sozusagen gar nicht anders als als Ware vorstellen. Das unterschreibe ich sofort. Trotzdem würde ich nochmal hin auf die Ausgangsfrage, was macht jetzt RB eigentlich im Vergleich zu anderen Clubs? Wie kommt man zu einer Aussage, dass es ein Marketinginstrument ist? Dann würde ich sagen, dass diese Bestrebung der Kommerzialisierung, wo du ja auch schöne Beispiele geliefert hast, hier jetzt schon in dem Fall mal zumindest, was die empirische Basis angeht, was man sehen kann, am allerweitesten, wie wir das bislang kennen, zugespitzt ist. Also da ist ein Markt gesucht worden, ein Lehrermarkt, wo man sich positionieren kann. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute. Das hier machen. Ich habe die andere Richtung gedreht, fragen, naja, mag sein, dass es kein qualitativer Unterschied ist, aber was tut denn jetzt zum Beispiel in dieser Frage der Glaubwürdigkeit des Profi-Fußballs oder des globalen Fußballs an? Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Ich bin froh, dass die Leute das hier machen. Eigentlich alles immer nur die konsequente Fortführung sein. Wäre ja theoretisch auch die Chance, mal was ganz anderes zu machen. Und da bin ich nämlich eben so ein bisschen skeptisch, weil das ist ja immer so ein Argument auch von RB Leipzig und auch direkt aus der Red Bull-Zentrale. Wir machen das nicht nur anders, wir machen das besser, als wie das bisher läuft. Und da würde ich sagen, den Beweis müssen sie erstmal noch antreten, dass sie dieses Spiel, dass sie eben, wie gesagt, auf jeden Fall in einer neuen Form zugespitzt haben, besonders konsequent gemacht haben. Also ob das nicht am Ende dann auch wieder dysfunktional ist oder zu... Also inwiefern das jetzt wirklich was anders macht, da wäre ich sehr skeptisch.
Da bin ich ja vollkommen bei dir, was das betrifft. Und das ist besser daran, das würde ich auch gar nicht behaupten. Und wenn es um das Marketing-Instrument geht, also zunächst mal auf der reinen, deskriptiven Ebene, selbstverständlich ist das ein Marketing-Instrument. Ich glaube, das ist auch unstrittig. Dieses Spiel mit Emotionen und der verkaufsfördernde Aspekt von Emotionen sieht man halt natürlich bei anderen Clubs auch. Also dann nehmen wir doch mal Borussia Dortmund. Was ist denn echte Liebe? Anders als ein Marketing-Slogan. Was ist mir sein mir beim FC Bayern München? Anders als ein Marketing-Slogan.
Bitte, das ist eine Lebenseinstellung. So gehe ich hier einkaufen, so gehe ich hier über die Straße, mir sein mir. Für mich geht keine rote Ampel, natürlich nicht. Das Traurige ist, dass das wahr ist. Wenn du das hier dem Polizisten sagst, dann sagt er ja lurchig.
Das ist aber der Zusammenhang, das werde ich noch mal Marxistisch zwischen Warenform und Denkform nicht zu seminaristisch werden lassen, aber das geht einem dann natürlich so scheinbar. Und tatsächlich nicht nur anscheinend, sondern wirklich scheinbar in Fleisch und Blut über. Aber es ist natürlich im Prinzip nichts anderes. Und in sofern sehe ich hier tatsächlich eher einen graduellen Unterschied als einen grundsätzlichen. Und darauf würde ich dann schon bestehen wollen. Ich möchte auch gar nicht sagen, dass es gleich bei jedem Kritiker von RB Leipzig darum geht, immer aufs Ganze zu gehen und zu sagen, alle, die das irgendwie kritisieren, sehen gleich den Untergang des Fußballs heraufziehen. Dem ist sicherlich nicht so. Da habe ich ein bisschen polemisch zugespitzt. Stehe ich auch zu. Kommen wir sich ja auch noch mal später dazu, weil es mir natürlich gerade auch um so eine Stoßrichtung von Kritik geht und so eine Stoßrichtung der ganzen Angriffe geht, die ich da so wahrnehme, die ich ziemlich ungut finde und von denen ich vor allen Dingen sagen würde, das verändert es nun gerade mit Sicherheit nicht zum Besseren und das missversteht eigentlich, glaube ich, auch, was Fußball ist und missversteht das Ganze so auch als das reine, wahre und gute und unverfälschte und natürliche und authentische, dass es so, dass so wieder existiert, so nach dass das in irgendeiner Form auch so zu begrüßen ist, weil das einfach auch sehr, sehr roh ist und teilweise auch sehr gewalttätig ist. Also insofern tun sich da glaube ich schon gewisse Ambivalenzen auf und das das Ganze ausgerechnet jetzt kommt. Das wollte ich auch so ein bisschen damit damit sagen, habe ich aber nur indirekt getan, dass ausgerechnet jetzt so was zustande kommt, wie RB Leipzig, so ein Modell zustande kommt, das auch gesucht wird nach den entsprechenden rechtlichen Konstruktionen. Martin Kind hat sinngemäß mal gesagt, na ja, der Markt sucht sich eben seine Wege und die Marktteilnehmer suchen sich ihre Wege und wenn es da irgendwelche Hürden gibt, dann suchen sie natürlich noch Schlupflöchern, bis diese Schlupflöcher beseitigt werden. Und das gilt so ein bisschen eigentlich für alle Zeiten so. Natürlich wäre so ein Modell RB Leipzig in den 60er oder 70er Jahren überhaupt nicht denkbar gewesen, aber da war auch die Gesellschaft in einem völlig anderen Stadium, da war der Kapitalismus in einem völlig anderen Stadium, also das ist ja nicht ohne Weiteres übertragbar. Genauso wie die Ausgliederung in Kapitalgesellschaften Anfang der Nullerjahre, hat es ja dann glaube ich begonnen, Gründung der DFL etc. Das ist ja auch nichts, was irgendwie schon in den 60er, 70er Jahren hätte stattfinden sollen oder stattfinden können. Gleichzeitig muss man auch sagen, ohne jetzt hier noch ein neues Riesenfass aufmachen zu wollen. Auch die Gründung der Bundesliga ist ja so eine Geschichte. Der Profifußball, noch einen kleinen Schritt zurückzugehen, einfach weil es auch ein bisschen ideologiekritisch werden soll, wie ich finde. Die Gründung der Bundesliga ist ja bekanntlich 1963 erfolgt. Da hat es in vielen, vielen anderen Ländern natürlich längst Profiligen gegeben, nur in Deutschland nicht. Das ist natürlich noch ein Überbleibsel gewesen, davon, dass die Nazis den Profifußball für eine jüdische Erfindung gehalten haben, dass es lange Zeit völlig selbstverständlich war, zu sagen, man darf doch mit den Fußballspielen kein Geld verdienen. Fußballspiel ist eigentlich ohnehin eine Fußlümmelei, die irgendwie aus dem England kommt. Also es ist verfemt worden. Sport hatte um seiner Selbstwillen betrieben zu werden, selbstverständlich als Amateur und in erster Linie das Turnen. Nicht ohne Grund ist Turnfahrter Jahr an auch eine deutsche Erfindung extrem antisemitisch geprägt gewesen natürlich und kann jetzt ein paar Schlagwörter in den Raum werfen, aber das ist zu spät zur Gründung der Bundesliga gekommen ist. Hat natürlich damit zusammengehangen, dass dieses Amateurideal in Deutschland lange Zeit sehr, sehr hochgehängt worden ist, weil man einfach das Geld verdient für so eine Betätigung, für so eine Beschäftigung, für was ganz, ganz Schreckliches gehalten hat, für was Verdammenswertes gehalten hat, dann ist die Bundesliga gegründet worden, dann hat es irgendwelche Gehalts-Obergrenzen gegeben und auch da haben sich die Spieler natürlich Schlupflöcher gesucht, indem sie sich verkauft haben, indem sie Werbung gemacht haben, indem sie Gelder bezogen haben, die sie eigentlich gar nicht hätten beziehen dürfen. Da gab es irgendwelche Bestechungskandale. Also man sieht auch an sowas natürlich immer, wenn der Fußball versucht, sozusagen gegen die gesellschaftliche Tendenz anzugehen, kommen manchmal auch ziemlich schräge Sachen dabei raus. Das heißt ja nicht in jedem Fall, dass die gesellschaftliche Entwicklung zu begrüßen ist oder dass ich mich da zu großen Kapitalismus-Apologeten aufschwingen würde, gar nicht. Ich glaube aber, dass eine nüchternste Bestandsaufnahme sehr, sehr notwendig ist, um überhaupt so was wie eine vernünftige Kritik an der ganzen Angelegenheit, und zwar an der gesamten Veranstaltung, überhaupt entwickeln zu können und sich nicht auf irgendwelche vermeintlichen Auswüchse zu konzentrieren und an denen dann doch, da würde ich dann doch so einen Mainstream sehen, die nicht nur zum größten Übel zu machen, sondern geradezu zu demonisieren. Und das ist das, was mir in dieser Debatte über LW Leipzig auch einfach missfällt.
Ich glaube, man kann es auch noch mal ein bisschen runterbrechen. Marketing und so, man ist wahrscheinlich einig, aber letztlich funktioniert das Marketing natürlich nur, weil Fußball gespielt wird. Du musst tatsächlich eine lokale Fußballstruktur schaffen, die im Lokalen tatsächlich auch alle Eigenschaften des normalen Fußballklubs aufweist. Das heißt, hier wird ganz normal getrainiert, ganz normal eine Mannschaft ausgebildet, es bestehen ganz normale Fangeschichten, soziale Gruppen, die sich drumherum bilden, die eine identitäre Verbindung zu dem Verein und zu den Spielern aufbauen. Du brauchst ja trotzdem bei allem, was du über Marketing dann drumherum als Branding und als Corporate Design und was hast du nicht gesehen, alles drumherum hast. Du brauchst diese funktionierende, lokale Fußballstruktur. Und es gibt den schönen Satz vom Spuk, ich war das glaube ich mal, das ist so ein Dresdner Blogger, der meinte, so jede Vereinsgründung ist ein Kind ihrer Zeit. Als Ostdeutscher ist man da wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen geprägt, weil so viele Vereine ja auch über irgendwelche Parteibeschlüsse etc. gegründet wurden und der trotzdem lokal funktioniert haben als Vereine, die so in Dynamo Dresden, das ist wahrscheinlich der Verein im Osten, so und es ist letztlich ein Verein, der eine bestimmte Geschichte hat, die man sich vielleicht so nicht ausdenken würde, wenn man irgendwie heute auf die Gründungsgeschichte gucken würde. So und es ist aber trotzdem eine lokale Struktur gewesen, die immer funktioniert hat und so ähnlich ist es in Leipzig auch. Du hast so eine lokale Fußballstruktur, die lokal auch als Fußballhallen funktioniert und angenommen wird. Und ich glaube, das macht es auch immer so ein bisschen schwierig, wenn Leute von hier die RB Anhänge auch mit Leuten diskutieren, die von außen drauf gucken. Weil von außen dieses Marketing-Ding, dieses Corporate Design, dieses Red Bull dahinter, der Verein ist quasi die Firma, die irgendwie diesen Erfolg erspielt, viel stärker präsent ist als für Leute, die hier dem Verein folgen und dem Verein anhängen oder sich mit diesem Verein entwickeln und so. Und letztlich, um das nochmal weiterzuführen, wenn du versuchst, diesen Unterschied zu machen und zu sagen, ok, Evonik in Dortmund, das ist ja irgendwie so die unterstützende Marke, die ist schon da. Ja, aber letztlich ist so diese Verknüpfung zwischen Evonik und der Fußballstruktur Dortmund ja auch keine andere als zwischen Red Bull und Leipzig. Weil es sind Firmen, die ein bestimmtes Interesse haben, mit diesem Gegenstand Fußball Marketing zu betreiben und darüber ihre Firma nachhaltig, stabil etc. im Wettbewerb zu halten. Also die geben ja nicht ihr Geld, weil sie sagen, oh, das ist eine lokale Fußballstruktur, da geben wir mal Geld rein, sondern weil sie ein Interesse haben, dass das wieder zurückkommt. Im besten Fall hast du den Fußballverein vor Ort, an den du dich ranpappen kannst. Wenn du das nicht hast, dann gehst du halt irgendwo hin, wo er ist. Wenn du mit dem Fußball denkst, Geld zu machen. So und deswegen ist halt so diese grundsätzliche Verknüpfung zwischen, was haben Firmen für Interesse, dass sie Geld in Fußball stecken, ist bei Red Bull keine andere als bei Evonik. Der Unterschied ist tatsächlich bei Red Bull im grundsätzlichen Marketingkonzept zu suchen, dass sie sagen, wir sind niemand, der irgendwie eine Struktur fördert, sondern wir sind die Struktur. Das ist ja letztlich der Unterschied. Das ändert nichts an diesem grundsätzlichen Wesen von, da ist eine Firma, die versucht, über den Sport Marketing zu betreiben. Das ist letztlich bei jeder Firma die Logik. Keine Firma setzt sich hin und sagt, wir wollen irgendwie die Marke Borussia Dortmund stärken. Jede Firma sagt, was machen wir, damit wir in 30 Jahren eine größere Firma sind als jetzt.
Aber ich finde, die besondere Spannung, die hier angelegt ist, hast du ja gerade schon selber jetzt auch gesagt. Du sagst nämlich, Red Bull hat den Anspruch, ein Großteil der Struktur selber zu sein. Und das steht schon auch in meiner Wahrnehmung, wie wir ja auch versuchen, hier ganz genau zu beobachten, wie wird jetzt eigentlich diese lokale Fußballstruktur hier entfaltet. Steht das schon in dem Widerspruch zu diesem, zum Beispiel dieser Identifikation von Fans, beziehungsweise es ist nicht an allen Stellen widerspruchslos, möchte ich mal so formulieren. Wenn man zum Beispiel an auch kritische oder politisch aktive Fan-Gruppen denkt, die sich mit dem Engagement, die die RB-Fans sind, die im Stahl und Gehen, die Doppelhalter haben, die an Choreos sich beteiligen, die sich als RB-Fans verstehen und trotzdem ihre Probleme haben mit der Firma Red Bull und auch mit Teilen, wie das Engagement umgesetzt wird, also die Banner teilweise ja verboten bekommen oder die vorlegen müssen. Oder früher, als die Daumenschrauben noch ein bisschen enger waren, dann auch mal montags zum Rapport mussten, nach dem Fußballwochenende, um sich da dann für ihren Support oder sowas – also jetzt weiß ich von den Rasenballisten, dass das mal eine Zeit lang gab. Tatsächlich, ich glaube, da hat Red Bull jetzt auch dazu gelernt und sie wollen nicht mehr alles selber sein. Sie wollen den Leuten jetzt nicht noch vorschreiben, wie sie sich genau zu identifizieren haben mit dem Verein. Aber diesen Widerspruch würde ich doch hier nochmal herausstellen, dass sobald diese Firma, die dahinter steht, auch den Anspruch hat, einen Großteil der Struktur selber zu bestimmen oder selber mitzugestalten, dass genau das, was du gerade beschrieben hast, ganz normaler Verein in einer ganz normalen Stadt mit den ganz normalen Sachen, die da rum passieren, das sehe ich hier doch mal zumindest eben nicht ganz widerspruchslos.
Ich hoffe, ich habe wirklich nicht normal gesagt. Ich glaube, ich habe tatsächlich eher lokal gesagt. Ich habe nicht gesagt, das ist ein ganz normaler Verein. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass es ein Verein ist, der lokal funktionieren muss. Und ich glaube, du hast natürlich absolut recht. Es gibt Fan-Gruppen und tatsächlich bin ich immer noch jemand, der bei den Rasenballisten – ich finde die nett und es ist alles super – ihren Spagat, sich von Red Bull zu distanzieren, aber Anhänger von RB Leipzig zu sein, den finde ich tatsächlich famos. Also das ist wirklich ein Spagat, den ich wahrscheinlich selber nicht hinkriegen würde, so in der Form. Das schließt vielleicht einen bestimmten Fanzugang durchaus aus. Und trotzdem hast du ja im Großen, in der Masse, eine Identifizierung mit diesem Verein. Das ist ja nicht wegzudiskutieren, dass du in einer Größenordnung, die relativ normal ist für eine Stadt wie Leipzig, eine Identifikation mit diesem Verein hast, auch im Unland. Das ist einfach da. Mehr wollte ich gar nicht sagen. Das ist nicht der normale Verein. Wie Borussia Dortmund ergibt sich halt schon daraus, dass, wie gesagt, der Verein auf einem anderen Wege als Marketinginstrument benutzt wird, als es Evonik mit Dortmund macht. Das ist natürlich ein Unterschied, dass RB Leipzig identisch ist mit Red Bull. Das ist natürlich ein Unterschied, klar. Aber das ist natürlich auch ein Marketingunterschied, der vor allem tatsächlich nach außen relevant ist. Ich meine, Red Bull ist nicht hier, damit 30.000 Leute im Stadion Red Bull trinken. Das ist hier, glaube ich, relativ wurscht. Das merkt man tatsächlich, glaube ich, in dem, wie ich es in den sieben Jahren erlebt habe, schon auch relativ deutlich, dass es im Lokalen gar nicht so die große Rolle spielt. Das meine ich nur. Das ist halt so diese unterschiedliche Wahrnehmung, dass du hier, wenn du hier zum Fußball gehst, von Red Bull relativ verschont bist, wenn du nicht gerade tatsächlich vielleicht irgendwie eine aktive Fanszene bist, die irgendwie vielleicht noch am liebsten Red Bull kritische Banner aufhängen will, ist es für dich tatsächlich nicht so wahrnehmbar, wie das von außen – ich sage ja, wenn ich irgendwie in Cottbus immer noch wohnen würde, wie vor 20 Jahren und irgendwie, wie sich in meinem Leben nie was geändert hätte und ich immer noch in Cottbus fern wäre und ich würde nach Leipzig gucken, würde ich auch sagen, warum machen die so einen Quatsch oder so? Also ich kann diesen Zugang von außen, dass sich das irgendwie komisch anfühlt oder unnatürlich ist oder was auch immer, den kann ich glaube ich emotional nachvollziehen, sage aber trotzdem, dass das irgendwie von so innen gar nicht so das Thema oder gar nicht so das Problem ist, weil du einfach auf was ganz anderes oder einer ganz anderen Sache dran bist, nämlich an der Fußballstruktur.
Weißt du, wie man sich total gut distanzieren kann und trotzdem irgendwie aber noch nah am Berichtsgegenstand dran ist, indem man Raber sagt und nicht RB? Nein, und das meine ich ernst, als es jetzt vielleicht rüberkommt, denn ich finde vielleicht sollten wir da jetzt mal ins Detail gehen. Weil es gibt verschiedene Ebenen, auf denen das Marketing von Red Bull sich bei Rasenballsport Leipzig wiederfindet. Und diese Ebenen verquicken sich und nicht alle davon sind neu. Manche sind nur quasi etwas konsequenter umgesetzt als bei anderen Vereinen. Und das eine ist eben der Name. Laut DFB- und DFL-Statuten ist es eigentlich verboten, einen Sponsoring oder Firmennamen im Titel eines Vereins zu tragen. Aber es gab es schon vor Rasenballsport-Ausnahmen. Nämlich einmal Bayer Leverkusen, Wackerbockhausen, die sich auf ihre Tradition als Werksclubs berufen. Und so ein bisschen Vorbild vielleicht auch bei der Namensfindung war der Leichtathletik- und Rasensportverein Ahlen, der sich nach seinem Kosmetikkonzern mit den Initialen LR, der dort Hauptsponsor war, bis zum Abstieg in die Regionalliga 2006, nannten die sich LR Ahlen. Und so kommt man ja auch bei Rasenballsport Leipzig auf dieses RB. Und das ist für mich tatsächlich, auch wenn das keine neue Form des Marketings ist, ist das für mich eine eigene Qualität. Denn es heißt zum Beispiel eben nicht Iwonik Dortmund und es heißt nicht Telekom München. Und es heißt zwar auch nicht Red Bull Leipzig, aber in der Außensicht steht für mich RB für Red Bull. Ich habe inzwischen gelernt, in der Auseinandersetzung mit Leipzig-Fans, die das nicht gut finden, dass ich im Rasenfunk Raba sage, dass dem nicht unbedingt so ist, wenn man mit diesem Verein schon länger zu tun hat. Ich glaube das auch, denn ich habe es bei mir selber erlebt, dass ich erst als ich das mit Raba, ehrlich gesagt, aus so einer Laune heraus angefangen hatte im Rasenfunk, erst dann ist mir aufgefallen, Moment mal, ich sage die ganze Zeit Bayer Leverkusen. Und tatsächlich, seitdem versuche ich es zu vermeiden, es rutscht mir manchmal noch raus, aber wer mal drauf achtet, ich spreche jetzt nur noch von Leverkusen. Denn meine Meinung ist einfach, jetzt ist natürlich auch spezieller Fall hier mit dem Rasenfunk, ich habe mich ganz bewusst gegen jede Form der Werbung entschieden, egal was da auch schon zum Teil angeboten wurde, weil ich den Rasenfunk werbefrei halten möchte. Einfach aus meiner Entscheidung verschiedene Gründe. Und dann will ich aber auch nicht indirekt die ganze Zeit Initialen verwenden, die für mich eindeutig mit der Marke Red Bull zusammenhängen. Für andere nicht, das gestehe ich schon zu, aber für mich ist es so. Und dann mache ich mich ehrlich gesagt auch so ein bisschen lustig über diese Wortschöpfung. Rasenball – angeblich hat man ja früher eine Form des Tennis so genannt, habe ich jetzt gelernt bei der Recherche, aber ganz früh im 20. Jahrhundert war das, glaube ich. Deswegen komme ich zum Rhaber. Aber kannst du das nachvollziehen? Also ich will nicht sagen, dass das eine neue Dimension des Marketings ist, denn wie gesagt, das haben wir auch bei anderen Vereinen. Aber ich finde, ich bin immer irritiert, wenn ich zum Beispiel die österreichischen Bundesligisten sehe oder auch wenn ich mir die DEL angucke, mit den Thomas Chabot Ice Tigers und so ein Kram. Das irritiert mich wahnsinnig. Ich finde das komisch, die Verquickung zwischen Sportvereinen und Unternehmensnamen und deswegen vermeide ich das.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen – ich glaube grundsätzlich mir das wirklich wurscht, also das ist irgendwie dein Ding. Da hast du es ja selbst gesagt, du hast schon Namen wie Bayer, wo du irgendwie – also ich finde es auch so diese St. Pauli-Geschichte, wir verzichten aufs Logo und das nächste Mal hängt das Bayer-Kreuz dann irgendwie auf der Webseite, wo man dann irgendwie nicht auf Werbung verzichtet im Vereinslogo. Und was ist der Unterschied? Machen sie dann in 20 Jahren das Red Bull RB Leipzig-Logo denn doch auf ihre Webseite, weil es es dann schon 20 Jahre gibt? Also da gibt es schon dann so irgendwie so seltsame Geschichten, wo du denkst, ja, aber wo ist die innere Logik? Wenn du Werbung in Vereinslogos oder Werbebezüge vermeiden willst, dann müsstest du andere Logos auch dann irgendwie runternehmen. Aber das ist mir auch letztlich relativ wurscht, glaube ich. Aber ich glaube, das Zentrale ist, dass es selbst wenn der Verein FC Leipzig heißen würde, würde irgendwie 50 Prozent der Fußballberichterstatter Red Bull Leipzig sagen. Also ich glaube, so dieser Marketing-Effekt hängt glaube ich viel weniger an diesen RB davor, sondern einfach an dem, was der Verein tatsächlich ist. Also das ist nicht irgendwie so, das ist ein Red Bull Verein. Und ich glaube, das hängt viel eher daran, als dass du irgendwie jetzt RB sagst oder Raba sagst oder irgendwas. Also bei Raba fällt dem eher noch eher auf, da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht, da muss es nur einer mitzugeben. Also ich glaube, das kannst du irgendwie argumentativ drehen, wie du willst. Aber ich glaube, diese Marketing-Verknüpfung über das RB, die finde ich immer so ein bisschen, das ist immer so ein bisschen mehr Taggold. Also ich glaube, die kommt ganz anders her. Und die kriegst du als Verknüpfung ja auch nicht los.
Also ich würde dir widersprechen. Ich glaube, wenn das Ding FC Leipzig hieße, würde das in der Sportberichterstattung, die ja durchaus handzahm ist, was das Thema angeht, auch immer FC Leipzig sein. Und durch das RB ist das Red Bull rollt halt so mit. Das ist unterbewusst, wie auch immer. Da kommt dann vermutlich mit rein, wie du sagtest, dass Red Bull, der Verein ist Red Bull. Aber wenn das dann FC hieße, dann hätte man, wäre es nicht so einfach, diesen Fehler quasi zu machen. Und statt Rasenballsport dann Red Bull Leipzig zu sagen.
Genau. Und ich störe zum Beispiel auch davor, dass mir so ein Red Bull mal rausrutscht. Weil wenn ich Raba sage, das ist übrigens auch herrlich von den Lippenreuten. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum das nicht jeder macht. Raba ist so ein schönes Wort.
Irgendwann musst du den Podcast löschen, weil du Red Bull Leipzig gesagt hast.
Ja, ich würde es tun. Nein.
Es wird dramatisch.
Es löst natürlich so eine gewisse – wahrscheinlich kommen wir auch noch dazu – eine gewisse Befindlichkeit hierzulande aus, wo Sticheleien oder nicht ernst genommen werden, dann gerne mal auch so ein bisschen persönlicher nimmt. Und da kann man gerne mal in so Westpennester hineinfassen.
Ja, irgendwie tut mir das dann tatsächlich auch leid. Da habe ich ja auch lange Diskussionen mit Leuten darüber geführt. Ein Hörer hat im Forum geschrieben, er fühle sich ernsthaft in seine Identität als Fan verletzt. Und ich glaube, der hat das ganz ernst gemeint. Und ich habe es auch so genommen und habe da lange drüber nachgedacht und dachte mir dann, ich will ja eigentlich nicht irgendwie, also so wie ich ja auch, ich will ja niemandem etwas Böses. Ich kenne ja inzwischen ja auch von jedem Verein nette Leute, Grüße nach Dortmund zum Jens oder nach Neuss, dass ich nicht mal mehr irgendwelchen Verein was Böses wünschen kann, weil ich da nette Leute kenne inzwischen. Und so ist es ja bei Leipzig auch. Aber für mich ist das einfach eine Form der Dreistigkeit gewesen, diese Wortschöpfung, eine kluge Dreistigkeit. Das möchte ich ausdrücklich betonen und auch eine legitime, denn alle Entscheidungsinstanzen haben das zugelassen, die ich aber irgendwie nicht mitgeben möchte. Und wo ich dann aber auch die Konsequenz schon einsehe, in dem Moment man dann das aber hier nicht mit zweierlei Maß messen und für irgendwie ständig ein Arzneimittelhersteller aus Leverkusen noch mitnennen. Und deswegen versuche ich mich da quasi auch selber zu erziehen und versuche einfach jetzt, ich möchte keine Thomas Schabo Ice Tigers im Rasenfunk haben, doof gesagt. Also einfach keine Unternehmensnamen, die mit Sportvereinen verknüpft sind. Aber interessant ist was, was Matteschitz selber dazu sagt. Er hat 2009, glaube ich, in einem Interview gesagt, er gibt da nicht so viele, Zitat, mit dem Namen RB Leipzig und den Bullen auf den Dressen sollte die Identifikation mit unserem Haus ausreichend gegeben sein.
Ja, ich glaube, die größere Preissigkeit finde ich auch das Durchbrügeln von die roten Bullen durch alles. Ich glaube, da bin ich dann derjenige, der sich dagegen wehrt. Ich glaube, ich habe auch noch nie irgendwo die roten Bullen geschrieben.
Ja, und das ist die zweite Komponente, die dazu kommt. Das gehört ja, also ich finde, das ist so eine Verquickung. Wir haben den Namen, wir haben das Logo, über das möchte ich gleich noch sprechen. Und dann haben wir eben, dass du im Stadion auf der Homepage und wo auch immer du Kontakt mit diesem Verein hast, wirst du angeschrien, dass das rote Bullen sein. Und deswegen finde ich schon, dass das auch, wenn wir darüber sprechen, dass die einzelnen Elemente, jetzt vielleicht das Logo ausgenommen, noch keine neue Dimension des Marketings sind in der Bundesliga, finde ich die Verquickung von den drei Dingen, also die Konsequenz, mit der das in allen Bereichen durchgeführt wird, finde ich ist schon etwas Neues in der Bundesliga. Und das kann man natürlich sagen, wie Alex gab es immer und ist jetzt auch nicht der Untergang des Fußballs, stimmt sehr wahrscheinlich auch, aber man kann es natürlich trotzdem auch schlecht finden.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall eine E-Mail ans Marketing des BVB schreiben, dass man doch jetzt mit den schwarz-gelben Pumas werben könnte oder sowas.
Pass auf, das steht das nächste Mal bei uns auf dem Programm.
Ja, aber es schenkt den Leuten natürlich auch rein Weinern, muss man natürlich sagen. Letztlich stellt sich da ja auch die Frage, was sind denn eigentlich diese Fußballklubs? Davon zu trennen wäre die Frage, was sollten sie unserer Ansicht nach sein und nach Ansicht jeder und jedes Einzelnen überhaupt sein. Wenn man RB Leipzig sagt und eigentlich das Ganze lieber Red Bull Leipzig nennen würde, ist es natürlich ein ganz offener und ehrlicher Ausdruck dessen, was Fußball inzwischen ist. Wie gesagt, ist ja nicht ohne Grund so, dass die Klubs eben ihre Profi-Abteilung ausgegliedert haben.
Aber du machst halt pro Nennung einmal Werbung, für die du nichts bekommst.
Ja, für die man nichts bekommt, sicherlich. Das kann man geißeln. Ich kann mich auch noch an die Zeiten erinnern, der 70er- 80er-Jahre, wo es im Fernsehen keine Schleichwerbung geben durfte und wo man auch peinlich genau darauf geachtet hat und wo auch keine Unternehmensnamen im Radio oder im Fernsehen genannt worden sind, sondern da hieß es dann immer, der sowieso Artikelhersteller oder ein großer Sportartikelhersteller, da wurde halt nicht der Name gesagt. Ich weiß nicht, das ist – jeder weiß ohnehin, wovon man da spricht. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das wirklich so eine dramatische Sache ist und sich da irgendwie so darauf festzulegen, dass man das jetzt unbedingt reinhalten will von solchen Einflüssen. Wie gesagt, gut, Max, das ist ohnehin deine Entscheidung. Die respektiere ich natürlich, aber ich weiß nicht.
Ich will die Diskussion stellen. Also, wie gesagt, ich bin hier ergebnisoffen reingegangen. Vielleicht sage ich in Zukunft auch B, aber für mich – ich weiß nicht, irgendwas, so wie wahrscheinlich manche Leute sich etwas streut, wenn ich Raber sage. Und ich immer leicht schmunzeln muss, wenn ich Raber sage. Und mich immer sehr freue, wenn andere Leute Raber sagen. Denn niemand hat ja festgelegt, dass die Abkürzung für das allseits bekannte Wort Rasenballsport nicht vielleicht Raber sein könnte. So stellt sich mir halt auch im Negativen was auf, wenn ich von RB spreche. Und ich denke dann eben einfach immer Red Bull. Vielleicht habe ich aber auch ein Problem mit der Marke. Weiß ich nichts. Vielleicht noch der nächste Punkt, auf den wir dann später noch kommen.
Das wäre ja auch mal ein Punkt, den man fragen müsste, ob das bei LRA eigentlich auch so gewesen ist. Ob da viele Leute eigentlich mit dem dahinterstehenden Unternehmen ein Problem hatten und ob es nicht bei Red Bull auch darum geht, wo kommt es eigentlich her, was wird da verkauft und so weiter. Aber das ist sicherlich noch mal ein anderes Thema. Aber nochmal, ich finde es durchaus eine ehrliche Aussage, wenn man es irgendwie so nennt. Und ich habe das deutlich größere Problem, ehrlich gesagt, damit, wenn ein Club wie der 1. FC Kaiserslautern mit öffentlichen Geldern gerettet werden muss. Das ist nämlich dann wirklich der eigentliche Skandal. Ich behaupte nicht, dass Fußballklubs und schon gar nicht welche, die professionellen Sport betreiben, dass die in irgendeiner Form gemeinnützig sein müssen oder überhaupt irgendwie allen gehören, sondern das ist dann tatsächlich eine privatrechtliche Angelegenheit. Aber dass irgendwie die öffentliche Hand hingeht und den 1. FC Kaiserslautern davor bewahrt, sich irgendwie in Wohlgefallen aufzulösen, das finde ich dann nochmal eine ganz andere Marke. Das sind wirklich dann quasi Gelder der Allgemeinheit. Und davon ausgehen muss ich sagen, wenn das nur RB Leipzig heißt und selbst wenn es Red Bull Leipzig heißen würde, finde ich vielleicht nicht schön. Du hast ja nun auch die anderen Beispiele genannt. Wenn man nach Österreich guckt, hat man so ein paar Konstruktionen dabei, wo man sagt, ja klingt jetzt irgendwie nicht so doll. Genauso mit den Stadionnamen, da geht es mir dann eher so, dass ich denke, ich habe jetzt keine Lust, mich alle zwei, drei Jahre da umzustellen. Deswegen bleibt für mich jetzt irgendwie ein Stadionname bestehen, den benutze ich weiter. Also wenn ich Westfalen Stadion sage, hängt es noch nicht mal damit zusammen, dass ich irgendwie den jetzigen Namensgeber irgendwie nicht mag, sondern dass ich denke, oh Gottchen, in Hamburg ist ja noch schlimmer. Da ändert sich das alle paar Jahre mal. Wer merkt sich das schon? Andererseits, wie will man das Ding eigentlich in München nennen, wenn man es nicht in Verbindung bringen will mit dem großen Versicherungskonzern, der dem Ganzen nun mal den Namen gegeben hat. Schlauchboot. Schlauchboot von mir, genau. Schlauchboot-Arena. Oder wie die ausgerechnet die durchkommerzialisierte FIFA das gemacht hat, ist das dann FIFA-Arena in München zu nennen. Aber das sind dann vielleicht Dinge, die muss man dann wahrscheinlich mit sich selbst ausmachen. Aber ich finde das ehrlich gesagt nicht so ein großes Problem. Ich möchte an der Stelle noch einen einwerfen. Auch da nochmal ein kluges Zitat, wie ich finde, von Nicole Selmer. Wollte ich vorhin eigentlich noch gesagt haben, hole ich hier mit nachher dich an der Stelle. Das passt auch irgendwie ganz gut. Sie hat geschrieben, eigentlich ist es so, dass man gar nicht mehr von einer Kommerzialisierung des Fußballs sprechen sollte, sondern davon ausgehen, dass es eben auch bestimmte Phasen gibt. Sagt, wir sind eigentlich in die Phase der Konzernalisierung eingetreten, wie sie sich daran auch widerspiegelt. Und ich finde es, glaube ich, eigentlich immer ganz gut, wenn man die Dinge irgendwie beim Namen nennt. Ich meine, hey Österreich, uns wären aber auch so grandiose Namen dann versagt geblieben wie Superfund Pushing. Das klingt doch großartig. Das ist doch furchtbar. Hätten wir wirklich ganzer darauf verzichten wollen? Superfund Pushing schlägt Falk Schalke 04 mit 4 zu 0. Und anschließend wechselt Edi Glieder. Das ist doch die reine Poesie, oder?
Ich finde auch den SK-Punti-Gammer-Sturm Graz ganz krass. Das ist wirklich einer meiner Favoriten, nicht zuletzt wegen des Sportradio 360 und dem Producer da. Ich wollte nur kurz zwei Sachen anmerken. Auch jetzt wieder ist es so ein bisschen so, als ob man es nicht kritisieren darf und sich nicht ein bisschen an dem Namen aufhängen darf. Und ich glaube dafür gibt es gute Gründe, weil es nämlich funktioniert. Also warum ärgern sich da Leute darüber? Weil dieser Umweg Rasenballsport natürlich ein Kompromiss ist, der der ursprünglichen Intention entgegensteht. Und deswegen ist es schon irgendwie lustig, sich genau daran aufzuhängen. Aber damit jetzt wieder so hinzudriften und zu sagen, naja, es gibt halt nur die Wahl zwischen, was weiß ich, sag ich mal jetzt zugespitzt, Manchester Kapitalismus und irgendeine Illusion von Fußball, die den Kopf von irgendwie rückwärtsgewandt denkenden Leuten ist, das ist mir ein bisschen zu einfach, diese schwarz-weiß Malerei. Und auch hier zum Beispiel, auch wenn das Ding am besten Red Bull heißen sollte, und das Stadion ja auch so heißt, auch hier wären da Steuergelder hinterher geschmissen. Das ist jetzt nicht so, als ob es das hier in diesen Konstruktionen nicht gibt. Und da bin ich schon zumindest dafür, dass nur weil man sagt, die Kritik an Kommerzialisierung greift häufig zu kurz, dass man jetzt nicht sagt, wir schauen aber trotzdem mal genau hin, wie das hier läuft. Und da driftet mir das dann zu schnell in der Kritik der Kritik einfach immer dahin, dass man sagt, na, ist doch naiv oder gibt es woanders auch. Ja, ist erstens kein Grund, dass man das nicht auch nicht gut findet. Und B ist umso mehr für mich, auch dann als kritisch denkender Mensch, irgendwie eine Aufforderung, doch mal genau hinzuschauen, wozu das dann eigentlich im Detail führt.
Das ist genau auch etwas, was ich als BVB-Fan mir dann immer anhören darf. Ihr seid doch bürsennotiert, was wollt ihr überhaupt? Ihr seid doch die Zugpferde der Kapitalisierung. Ihr habt das doch alles angestoßen, bla bla bla. Was auch immer da kommt, das ändert ja nichts daran, dass ich das vielleicht sogar scheiße finde. Dass ich auf die Mitgliederversammlung des BVB gehen kann. Liebe Grüße nach Leipzig an dieser Stelle. Und da meinen Unmut kundtun kann und sagen kann, hey Leute, was wäre denn hier mit 50 plus 1 und ich find kacke, dass wir das und das machen. Und ich bin doch mündig.
Moment mal, rederecht haben die Mitglieder bei den Ängsten.
Ich darf sogar Anträge einbringen. Das ist krass. Das ist halt genau der Punkt. Dass man immer dieses alles oder nichts und das nervt mich halt. Weil ich kann doch auch beim BVB Sachen kacke finden. Weil ich irgendwann mal als 5- 6-Jähriger die gelben Trikots im Fernsehen geil fand und jetzt diesem Verein verfallen bin und mich dann auch irgendwann mit den Werten identifizieren konnte, mit den Freundschaften, die dadurch aufgebaut wurden und so weiter. Dass ich dann jetzt, nur weil ich Fan dieses Vereins geworden bin, also ich bin noch nicht total unkritisch gegenüber dem, was hier passiert. Leset euch doch mal schwarzgelb.de durch, was da steht über Chinareisen, über Asienreisen, über keine Ahnung was, über den Stadionnamen. Ich meine, wir nutzen konsequent jede Gelegenheit, um irgendwie diesen Stadionnamen nicht zu verwenden. Also ich bin doch nicht nur, weil ich Fan eines börsennotierten Vereins bin, der totale Kommerzfan und darf deshalb nicht andere Vereine kritisieren und muss dann immer die Kommerzialisierung als gottgegeben hinnehmen. Es gibt nicht nur Schwarz und Weiß. Und ich finde Dinge bei BVB kacke, die ich dann bei Raba erst echt kacke finde. Ich hoffe, ich hab dir einen kleinen Schmunzeln auf die Lippen gezaubert mit Raba gerade.
Ich würde gerne dazu sagen, das geht ja schon auch ein bisschen in meine Richtung. Ich möchte mich da nicht zum Apologeten aufschwingen und auch an der Stelle anmerken, dass ich – Jens, so wie du das jetzt gesagt hast mit China beispielsweise und dem BVB – so geht's mir natürlich mit Bayern, München und Katar. Also diverse Texte dazu geschrieben, Interviews gegeben, das in Vorträgen zur Sprache gebracht und so weiter. Und ich bin ja längst nicht der einzige Bayern-Fan, der dazu was macht. Und natürlich mit einigen ersetzen sie, dass es überhaupt nichts bringt. Ich meine, es gibt ja nun wirklich genügend Leute, die deswegen auch ausgetreten sind. Es hat eingegeben, dass auf der letzten Jahreshauptversammlung angesprochen hat, auch in aller Deutlichkeit angesprochen hat. Das sind natürlich auch Dinge, von denen ich weiß, natürlich das gehört auch zum modernen Kapitalismus dazu. Das gehört zum modernen Fußball dazu. Das sind so die Dinge, die man natürlich dann kritisieren muss. Es geht überhaupt nicht darum, eine Apologie von RB Leipzig zu betreiben. Ich halte das immer ganz gerne den Leuten entgegen, die das vermeintlich authentische verteidigen. Wenn du überlegst, du hast ja gerade davon gesprochen, ich bin als kleiner Stöpsel BVB von geworden, weil ich schwarz-gelb geil gefunden habe und die Stimmung im Stadion geil fand. So müsste man das dann schon aber auch denjenigen zugestehen, die heute beispielsweise als Kinder nach Leipzig ins Stadion gehen und dazuschauen und sagen, ich habe mich da irgendwie in den Fußball verliebt und finde das irgendwie großartig. Das ist für die ja letzten Endes dann auch nichts anderes. Das möchte ich denen zumindest nicht absprechen. Das wird aber nach meinem Eindruck vielfach getan. Und da wird dann die Ambivalenz natürlich auch nicht zugelassen. Ich würde tatsächlich nur für Ambivalenz plädieren wollen. Das setzt dann vielleicht an der einen oder anderen Stelle schon mal voraus, dass man sozusagen dem auf einen groben Klotz, auch einen groben Keil setzt oder der einen Seite erst auch mal durchaus mit einem Schuss Polemik entgegentritt, um die Ambivalenzen herauszuarbeiten. Also das wäre mein Ziel in der ganzen Angelegenheit. Und wenn ich da manchmal ein bisschen überschießende Polemik drin haben sollte, dann ist das durchaus beabsichtigt. Aber es ist nicht so, dass ich die Ambivalenzen nicht sehe. Vielleicht ein schönes Beispiel noch, weil es auch die Bayern betrifft an dieser Stelle. Ich habe mich mal auf einer Veranstaltung mit jemandem unterhalten von der Schikaria, weil es da auch eigentlich eine ganz kuriose Geschichte gibt. Die Schikaria hat hier nun große Verdienste erworben, das Andenken von Kurt Landauer in Ehren zu halten. Also für diejenigen, die nicht wissen, wer es ist, langjähriger jüdischer Präsident, das FC Bayern von den Nazis verfolgt, nach 1947 wieder zum Präsidenten geworden. Von der offiziellen Clubführung lange Zeit im Prinzip ins Abseits gestellt. Wollen wir nicht drüber reden, waren wir noch nicht geboren, haben wir nichts mit zu tun. Ein früherer Vizepräsident hat sogar mal gesagt, wir können doch jetzt nicht über den Juden Landauer reden, sonst holen wir uns die Nazis ins Stadion. Die Schikaria hat da immer großartige Sachen gemacht, Choreografien, antirassistische Fußball-Tourniere und so weiter. Aber ein Widerspruch tut sich da ja trotzdem so ein bisschen auf. Wenn man mal überlegt, wer Kurt Landauer eigentlich war, muss man sagen, das ist ja auch so ein Pionier der Kommerzialisierung gewesen. Das ist doch jemand gewesen, der gesagt hat, die Spieler sollen natürlich Geld verdienen können, dafür, dass sie Fußball spielen. Der gesagt hat, ich möchte auch an diese Gehälter investieren. Der auch klar gesagt hat, wir wollen internationale Begegnung organisieren. Wir wollen uns mit den Besten der Welt messen. Als in Deutschland noch vollkommen klar war, Fußball ist eigentlich eh irgendwie, ist irgendwie wie gesagt Fußlümmelei irgendwie aus England und irgendeine Form von Internationalisierung oder sogar Geld dafür bekommt, um Gottes Willen. Also man muss ja immer daran, dass immer an den jeweiligen Zeiten messen, in denen es stattfindet. Also übertragen auf heute, müsste die Schikaria als kommerzkritische Ultra-Organisation Kurt Landauer eigentlich für was ganz, ganz Furchtbares halten. Aber gleichzeitig hält sie ihnen Ehren, weil das natürlich nicht der Bereich ist, ist mir schon klar, den sie, dessen wegen sie sich seiner angenommen hat. Das weiß ich schon. Aber den Widerspruch können sie natürlich nicht auflösen und das finde ich so ein bisschen amüsant, weil man das irgendwie gar nicht so auf dem Schirm hat, was die Ziele dieses Mannes eigentlich waren. Und ich finde, das gehört zu diesen Abivalenzen auch dazu, dass man auch mal sagt, hey, was ist denn Fußball zu früheren Zeiten gewesen und was ist eigentlich überhaupt von diesem Amateurideal zu halten und ist von diesem Amateurideal, dass man wirklich mit guten Gründen einfach auch kritisieren kann, dieses, die Dinge unbedingt um ihrer Selbstwillen tun zu wollen. Ist das nicht irgendwie auch, ist das nicht wirklich auch in höchstem Maße kritikabel? Ist es nicht irgendwie eben mindestens auch ambivalent zu sagen, hier, wir handeln aus wohlverstandem Eigeninteresse. Natürlich handeln wir auch für Geld. Und natürlich hat der Markt auch an der einen oder anderen Stelle sowas wie eine zivilisierende Vernunft. Und an anderen Stellen ist er vollkommen wahnsinnig geworden und läuft vollkommen aus dem Ruder. Aber diesen Aspekt vermisse ich so ein bisschen in der Diskussion. Und ich finde gerade diese Person Kurt Landauer, es gab da eine ganz gute Diskussion mit dem Schikaria-Vertreter, weil er sagt, stimmt, hast du eigentlich recht. Haben wir eigentlich so gar nicht gesehen. Man könnte das Ganze schon in eine Rechnung bringen, in eine Richtung bringen, wo man sagt, okay, wir haben diese Ambivalenzen, da sollen wir drüber sprechen. Und vielleicht auch damit aufhören, gewisse Jahrzehnte zu verklären, wie es nach meinem Eindruck heute immer noch häufig der Fall ist. Also in den 70er und vor allem in den 80er Jahren, da bin ich auch schon ins Stadion gegangen, da war längst nicht alles gut. Also ich rede jetzt vom Westen, da war längst nicht alles super. Und im Osten war es das mit Sicherheit auch nicht, denke ich mal. Und da gibt es dann für meinen Geschmack auch nichts zu romantisieren. Ich glaube, das sollte man in diese Debatte einfließen lassen, um einfach auch zu dieser Ambivalenz zu kommen, die das Ganze für mich zumindest aus meiner Sicht hat.
Also da unterstütze ich dich natürlich vollkommen, nach dem Motto, es gibt kein richtiges Leben im Falschen, beziehungsweise man kann nicht auch ohne Widersprüche leben in unseren Gesellschaften so. Ich finde es auch gut, dass du das hier einbringst, wie du das machst. Ich finde nur immer, hier so lokal ist ein ganz großes Problem für uns, wenn man genau so eine Haltung einnimmt, auf so Ambivalenzen aufmerksam machen zu wollen und das zu thematisieren. Dass das so etwas ist, was an der Art und Weise, wie Red Bull nach außen kommuniziert und wie sie sich auch selbst darstellen und wie auch die daraus abgeleitete Selbstwahrnehmung von vielen Fans ist, perrt das halt vollkommen ab. Da ist halt nicht viel, dass man die Ambivalenzen des eigenen Handelns deutlich macht, sondern da ist es halt so zu spitz, so Vereinfachung wie was denn, die anderen hatten ja ihre Chance, wir machen jetzt hier unser Ding, wir machen das eh besser als die anderen. Und wenn man da dann an berechtigte Kritikpunkte kommt, perlt halt eben genauso im differenzierenden Haltung an dem Selbstverständnis und auch der öffentlichen Inszenierung von der RB-Franchise hier wirklich komplett ab. Also es ist auch so ein bisschen frustrierend. Deswegen verstehe ich dein Ringen nach Differenzierung in der gesamten Diskussion, das täte wirklich auch gerade auch nochmal der medialen Aufarbeitung von seltenen Diskussionen wirklich gut, weil das ist irgendwie nicht nur der Stammtisch, der da Differenzierung braucht, sondern auch wirklich bis hoch zur Sportschau. Aber sozusagen gerade dann hier im lokalen Kontext klingt das dann – ich weiß, du meinst das nicht so – klingt das so ein bisschen wie Hohen nach, weil da also hier die großen Meinungsminder inklusive des Vereins selber, die sehen das überhaupt nicht für nötig, sich mit sowas abzugeben, wie da noch Differenzierung einzuziehen. Da wird gemacht, da wird geklotzt und nicht gekleckert und wer damit ein Problem hat, der ist ein Spaßverderber, der soll sich um was anderes kümmern.
Das war auch das, was ich vorhin meinte, nur ganz kurz noch, als ich gesagt habe, möglicherweise unterscheidet sich die Wahrnehmung auch so ein bisschen je nach Standort. Also ich habe genau das, was du jetzt gerade gesagt hast, natürlich auch insbesondere nochmal in dem Interview mit euch im Ballesterer gelesen. Da ist mir auch klar geworden, okay, ihr kriegt natürlich auch jeden Tag, ihr lebt in Leipzig, ihr kriegt jeden Tag die Leipziger Medien um die Ohren gehauen. Habt auch noch gesagt, das Problem ist dieses Konglomerat von RB, der Leipziger Volkszeitung, dem Rathaus mit Bürgermeister Burkhard Jung. Das ist sicherlich auch das, was du meintest, da kommt die Politik natürlich auch noch mit rein. Es ist also nicht einfach nur eine private Geschichte. Und der Handelshochschule, die die wissenschaftliche Expertise liefert. Gerade letztes Jahr ist mir offen gestanden auch nicht so klar geworden und klar gewesen. Nachdem ich das Interview mit euch gelesen habe, habe ich gedacht, okay, das ist vielleicht ein Punkt in der Diskussion, den ich vernachlässige oder den ich vielleicht nicht so mitbekomme. Die Glorifizierung in manchen Medien, da habe ich auch das Gefühl, okay, das geht mir natürlich zu weit. Also bin auch Sky-Abonnent und kriege da das eine oder andere mit, wo ich denke, okay, das ist mir dann natürlich deutlich zu unkritisch. Also das will ich selbstverständlich auch nicht. Ich bekomme aus meiner Perspektive deutlich eher diese ganze Fan-Debatte mit. Das mag auch an den sozialen Medien liegen, das mag daran liegen an den Kreisen, an denen ich mich aufhalte, die natürlich dann eher links sind und nochmal eine ganz andere Art von Argumentationen bringen, die mich teilweise wirklich um den Verstand bringen, weil ich das für ideologisch vollkommen versaut halte. Und es kann schon einfach auch gut sein, dass daraus sozusagen mein Bedürfnis gewachsen ist, dem etwas entgegenzusetzen und damit dann an einen Punkt zu kommen, wo er sagt, hör mal Alter, das klingt echt wie Hohen, wir leben mit Leipzig, wir kriegen das ganz anders mit. Also das gestehe ich vollkommen zu und das ist mir nach der Lektüre eures Interviews und nach dem, was du jetzt gesagt hast, auch sicherlich noch mal klarer geworden.
Wir reden jetzt schon über eine Stunde über diesen Aspekt des Kritikpunkts, dass Leipzig ein Marketinginstrument sei. Ich möchte dazu mal ein Zitat von Dietrich Mateschitz einwerfen. Das Thema Fußball wurde bei uns im Unternehmen immer diskutiert. Red Bull ist global geworden und auch Erwachsener. Unsere Zielgruppe, die Red Bull am Anfang vor 17 Jahren beim Snowboarden oder Mountainbiken getrunken hat, steht heute im Beruf. Kennt ihr ja alle. Früher tranken die Red Bull in der Disco, heute sind sie älter und konsumieren bei Überstunden im Büro. Da kommt man Marketing strategisch an einer Sportart wie Fußball als Wichtigste der Welt nicht vorüber, hat er 2005 in der FAZ gesagt. Das fasst ja, finde ich, schon ganz gut zusammen, dass wir hier, um diesen Punkt Marketing im Fußball durch Red Bull zusammenzufassen, haben wir hier zwei Besonderheiten, die es dann doch von anderen Marketing-Formen, die wir im Fußball erleben, unterscheidet. Das eine ist, dass wir hier den Fußball als Sportart, als Projektionsfläche sehen für ein Unternehmen. Das kann sein, dass das bei anderen Unternehmen auch so war. Es ist sicher kein Zufall, dass die großen Autohersteller zum Beispiel auch jetzt in der größten deutschen Sportart unterwegs sind. Aber der Punkt, der da dazu kommt, ist mit einer anderen Intention. Also während sich eben andere Unternehmen an bestehende Vereine dranhängen, macht RB Leipzig oder Raber Leipzig oder wie auch immer, mein Gott, ich weiß es nicht mehr, wie ich es machen soll, die machen das anders. Also in einem anderen Artikel habe ich die Formulierung gelesen. Die Firma steigt nie nur als Geldgeber bei Sportveranstaltungen oder bei Vereinen ein. Red Bull will immer der Hausherr sein, denn nur wenn der Konzern über alle Details bestimmen darf, kann er den Sport so verändern, dass er zum Konzern passt und die Marke stärkt. Übernehmen, auf Linie bringen, aufmotzen, die Kosten sind zweitrangig, das ist die Strategie von Red Bull. Matthias, würdest du mir zustimmen, wenn ich sage, das ist schon eine neue Qualität, die Red Bull in den Fußball reingebracht hat und auch gerade in den deutschen Fußball?
Also ich habe es ja vorhin schon mal versucht zu sagen. Also klar hast du in dieser Art und Weise, wie man das Marketing nutzt, oder wie man Fußball als Marketing nutzt, hat man eine andere Rangehensweise, weil die Firma einfach nicht so tickt, dass sie sagt, wir geben dir 20 Millionen, guck, was du draus machen kannst sportlich. Die Firma sagt, wir haben 20 Millionen, wie setzen wir die ein? Wie ist die Kostenkontrolle? Was machen wir damit? Und natürlich ist das ein anderer Ansatzpunkt. Nur ist die Frage letztlich, wie es jeder für sich bewertet, wie groß er diese Differenz sieht. Und für mich ist sie eher graduell, für mich ist es eher vernachlässigbar, sonst wäre ich nicht zu dem Verein gegangen vor vielen Jahren. Und für andere ist es ganz essentieller, weil es für sie sich nicht anfühlt und für sie nicht sein kann, dass das so läuft. Ich habe es vorhin schon versucht zu sagen, dass ich den ganz großen Unterschied in der Art und Weise, wie Firmen denken und wie Firmen versuchen, Marketing zu machen, nicht sehe. Und dass es für mich eher ein gradueller Unterschied ist. Von daher ist es eine Bewertung, die jeder für sich treffen muss. Für mich ist es nicht essentiell.
Ich glaube, das Problem an dieser Stelle ist halt nicht… Du vergleichst ja jetzt Red Bull mit Evonik zum Beispiel. Aber das ist ja ein Vergleich, den kein anderer bemüht. Alle vergleichen den BVB mit Red Bull. Und ich glaube, klar nutzt Evonik das als Vehikel, so wie Red Bull das als Vehikel nimmt. Aber ich bin kein Fan von Evonik, ich bin Fan von BVB. Und insofern ist da halt bei Red Bull diese Verquickung zwischen Vehikel und demjenigen, der es nutzen will, die halt vielen sauer aufstößt. Und wo dann einfach diese Differenz ist, die nicht mehr graduell ist, sondern essentiell.
Ja, aber hier sind die Leute auch Fans von RB Leipzig und nicht zuerst von Red Bull. Das ist ja das, was ich versucht habe, vorhin zu sagen. Du hast von außen natürlich eine Sicht darauf, dass das Red Bull ist. Aber wenn du hier zum Fußball gehst, gehst du zu RB Leipzig. Du gehst dorthin, weil du Emi Forsberg geil findest, weil du irgendwie mit deinem Fanclub dahin gehst, mit dem du irgendwie total gerne bist und Spaß haben willst. Du hast doch in diesem Vereinsumfeld doch ein ganz ähnliches Erleben, wie du das bei Dortmund hast. Du gehst ja nicht hin, weil du Red Bull findest. Da gibt es wahrscheinlich auch ein paar, die Red Bull als Eventmarke so gut finden, dass sie RB Leipzig auch gut finden. Aber das ist ja nicht der Hauptteil der Leute, die in Leipzig zum Fußball gehen. Der Hauptteil der Leute in Leipzig geht zum Fußball, weil sie geilen Fußball sehen wollen, weil sie zum Schluss auch mal in der 90. Minute gegen Dortmund gewinnen wollen, weil sie einfach genau diese Erlebnisse haben wollen. Das hat erst einmal mit Red Bull nur insofern zu tun, dass die das Ganze finanzieren und hinstellen. Drumherum bilden sich genau dieselben sozialen Strukturen. Darüber diskutieren, ob das normal ist oder nicht. Aber es bilden sich ähnliche soziale Strukturen, die jenseits von Red Bull oder dieser Marke tragfähig sind und diesen Verein zu einer Vereinstruktur machen, die sich im Stadion ähnlich anfühlt, als wenn ich in Mainz stehe.
Das muss ich erst noch zeigen. Aber prinzipiell will ich dir insofern gar nicht widersprechen, als dass ich die Fans ja auch überhaupt nicht kritisiere. Das ist ja auch etwas, was Red Bull leider ziemlich clever gemacht hat. Die haben da einfach ein riesiges Vakuum besetzt, haben dem Osten einen sportlich erfolgreichen Verein gegeben. Was ja auch in den Diskussionen ganz oft irgendwie, gerade beim BVB-Hochschwappen ist so ein Ost-West-Gefälle. So nach dem Motto, ihr gönnt uns Aussies auch gar nichts. Und das hat Red Bull clever gemacht. Und ich würde auch nie die Fans kritisieren. Wenn jetzt ein Fünfjähriger bei Red Bull ins Stadion geht und einen geilen Fußball sieht, das gönne ich ihm von Herzen. Das ändert nichts daran, dass dieser Verein niemals hätte existieren dürfen. Also aus meiner Sicht.
Sagt das für einen, das reicht halt was anderes.
Das sagt leider auch der DFB in dem Fall was anderes.
Was ich beim DFB da interessant finde, weil wir das vorhin hatten mit diesen ersten Geschichten von Trikotwerbung etc. Dass es tatsächlich Zeiten gab, wo es so eine enorme, ich glaube zumindest so eine Klagebereitschaft gab. Oder so eine Bereitschaft gab, erst mal Sachen auch juristisch durchzufechten, auch wenn man dann unterliegt. Aber man hat zumindest so eine Idee von, okay, das ist was wir schützen wollen, das schützen wir auch erst mal mit einer juristischen Auseinandersetzung. Ich glaube, das ist das Einzige, was mich so ein bisschen erstaunt, dass es in diesem ganzen Zuge nicht irgendwie so einen Versuch gab, von, okay, wir sind jetzt streitlos. Erst mal, abgesehen von Andreas Rettich mit seinen Pseudo-Steinen, ja, da versucht er den Weg zu legen, aber die keine waren. Gab es nicht wirklich so eine Streitlos zu sagen, okay, wir lassen es mal drauf ankommen. Vielleicht, weil sie dann wussten, dass irgendwas an ihren Regeln bricht, was sie dann irgendwie nicht mehr retten können. Möglich, ja. Das ist zumindest die Interpretation, die die gängige ist. Aber ich finde es schon erstaunlich gegenüber von vor 30, 40 Jahren, wo es ja offensichtlich diese Streitlos-Vorgericht tatsächlich noch gab. Also das ist tatsächlich etwas, was ich so ein bisschen erstaunlich finde.
Ich glaube, da haben viele auch einfach die Vorteile gesehen, die ein potenter Fußballverein oder Investor dann mit sich bringt. Und eines der Argumente, was man oft hört, ist mit RB ist ja die Liga wenigstens wieder spannend. Und wie Uli Hoeneß im Intro sagte, jetzt gibt es noch einen neuen Feind, gegen den man schießen kann. Ich glaube, der DFB wird da Recht gewesen sein. Erstens, okay, die sind jetzt zwei Jahre bei uns im Zuständigkeitsbereich. Danach sind sie eh weg. Dann soll die DFL sich mal drum kümmern. Und zweitens, glaube ich, gibt es da sehr viele Verquickungen auch einfach bei Personal. Ich habe jetzt leider nichts schriftlich. Vielleicht hat Max sich irgendwas rausgeschrieben, welche Leute da bei wem, wo, wie, in welchen Vorständen sitzen und von wem Geld kriegen und dann eigentlich noch von Red Bull bezahlt werden. Ich glaube, da ist einfach so viel Klüngelei, die man ja auch bei Red Bull dann immer den Traditionsvereinen vorwirft, weshalb es bei Traditionsvereinen ja nicht klappt wegen dieser Klüngelei. Und der professionelle Raber achtet nicht auf Personenkult, sondern macht einfach alles nach Geld. Ja, und die gibt es halt auch so und die hat man sich halt auch zu Nutze gemacht.
Wie jein. Also die sind natürlich, wenn du den Uli Wolter siehst, der hatte natürlich eine DFB-Vergangenheit. Und natürlich sind sie nicht doof, sich irgendwie Leute zu engagieren, die gewisse Connections haben und Kontakte haben und dort gut aufgestellt sind. Aber du hast ja trotzdem und so diese Ganzen von, die spielen ja so einen guten Fußball und die machen ja die Bundesliga-Spante, sind ja alles Diskussionen und Argumente, die kommen ja erst irgendwie seit Anfang dieser Saison. Die gab es ja vorher nicht in den Diskurs. Und du hast ja vor, ich sag mal, vier, fünf Jahren, bevor RB irgendwie in die zweite Liga aufgestiegen ist, hast du so viele Leute aus Bundesliga-Vereinen, die immer gesagt haben, ja, wenn die in die DFL kommen, dann werden wir schon mal gucken. Für die lassen wir uns was einfallen. Wir wissen schon, wie wir das machen, dass die erst mal herkommen. Also du hast ja durchaus einen Diskurs von alteingesessenen Vereinen, die gesagt haben, da machen wir was. Also es gab ja schon Leute und ich sag mal, die DFL ist eine Vereinigung von 36 Vereinen. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass du da nicht haltest Sachen durchdrücken können, wo du sagst, okay, wir streiten uns jetzt mit denen aufs Messer. So und es hätte ja aus den Clubs kommen können. Selbst aus den Clubs kamen das. Da hast du so einen Watzke, der dann irgendwie so ein bisschen stichelt, aber essentiell an der Stelle, wo man hätte eingreifen können, was machen können bei der Lizenzierung, kam von den Clubs exakt nichts. So und das ist halt so ein Punkt, wie ich sage, das ist doch seltsam, weil ich glaube nicht, dass Red Bull sich die ganzen Clubs-Chefs gekocht hat, bevor sie irgendwie ihre Lizenzunterlagen bei der DFL eigenrecht haben. Ich glaube, so einfach ist es auch nicht.
Da gab es ein schönes Segment im Milan-Ton-Podcast aus dem Herbst, wo Andreas Rettig zu Gast war. Da hat er mal an einer anderen Streitfrage gezeigt, wie schwer das eigentlich ist für die kleinen Clubs. Da ging es um die Neuverteilung der Gelder zwischen erster und zweiter Liga, die ja jetzt auch für den Zweitligaclubs schlechter ausgefallen ist. Da hat er mal so ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen erzählt, wie schwer das dann auch für die Kleinen in dieser Ansammlung der Proficlubs ist, da was zu bewegen. Und da ist es wie überall, ob man jetzt in der Wirtschaft oder in der Politik ist, dass die, die am längeren Ende des Tisches sitzen, da schon Mechanismen expliziter oder impliziter haben, um sozusagen so missliebige Sachen von unten einfach schon mal so ein bisschen von vornherein auszuschließen. Und da, glaube ich, ist es genauso wie Matthias sagt, am Ende hatten dann doch die Großen vermutlich gar kein Interesse dran, RB da nicht, Red Bull nicht zuzulassen als einen neuen Player im deutschen Profifußball. Hätte man denen gesagt, wie das dann schon 2, 5 Jahre später aussieht, hätten vielleicht andere anders drüber nachgedacht, aber zumindest erst mal drauf ankommen lassen und dieses Geld und die Aufmerksamkeit und auch diese Professionalität zuzulassen, da hatten, glaube ich, die großen Vereine schon Lust drauf auch.
Ich glaube, die Angst, dass das Red Bull ihnen wirklich einen Platz wegnimmt, war einfach nicht da. Und jetzt stehen sie da ganz oben und plötzlich muss man dann noch Vierter werden, um sich überhaupt für die Champions League qualifizieren zu dürfen. Genau, das war, glaube ich, diese Blauäugigkeit, die dann auch dazu geführt hat.
Und ich kann mir zusätzlich noch vorstellen, dass viele gewusst haben, dass diese ganze rechtliche Geschichte eine fragile Angelegenheit ist. Auch da nochmal, ich tue es wirklich nicht gerne, Martin Kind zitieren, der sagt, 50 plus 1 ist juristisch angreifbar, verstößt gegen Europarecht, den freien Kapitalverkehr, Kartellrecht und Wettbewerbsrecht und eine rechtliche Prüfung bringt die ganze Verbandsregel zum Kippen. Und ich glaube, das ist den Leuten bewusst. Ich spreche es jetzt deswegen nochmal an, weil Matthias gerade gesagt hat, früher gab es da diese rechtlichen Auseinandersetzungen, jetzt ist die Streitliste irgendwie geringer geworden. Es hat ja nun hinreichend Ereignisse auch gegeben in der Vergangenheit, wo einfach dann einschneidende Dinge passiert sind. Schlichwort Bossmann-Urteil beispielsweise. Und da steht dann irgendwann auch das nächste an. Ob uns das passt oder nicht, ist das eine. Das andere ist, wie solche Gerichte dann möglicherweise entscheiden. Und auch da natürlich ist es so, wie Kind sagt, wenn man Veränderungen nicht gestaltet, schaffen sich die Marktteilnehmer Wege der Umgebung. Das war jetzt ein wörtliches Zitat. Noch angefügt, das ist nicht nur im Fußball so. Dem ist ja nun auch dann tatsächlich so. Und ich glaube, dass viele das wissen. Da kann man übrigens auch eine ganze Podcast-Folge mit verbringen, beispielsweise auch darüber zu diskutieren, wie ist das eigentlich mit dem Thema Geldstrafen. Nur mal so als Beispiel, das ist rechtlich höchst umstritten. Das tastet aber niemand an, weil da natürlich ein ganzer Rattenschwanz dranhängt und ein ganzes System ins Kippen kommt. Und da ist dann auch der gesellschaftliche Konsens da. Das will man dann irgendwie nicht. Deswegen tut man es irgendwie auch nicht. Aber ich glaube, dass das in der ganzen Angelegenheit eine nicht geringe Rolle gespielt hat.
Da schließt sich ein schöner Kreis, wo wir gerade bei Geldstrafen und Leipzig und Dortmund sind. Ich hätte zu gerne gesehen, dass der BVB wirklich mal gegen diese Südtribünensperrung vorgeht. Ich fürchte aber, dass – einfach weil das in sich argumentiert totaler Mumpens war. Da wurden dann Spruchbänder belangt, die in Leipzig gezeigt wurden, wo Brinkhoff statt Brause dran stand. Du kannst jetzt sagen, was du willst, aber das ist nichts, was du in irgendeiner Form belangen könntest. Das sind dann Sachen, wofür der DFB irgendwann gesagt hat, wir sperren euch die Tribüne. Explizit in der Urteilsberatung geschrieben hat, ey, machen wir nicht für das, was vor dem Stadion passiert ist. Dürfen wir gar nicht. Und ich hätte in dem Zusammenhang einfach zu gerne gesehen, dass sich mal so ein Verein wie der BVB, der sich danach dann auch öffentlich zerrissen gezeigt hat und gesagt hat, okay, wir akzeptieren diese Strafe, weil öffentlich so viel Druck aufgrund der Vorkommnisse vor dem Stadion auf uns lastet. Aber wir sind glasklar gegen Kollektivstrafen und bla. Ich hätte zu gerne gesehen, dass das mal ausgefochten wird, um dem DFB einfach wirklich mal ein Vorlass zu geben mit irgendwelchen unsinnigen Geldstrafen, mit Fanausschlüssen für Dinge, ja, also Menschen bestrafen, die gar nichts getan haben und so weiter. Ist halt ein bisschen doof gelaufen in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung, dass da so ein riesiger Druck auf dem Kessel war. Aber das hätte ich gerne gesehen.
Ja, das verstehe ich. Das Strafsystem ist ja tatsächlich eher geprägt durch Unnachvollziehbarkeit. Aber ich würde gerne nochmal zu der 50 plus 1 zurück, weil das Spannende, das ich dran finde, ist ja, warum ich es erstaunlich finde, dass man da keinen Klagebedürfnis oder irgendwas oder keinen Streitbedürfnis hat, ist ja, du hast eine Regel, die offensichtlich jetzt schon nicht mehr funktioniert. Also du hast eine Regel, die umgangen wird, wo es Ausnahmen gibt etc. Also du hast diverseste Vereine, die jetzt auch hopp, die die Ausnahmeregelung, der die Ausnahmeregelung gekriegt hat, kind, der sie vielleicht irgendwann übernimmt kriegst. Also du hast eine Regel, die eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr das abdeckt, was du eigentlich willst. Also welche Regel lasse ich denn juristisch prüfen, wenn ich die? Also das ist doch absurd, immer so zu tun. Wir müssen die erhalten, wir dürfen da nicht ran, wir können da nicht streiten etc. Wenn die Regel überhaupt nicht mehr das leistet, was ich von dir will. Also was ist denn das Argument zu sagen, wir müssen 50 plus 1 stützen und lass uns das bloß nicht zu Fall bringen, wenn da jemand gegenklagt. Warum? Die Regel erfüllt ihren Zweck nicht und ist doch Quatsch. Dann überlegt dir eine Regel, die irgendwie Sinn macht, die das macht, was du willst, aber dann machst du auch so, dass sie juristisch nicht angreifbar ist. Und so wie es jetzt ist, ist es totaler Unsinn. Da verteile ich dann, rette ich die 50 plus 1-Regel, aber hinten sind sechs Vereine, die sich darüber totlachen. Also das macht doch keinen Sinn.
Ich würde da auch gleich noch mal kurz reinspringen zu 50 plus 1. Ich teile die Diagnose, dass das eine Regel ist, die nicht nur der Form nach, also jetzt irgendwie dem Wortlaut nach unter Beschluss steht, sondern auch vor allem dem Geist nach, also sozusagen was man damit eigentlich will. Ich will nur kurz mal ein anderes Beispiel aus dem Profisport dagegenstellen, weil ja sozusagen häufig so ein Kurzschluss oder so eine Logik ist am kritisieren von 50 plus 1. Na ja, eben wie Herr Kindt das sagt und die Zitate sind wirklich gut und ich finde auch schön, dass du die gebracht hast, Alex, die freien Marktteilnehmer oder den Marktteilnehmer auf dem freien Markt suchen sich ihren eigenen Weg. Der sportliche Wettbewerb, gerade im Profisport, ist ja auch immer, zeichnet sich ja dadurch aus, dass es Regeln gibt, die nicht nur auf dem Platz gelten, sondern die man sich auch gibt als Wettbewerber, damit das irgendwie noch vergleichbar ist und nicht aus dem Ruder läuft. Jetzt kann man sagen, bei Formel 1 oder so Rennserien, die ändern die Regeln halt dann immer da, wie es den Großen passt, machen die auch so. Deswegen ist das manchmal auch so ein Kindergarten. Aber ein schönes Beispiel aus den durchkommerzialisiertesten Ligen der ganzen Welt, nämlich aus dem US-Sport, ist ja, dass die internen ja quasi funktionieren wie Staatssozialismus. Also die Liga nimmt zentral das Geld ein und es ist relativ eingeschränkt, wie die einzelnen Franchises selber noch Geld verdienen dürfen. Und es wird peinlich genau drauf geachtet, wie da sozusagen, dass alle ungefähr das Gleiche kriegen und alle ungefähr die gleichen Chancen haben. Also eine ganz andere Art, wie der sportliche Wettbewerb und vor allem der wirtschaftliche Wettbewerb geregelt wird.
Und das bringe ich nur deswegen als Beispiel, um zu sagen, wenn jetzt 50 plus 1 fällt oder neu gemacht wird oder besser gemacht wird, weil es eben so offensichtlich ist, dass das gerade mit europäischen Recht eigentlich nicht zusammenpasst, ist, glaube ich, nicht die nächste Logik zu sagen, jetzt gewinnt einfach der, der das meiste Geld einsetzt, weil auch da müsste man natürlich irgendeinen Riegel davor schieben, weil sonst ja auch einfach dieses, sage ich mal, Biotop, was nämlich auch so zwei Profiligen sind, wie sie die erste und die zweite und die dritte oder drei Profiligen in der dritten Liga, dann wiederum in einem europäischen und weltweiten Kontext darstellt, ja auch wieder gefährdet. Also es gibt irgendwie ein Grundinteresse, dass die doch alle ein bisschen zusammenhalten. Und die Frage ist eben, wie geht man jetzt damit um? Dass jemand nicht nur reinpumpt, sondern das auch noch sinnvoll tut oder irgendwie das noch gut tut im Sinne von wirtschaftlichen Erfolg. Und da bin ich mal gespannt. Und ich glaube nicht, dass sozusagen der Freifahrtsschein jetzt gewinnt, der das meiste investiert. Die Lösung ist auch im Sinne einer funktionierenden und schön anzuschauenden Liga.
Wir sind mitten im nächsten Kritikpunkt gelandet, den man aber nicht nur an Leipzig anlegen kann. Das ist, glaube ich, eine wichtige Prämisse, die man hier gleich voraus schicken muss. Und dahinter steht ja, dass der sportliche Wettbewerb – das hast du gerade ganz schön herausgearbeitet, finde ich, Andreas – durch die 50 plus 1-Regel geschützt werden soll. Noch mal ganz kurz, was bedeutet 50 plus 1? Das bedeutet sehr verkürzt gesagt, ein Investor oder jemand, der sich mit Geld an einem Fußballverein beteiligt, darf nie die Entscheidungsmehrheit haben. Das heißt, der Verein soll sich nie nach diesem Investor richten müssen, sondern eben 50 plus 1 stimmprozentuale Stimmverteilung soll immer beim Verein bleiben. Und jetzt haben wir hier zwei Prämissen, die bei Diskussionen dieses Punkt wichtig sind. Das eine ist eben festzustellen, diese Regel wurde schon mehrfach ausgehöhlt. Und es ist die Frage, ob sie dann in dem Sinn überhaupt den Wettbewerb überhaupt noch schützt, denn es gibt schon Ausnahmen von der Regel. Wir haben das Modell, das Kind durchgesetzt hat, hatten wir vor Ewigkeiten schon angesprochen. Alex hat das damals genannt. Dass Unternehmen oder Investoren, die sich 20 Jahre bei einem Verein engagieren, von dieser Regel befreit sind. Und wir haben gewisse Sonderregelungen auch für Hoffenheim, für Leverkusen, zum Beispiel für VfL Wolfsburg auch. Das heißt, dieser Wettbewerbsschutz, den diese Regel bieten soll, eben vor einer Verzerrung des Wettbewerbs zu schützen, den gibt es de facto schon jetzt nicht. Und die zweite Besonderheit ist aber, und darauf weist auch Andreas Rettig in der wirklich sehr empfehlenswerten Millantonausgabe, die auch definitiv verlinkt wird in den Show Notes hin, dass auch hier Rasenballsport Leipzig eine neue Qualität reingebracht hat. Denn diese 50 plus 1-Regel ist vom Verein ausgedacht. Das heißt, wir sprechen hier immer darum, dass aus einem Verein eine andere Gesellschaft ausgegliedert wird, die für den Fußballbereich zuständig ist. Egal, ob das eine Kommandate-Gesellschaft auf Aktien ist, wie in Dortmund oder in der GmbH, wie es in Leipzig der Fall ist. Und bei Leipzig war aber der Ablauf umgekehrt, weil der Verein quasi nur gegründet wurde, um diese 50 plus 1-Regel zu erfüllen. Und wir jetzt eben dann eine 99-prozentige Beteiligung Red Bulls am Verein haben. Aber das eine Prozent, was der Verein hält, sind die stimmberechtigten Prozente. Und jetzt sitzt aber innerhalb dieses Vereins dann wiederum Red Bull-Mitarbeiter, nahestehende Personen. Wir wollen über das ganze Konstrukt können wir dann später noch genauer reden. Und jetzt stellen sich ja dann zwei Fragen. Zum einen, wir haben eine Regel, die soll eine Verzerrung des Wettbewerbs schützen, die jetzt schon ausgehöhlt ist. Das können wir bestimmt nicht Leipzig vorwerfen. Und die zweite Frage ist, hat man denn wirklich einen Wettbewerbsvorteil? Also was ist denn da eigentlich der Vorwurf, den man machen kann? Wirtschaftliche Planungssicherheit losgelöst vom sportlichen Erfolg?
Ich glaube, was zumindest auf Fanseite immer geil ist, dieser 50 plus 1-Regel war, war gar nicht die sportliche Gleichbehandlung, weil der FC Bayern hat halt einfach mehr Geld und da würde ein Investor in Hannover vielleicht sogar ganz gut tun, um da ein bisschen mehr Gleichmäßigkeit zu schaffen. Sondern ich glaube, von Fansicht war es immer die abschreckenden Beispiele, was Investoren für verbrannte Erde hinterlassen und das Investoren, wenn sie die Lust verlieren, zum Beispiel einfach den Verein, den man ja selber im Herzen trägt, zugrunde richten. In Salzburg erfährt man das gerade mit Red Bull, wie das so passiert, wenn der Browser-Hersteller plötzlich ein neues Spielzeug hat und dann sämtliche Assets und Starspieler abgezogen werden. Ich glaube, das war dann etwas, was zumindest von Fan-Seite aus immer im Fokus stand. Und an einer Stelle wollte ich ihn korrigieren. Ich glaube, Hoffenheim hat keine Sonderregelungen, sondern Dietmar Hopp hat de facto einfach – also die Jure, nicht de facto – die Jure nichts zu sagen. Ist kein Präsident oder sowas, sondern einfach nur Mitglied. Ist halt aber einfach der Geldgeber.
Naja, ich glaube, in Hoffenheim ist eigentlich der erste Verein, der von dieser 20-Jahre-Regel quasi profitiert hat. Also die waren die ersten vor zwei Jahren, die nach dieser Regeländerung den Antrag gestellt haben, dass Hopp hundertprozentiger eigener werden kann. Also die sind tatsächlich eine Ausnahme.
Ja, mittlerweile.
Das waren sie früher nicht, aber sie waren die ersten, die dann gesagt haben, nachdem Kind diese Regelung durchgekompromisst hat beim DFB. Die waren die ersten, die davon profitierten. Andreas hatte dich gestern auch nochmal erklärt in der Sky-Diskussion zu 50 bis 1.
Ja, außerdem die von vornherein schon als Beispiel gehalten. Das heißt ja nicht grundlos Lex Leverkusen.
Ja, aber was machen wir jetzt mit diesem Argument, dass der sportliche Wettbewerb dadurch verzerrt wird? Was hier ein wichtiger Punkt ist.
Verzerrt durch 50 plus 1 oder durch das Auflösen von 50 plus 1 quasi?
Durch das Auflösen von 50 plus 1?
Ich glaube nicht, dass…
Oder das umgehen, das kreative Umgehen von 50 plus 1?
Ja, das Umgehen ist viel eher das Problem, weil gefühlt für die einen Klubs andere Regeln gelten als für andere. Deshalb glaube ich auch, dass eine Auflösung von 50 plus 1 gar nicht so viel ändern würde. Denn letzten Endes ist das jetzt abgesehen von Red Bull oder Hoffenheim oder auch Wolfsburg und Ewa Cousen einfach so, dass die Vereine, die die größte Strahlkraft haben, immer die finanzstärkeren Investoren anziehen werden. Das heißt, Hannover 96, das einfach unfassbar langweilig ist und niemanden interessiert, außer einen Podcast… Ist einfach die grauste Maus der zweiten Bundesliga. Also da werden dann außer Kind, der vielleicht Bock hat, Geld reinzustecken, werden die Leute trotzdem lieber zum FC Bayern gehen und da ihr Geld reinstecken. Auch wenn sie dann nur eine kleine Bande kriegen. Aber die kleine Bande ist halt in der Champions League zu sehen und nicht nur in der zweiten Bundesliga. Deshalb glaube ich, dass eine Auflösung von 50 plus 1 insofern gar nichts ändern würde. Das aktuelle Problem ist einfach, dass es 35… nein, 30 Vereine gibt, die sich dran halten müssen. Und sechs, sieben Vereine, die es schon umgangen haben oder für die Ausnahmeregeln gelten. Und die haben halt jetzt aktuell diesen Vorteil.
Letztlich ist die Frage, was…
tatsächlich ist es ja wirtschaftlich kein Vorteil.
Na gut, dass man wohl Geld reinbuttern kann, wie sie wollen, ohne dass da irgendwie irgendwas…
Ja, vor allem kann Red Bull mitbestimmen. Also die These, die hinter 50 plus 1 steht und die auch viele Befürwörter der Aufhebung dieser 50 plus 1-Regel vertreten ist, dass das unter anderem Investoren davon abhält, sich im deutschen Fußball zu engagieren, weil es eben nicht so ist wie in anderen Legen, dass du für das Geld, das du gibst, auch Mitbestimmungsrechte bekommst und doof gesagt sagen kannst, was mit dem Geld dann eingesetzt wird. Und das ist natürlich bei Leipzig durch das Umgehen dieser Regel schon der Fall. Red Bull weiß, die 100 Millionen, die wir da reinstecken, die werden auch genauso eingesetzt, wie wir das haben wollen nach dem sportlichen Konzept, das wir haben wollen und aber auch mit allen anderen Bereichen. Also da kommt dann keiner auf die Idee, wir bauen jetzt nicht einen riesigen roten Bullen vor das Trainingsgelände, sondern dann wird das halt einfach gemacht.
Haben die den nicht gebaut?
Der wurde nie genutzt als Skaterpark. Ne, den tut er noch, aber es wurden so Sitzgelegenheit drauf gebaut. Ja, auch großer Skandal damals.
Genau so gut funktioniert wie Red Bull Salzburg.
Das Grundproblem ist doch aber ja letztlich nicht die Strukturfrage, sondern das Grundproblem ist, dass jemand, der sagt, mir ist es irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 100 Millionen wert, hier Fußball hinzustellen. Das Thema ist doch letztlich die grundsätzliche Frage, wie kann man in der Liga Wettbewerbsgleichheit herstellt und nicht die Frage, wie ist es letztlich organisiert. Ich verhalte das immer für so eine Schein-Debatte, sich darüber Gedanken zu machen. Also andersrum. Das Argument gestern hier bei der Diskussion von Andreas Rettich und Philipp Köster war ja eher, okay, mit 50 plus 1 Mitbestimmung hat man Identifikation, Emotion etc. Ohne ist Fußball nicht denkbar, geht nur, wenn man irgendwie mitbestimmen kann. Halt ich für ein seltsames Argument, weil ich glaube, Emotion und Identifikation hat ja schon erklärt, dass es auch auf einer anderen Ebene geht. Aber das Argument ist ja eher so ein emotionales, wo man sagt, okay, Fußball mit Fans funktioniert nur über diese Mitbestimmung. Das ist ja kein wirtschaftliches Argument. Und so sehe ich es eigentlich auch. Du hast eigentlich auf so einer Ebene nicht wirklich einen essentiellen wirtschaftlichen Vorteil dadurch, dass du eine andere Struktur baust. Du brauchst trotzdem jemanden, der das Geld reinsteckt.
Du hast einen Wettbewerbsvorteil, keinen wirtschaftlichen Vorteil.
Na, du hast Planungssicherheit, oder?
Richtig. ZB werden Freiburg, die müssen halt schauen, bis in April rein, ob die jetzt – ich meine, die sind clever, die geben nur Verträge raus an die Lizenzspieler, die auch für die 2. Liga gelten. Aber was z.B. die Tätigkeit auf dem Transfermarkt angeht. Und da hast du gerade, wenn du noch als so eine internationale Firma mit so vielen Franchises aufgebaut bist, natürlich ganz anderen Handlungsspielraum. Und wie gerade im Red Bull-System ja auch die Spieler transferiert werden und wo sie geparkt und entwickelt werden. Und wann man auf diese Ressourcen, die ja dann am Ende die Spieler auf dem Platz sind und die Leistung bringen sollen, zurückgreift, das ist ein ganz klarer Wettbewerbsvorteil, den andere so nicht haben.
Da geht es um Ressourcen und Geld-Einsatz und nicht darum, ob ich irgendwie 50 plus 1 erfülle oder nicht. Ja, aber ohne 50 plus 1...
Also das ist ja das, wenn ich von Finanz-Doping spreche, dann meine ich, dass ein Verein aus der fünften Lila mit sehr viel Geld in eine Position gebracht wurde, in sehr kurzer Zeit, dass er nur durch den massiven Geldeinsatz erreichen konnte. Und das passiert auch deshalb so reibungslos, in Anführungsstrichen, weil es einen doppelten Boden gibt, und zwar Geld. Wenn Red Bull nicht aufsteigt, dann packt Red Bull mehr Geld rein. Frag mal den ersten FC Kaiserslautern, was passiert, wenn die nicht aufsteigen und deshalb fast pleite gehen. Frag mal Alemannia Aachen, was passiert, wenn die nicht in der dritten Liga spielen und deshalb das Stadion nicht mehr bezahlen können. Frag mal den MSV Duisburg oder SG Wattenscheid 09. Die hatten alle diesen doppelten Boden nicht. Die, das sind Traditionsvereine, und das wird ja immer argumentiert, Red Bull ist doch sportlich aufgestiegen. Die Traditionsvereine könnten doch genauso gut arbeiten. Ja, könnten sie. Sie haben aber das Problem, dass, wenn sie Fehler machen, diese Fehler nicht einfach negiert werden durch das Geld, was dahinter steckt. Und die, also das Zuschauerinteresse dort ist, oder ihr hattet das ja angesprochen, beim SSV Markranstädt und dann auch bei Red Bull in den ersten Jahren war so überschaubar, dass da eigentlich kein Sponsor hingegangen wäre und gesagt hätte, boah, 2000 Leute, hier stecke ich jetzt mal 200 Millionen Euro rein. Das ist nur passiert, weil Red Bull da hingekommen ist. Genauso wie es zum Beispiel in Hoffenheim nur passiert ist. Nein, aber das ist ja wieder dieses, die eine Marke bedingt die andere. Beim BVB kommen die Sponsoren, weil es eine Strahlkraft gibt. Beim FC Bayern engagiert sich Adidas oder Audi mit 100 Millionen Euro, weil sie die Strahlkraft des Vereins nutzen wollen. Und das war halt bei Red Bull nicht so. Bei Red Bull wurde diese Strahlkraft künstlich erschaffen, dadurch, dass halt erst investiert wurde. Der Markt hätte das nie ermöglicht quasi, dass Red Bull so aufsteigt.
Sind wir doch beieinander. Das ist ja überhaupt nicht der Punkt. Es geht mir doch nicht darum, dass die irgendwie viel Geld reingepumpt haben und den Vorteil haben, dass sie, wenn es nicht klappt, irgendwie ein Jahr später sagen, okay, dann probieren wir das vielleicht mit noch ein bisschen mehr Geld und mit anderen Leuten nochmal. Das ist ja gar nicht der Punkt. Mein Punkt war ja nur, du kannst doch, mein Punkt war ja nur zu sagen, das liegt doch aber nicht daran, ob es 50 plus 1 gibt oder nicht, sondern daran, dass jemand sagt, ich pumpe jetzt so lange Geld rein, bis mir das Erfolg bringt. Nimm alle manier Aachen, die irgendwie gerade kurz vor der Insolvenz stehen und Investoren vor der Tür stehen und sagen, wir stecken hier Geld rein, wenn das und das die Voraussetzung ist. Du kannst doch als Investor genauso zu einem 50 plus 1 Verein gehen und dir die Abhängigkeit zu dir schaffen und die über die Jahre hochpumpen, bis die irgendwann in der Champions League spielen. Das ist doch keine Frage von grundsätzlicher Organisationsstruktur, ob jemand sagt, ich habe Bock, irgendwie das Geld da reinzustecken und irgendwie um anzukommen. Klar, hast du eine größere Sicherheit, dass nicht irgendjemand in dem Verein sitzt und sagt, ich nimm hier die 20 Millionen und koffier meinen Schwiegersohn ein. Aber grundsätzlich ändert es doch nichts, was das für eine Struktur ist, eine Organisationsstruktur ist, ob du da irgendwie viel Geld reinstecken kannst oder wenig Geld reinstecken kannst. Deswegen sage ich nur, letztlich kann man sich irgendwie 30 Jahre lang über Organisationsstrukturen unterhalten. Aber letztlich ist ja die spannende Frage, wie organisierst du einen Wettbewerb, der es möglich macht, dass nicht irgendjemand kommt und sagt, ok, ich gebe 150 Millionen hier Sponsoringgeld und der nächste hat 10. Weil dann hast du natürlich per se ein Ungleichgewicht. Das ist ja eher die spannende und wahrscheinlich unlösbare Frage. Im Gegensatz zu der Scheindibatte, brauchen wir 50 plus 1, da brauchen wir nicht. Und was sind die Organisationsstrukturen? Das, finde ich, ist letztlich eine lokale Frage, wer was worauf Bock hat.
Aber das heißt, du würdest ja schon zustimmen, dass Leipzig einen Wettbewerbsvorteil hat gegenüber nicht allen Bundesligisten, sondern ganz vielen, die eben nicht diesen finanziellen doppelten Boden haben, bei dem Fehler einfach leichter verziehen werden. Das ist ja auch so ein gern gebrachtes Argument, was ja auch stimmt. Der sportliche Erfolg wurde Leipzig ja auch nicht geschenkt. Kein Team hat gesagt, oh, ihr seid so reich, wir legen uns jetzt auf den Rücken wie ein Käfer, und ihr dürft jetzt einfach freiwillig aufsteigen. Nein, da mussten auch sportliche Entscheidungen getroffen werden, die funktionieren mussten. Und die sogenannten Traditionsvereine, da findet man ganz, ganz viele Beispiele, wo das nicht geklappt hat. Dafür kann ja Leipzig nichts. Aber der Unterschied ist einfach, dass man eben einen doppelten Boden hat. Das heißt, man fällt eben nicht so tief wie andere, wenn man Fehler macht. Würdest du schon zustimmen, dass es diesen Wettbewerbsvorteil gibt?
Ja, absolut. Klar hast du den Wettbewerbsvorteil. Und der hast du ja schon auf einer sehr viel kleineren Ebene in Ingolstadt und Augsburg genauso, den der zweiten Liga auch immer mal Mist gemacht haben und irgendwie ihre Trainer gewechselt haben. Und das konnten, weil dahinter jemand stand, der gesagt hat, okay, das ist mein langfristiges Ziel. Und klar hast du das bei AB Leipzig extrem, auch wenn sie irgendwie von Vierter an die Dritte und dann die Zweite das nicht ausspielen mussten in der Form, wie es möglich gewesen wäre. Aber klar ist das ein Wettbewerbsvorteil absolut. Natürlich, weil die RB Leipzig ist in der Regionalliga immer ein U-Boot gewesen. Das war jenseits dessen, was es war, Schelja hat in den Etagen 16 andere Mannschaften zusammenhärten. Also klar ist das auf der Ebene ein U-Boot gewesen, was eher jetzt langsam, wo sie in der Bundesliga ankommen, sie quasi zum ersten Mal eine Situation haben, wo sie tatsächlich Vereine über sich haben, wirtschaftlich.
Ich finde, da haben wir eigentlich auch ganz gut rausgearbeitet, warum das zwar indirekt, aber dann auch nicht direkt in der Kausalität zumindest nicht mit 50 plus 1 zu tun hat. Das sind Debatten, die schon miteinander zusammenhängen, aber nicht das eine bedingt das andere. 50 plus 1 war eher das Vehikel, was aber von anderen auch schon entsprechend verwendet wurde. Jetzt haben wir aber noch einen zweiten Vorwurf gegenüber Rasenballsport Leipzig, der auch mit einer Verzerrung des Wettbewerbs zu tun hat. Den würde ich jetzt gerne an der Stelle auch mit euch durchdiskutieren. Und zwar zum einen durch die Konstruktion, dass man eben mit anderen Vereinen zusammenhängt und sich Spieler fröhlich hin und her schieben kann zu Konditionen, die man – ich sage das jetzt einfach mal so und ihr müsst mir vom Gegenteil überzeugen, wenn es anders ist. Man kann sich die Kondition selbst überlegen und dann wechselt halt auch jemand aus der österreichischen Liga, die bisher nicht dafür bekannt war, meiner Meinung nach, dass man da sich Leute für 15 Millionen holt, wechselt aber jemand auch mal mit diesem Betrag zwischen Salzburg und Leipzig und was da eben noch mit reinkommt, ist eine europäische Komponente. Wir sprechen dann hier von Financial Fair Play, nachdem sich Investoren nicht so mehr als mit 30 Prozent bei einem Verein wirksam machen dürfen.
Nicht mehr als 30 Prozent des Umsatzes ausmachen.
Danke, es ist schon langsam.
Das ist übrigens falsch, weil es zum 20. Mal irgendjemand wiederholt ist. Die Regelung gibt es einfach nicht. Also die ist einfach Quatsch. Es gibt eine Regelung, dass wenn du mehr als 30 Prozent des Itars trägst, du quasi als Eigentümer gilfst, egal ob du das formal bist oder nicht, gilfst du dann als Partei mit bestimmendem Einfluss, glaube ich heißt das auf IFA Deutsch. Aber es gibt keine Regelung, die dir verbietet, mehr als 30 Prozent des Itars zu decken.
Das Problem wird erst, wenn diese Partei mit bestimmendem Einfluss bei mehr als einem Verein, dann wird es ja erst das Problem. Aber wie du sagst, klar, es ist nicht verboten, dass in einer Franchise Red Bull mehr als 30 Prozent macht. Und das Witzige ist ja auch, dass dieses Argument, was Max gerade hatte mit den Ablösen, das haben sie ja deswegen auch wohl so hoch gemacht, um Red Bull Salzburg von genau diesen Problemen nämlich frei zu machen. Also die hohen Ablösen aus Leipzig waren ja dann das Argument, betriebswirtschaftlich oder buchhalterisch, um zu sagen, ach ja, ne, also hier Red Bull Salzburg, da ist ja gar nicht Red Bull mit über 30 Prozent bestimmte Partei, sondern die wirtschaften ja ganz gut und nehmen ihr Geld ja eigentlich durch was ganz anderes ein. Der Witz ist natürlich, dass dieses Geld aus Leipzig kam. Und ja, also spannendes Thema, weil man auch sieht, dass entgegen den ersten Äußerungen, die da vor allem aus Leipzig kamen, jetzt heute hat ja Oliver Minzlaff auch angekündigt, seinen Job da als Global Head of Soccer für Red Bull Niederzulegen mit der Versehen, mit dem schönen Hinweis aus freien Stücken.
Wir wünschen ihm auf seinem weiteren Lebensweg bei Rasenballsport Leipzig alles Gute.
Er hat es ja schon weit geschafft. Er war früher immer Manager unter anderem von Andrea Berg. Ich meine, jetzt war er Global Head of Soccer und ich glaube, er tauscht den Job. Das wird so ähnlich sein wie beim Paps. Nicht gegen irgendwas ein, was drunter liegt. Also mal schauen, was da passiert. Sorry für die Zuspitzung am Rande. Vielleicht auch der späten Stunde. Und meiner Getränke war in der letzten halben Stunde geschuldet.
Lass mich raten, keine Brause eines großen österreichischen Herstellers.
Nein, es ist eine versetzte Brause aus lokalem Anbau. Ich glaube, das hat ihn wirklich schon ein bisschen Probleme und Angst gemacht. Das sieht man eben daran, dass er jetzt zum Beispiel doch den Job aufgibt. Da haben ja tatsächlich auch Medien nachgehakt. Es gab diesen schönen WDR Sport und Zeitbericht mit dem Bonmot, dass die Drehgenehmigung für das Trainingsgelände aus Salzburg in Leipzig verteilt werden musste. Also da sieht man, wie eng das natürlich nach wie vor zusammenhängt. Das ist das Red Bull Trainingsgelände. Ja, genau.
Das ist nicht das Salzburger Trainingsgelände, sondern das ist das Red Bull Trainingsgelände. Head of Soccer Red Bull ist Oliver Münzler wahrscheinlich bis dahin der ganz plausible und nichts Ansprechpartner gewesen.
Ja, ich meinte nur welches Red Bull Trainingsgelände ist, deswegen habe ich Salzburg gesagt, um eben genau das Problem auseinanderzuhalten, um das es da nämlich geht. Im Endeffekt ist diese Struktur, die Red Bull geschaffen hat, natürlich ein – deswegen sage ich das auch die ganze Zeit, ich sage das nicht aus bösem Willen, sondern das ist, die bauen das Franchise-System, versuchen sie, das amerikanische Franchise-System in den globalen Fußball einzubauen. Und das hat bislang ganz gut geklappt, gerade was die Entwicklung von Talenten und die Sichtung von Talenten angeht. Nabicator und Emil Forsberg, ich denke, das sind Spieler, wo man sagen kann, dass die in fünf Jahren bei ganz anderen Vereinen spielen. Und das sind beides Kandidaten potenziell für Weltfußballer des Jahres. Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, wie bauen sie ihre Struktur dahingehend um, dass sie mit diesen Regeln noch konform gehen. Da bin ich sehr gespannt auch auf den Sommer, wie konsequent die UEFA da tatsächlich sein wird.
Also um kurz diesen Punkt fertig zu bringen, damit jede Hörerin und jeder Hörer das vor Augen hat. Also du hast natürlich vollkommen recht, Matthias, dass man mehr als 30 Prozent Investment in einem Verein hat. Das ist nicht verboten. Aber da wollte ich eigentlich noch dazu kommen. Es geht um die Gefährdung der Integrität des Wettbewerbs. Das heißt, wenn wir eben von der Europa League oder der Champions League sprechen und zwei Mannschaften treten an, wobei beiden Mannschaften die Bedingungen eben nicht gegeben sind, dass jemand 30 Prozent oder drunter ist und eben automatisch als der Bestimmer, würde ich mein Zwilling gegenüber formulieren, dann ist die Integrität des Wettbewerbs gefährdet, weil man natürlich nicht weiß, hat das Auswirkungen, wenn diese beiden Mannschaften aufeinandertreffen würden. Und das scheint, so wie man jetzt lesen kann und in aktuellen Berichten nachvollziehen kann, der UEFA ein hohes Gut zu sein, wo man durchaus genauer hinguckt und ist ja auch relativ leicht nachvollziehbar. Und dafür muss sich jetzt Leipzig, sowohl Leipzig als auch Salzburg, müssen sich dafür rüsten, was ja schon zeigt, dass man bisher mit diesen Regelungen, das hatte man bisher noch nicht auf dem Schirm.
Na ja, doch, man hat das schon länger, ich glaube, seit zwei Jahren oder so hat man das locker auf dem Schirm, weil es gab, ich glaube, vor zwei Jahren oder so war es zum ersten Mal, wo jemand dranglich die Frage gestellt hat, ob er denn noch irgendwie länger in Salzburg bleibt und er gesagt hat, ne, kann er schon wegen zukünftigen UEFA-Geschichten nicht. Also das Thema haben sie eigentlich schon relativ lange auf dem Schirm, dass so diese ganze Struktur mit Ranglik hat, zwei Vereine etc. eigentlich nicht funktioniert und dass sie da agieren müssen. Und generell mal jetzt von dieser Minzlav-Geschichte, der nicht mehr Chef von Red Bull Soccer ist, wo er sowieso ja formal schon nicht für Salzburg zuständig war, hat man eigentlich im letzten Jahr eigentlich alles dafür getan, diese formalen Regeln, die die UEFA oft stellt, zumindest zu erfüllen. Eigentlich ist es letztlich aus meiner Sicht der Situation eher so eine Frage, weswegen bin ich glaube ich auch so auf dieser Streitlust herumgeritten, eher eine Frage, wie streitlustig ist die UEFA im Gegensatz zum DFB? Haben die Bock irgendwie, sich zu streiten? Haben die Bock irgendwie auf die Auseinandersetzung? Auch wenn formal eigentlich nichts dagegen spricht, dass die Vereine unabhängig sind, also formal unabhängig sind. Haben die Bock, das durchzustreiten, weil es genug informelle Fakten gibt, die sich vor Gericht dann irgendwie belegen ließen? Keine Ahnung. Also diese Trennung oder diese formale Trennung geht so weit, dass du inzwischen nicht mal mehr den Fußballverein von Red Bull Salzburg auf dieser großen Übersichtseite Red Bulls kommend findest. Oder findest du irgendwie Red Bull München Eishockey, Red Bull Salzburg, Eishockey, RB Leipzig, Red Bull New York, aber nicht mehr Red Bull Salzburg. Und das ist halt schon alles so im letzten Jahr passiert, wo sie schon gucken, was müssen wir der UEFA anbieten, dass wir da durchkommen. Und aus meiner Sicht hängt es daran, wie streitlustig ist die UEFA und wie streitlustig ist sie nicht.
Aber, und das wird jetzt eine zweite Frage, die ich da dran hängen würde, und ich finde nämlich, deswegen gehören die beiden Punkte, über die wir jetzt in den letzten Minuten gesprochen haben, zusammen. Geht mit dieser Struktur nicht auch eine Wettbewerbsverzerrung im nationalen Vergleich einher, weil man eben einfach die Möglichkeit hat, in seinen Bilanzen buchhalterische Tricks anzuwenden? Also, doof gesagt, wenn es jetzt bei Leipzig gerade mal ganz blöd liefe und man aus irgendeinem Grund Kapital bräuchte, was aber Leipzig Red Bull nicht als Sponsorenzulage zuschießen möchte oder als Darlehen, da können wir auch gleich nochmal drüber sprechen, dann verkaufe ich eben meinen zweiten Torhüter für 40 Millionen an Salzburg. Dem kann ja, zumindest meinem Kenntnisstand nach, kein Riegel von keiner Seite vorgeschoben werden. Und damit kann man ja dann auch Geldströme hin und her schieben, so wie man es gerade buchhalterisch braucht. Und ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass Leipzig sonst nicht überleben würde. Das ist natürlich Quatsch. Dahinter steht ja ein Milliardenkonzern. Aber das ist doch dann wiederum auch wieder für die nationalen Ligen ein Problem, wo ja Lizenzauflagen zu erfüllen sind, die alle auf denselben Bilanzen basieren.
Ich möchte das noch kurz ein Stück weiter spinnen, bevor die Frage beantwortet wird. Vielleicht wird sich dann irgendwann auch der Fiskus oder Uli Hoeneß dafür interessieren, was da so passiert, wenn dann Insolvenzverschleppung und sowas zum Tragen kommen sollte.
Ja, man kann natürlich theoretische Szenarien spinnen. Letztlich sitzen auf jeder Seite beden Seiten Unternehmen, die irgendwie ihren Ämtern rechenschaftschuldig sind und Bilanzen vorweisen müssen. Die stimmt so. Und bis jetzt fällt mir spontan nicht in Transfer ein, der nicht irgendwie marktüblich gewesen wäre. Also wenn diese 15 Millionen für Keter, wenn er dorthin gegangen wäre, wo er hätte auch hingehen können, nämlich nach Paris Saint-Germain oder zu Arsenal London, hätten sie die 15 Millionen locker erlöst. Wahrscheinlich sogar noch 3 Millionen mehr. So wie bei Sadio Mani, der ist ja auch für irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 15, 18 Millionen gegangen nach England. So, bis jetzt hast du nicht, du hast in den Transfers zwischen RB und RB ja nicht wirklich irgendwie Anhaltspunkte dafür, dass da irgendwie Marktübliche Preise...
Naja, also zum Beispiel, ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht über jeden Spieler diskutieren, aber Opa Meccano, ein 18-jähriger Innenverteidiger, kennen durchaus einen Begriff, aber den für 10 Millionen Euro zu holen...
Wenn du dich mit Barcelona streitest, die sie ein halbes Jahr später geholt hätten, wie gesagt, von Barcelona hätten sie nicht weniger gekriegt.
Aber ich weiß nicht, welcher Spieler es war, aber gab es nicht bei einem Spieler sogar das Zitat von Ralf Rangnick, der jetzt erstmal bei Leipzig spielt und man sich dann später um die Formalitäten kümmert? So wie Ablöse und sowas?
Das war Bernardo am Anfang der Saison, den sie so drei Tage vor Transferfenster schließen wollte.
Und am Tag eines wichtigen Spiels, ich glaube sogar Derby von Salzburg, wenige Stunden vor dem Spiel, das war auch einer der Punkte, an dem die Stimmung da in Salzburg gekippt ist, dass da ein wichtiger Spieler einfach mal rübergeschoben wird.
Ja, wobei Bernardo – ich glaube, Bernardo war in Salzburg jetzt nicht der Spieler an den Ziegen. Ich glaube, das war früher so – Stefan Oelsanker war so der erste, wo man so sehr unzufrieden war in Salzburg, dass der dann gegangen ist. Weil letztlich – du kannst über diese Spielertransfer – ich glaube, der große Vorteil bei den Spielertransfers zwischen RB Leipzig und Red Bull Salzburg ist, dass du am Ende – und das ist ja diese Rangnick-Aussage – dass du am Ende kein Thema hast, das Red Bull Salzburg mehr sagt zu dem Transfer. Und was du aber trotzdem hast, du musst erstens irgendwie einen marktüblichen Transferpreis in deine Bilanz schreiben und du musst zweitens den Spieler davon überzeugen, dass er zu dir kommt. An den Punkten kommst du nicht vorbei. Und dann kannst du dich lustig machen, dass Rangnick sagt, Upa Mikano war der schwerste Transfer seines Lebens. War es aber trotzdem, weil er irgendwie den Berater überzeugen musste. Er ist mein ungeteiltes Mitleid von dir.
Das muss schlimm gewesen sein. Oder auch so wenige finanzielle Mittel hat, um die Berater zu überzeugen. Ganz, ganz schlimm. Armer Ralf Rangnick.
Also, Entschuldigung. Letztlich geht es darum, dass du irgendwie den Spielern zeigen musst, was ist ihre Perspektive. Und da gibt es irgendwie relativ viele Geschichten, wo das funktioniert hat. Wo die Leute sagen, nimm den Cater, der einfach irgendwie vorher zwei Jahre in Salzburg war, von Rangnick das Salzburg holt wurde. Wo Klaver, wenn Rangnick zu Cater geht und sagt, hier, der nächste Schritt ist hier, in zwei Jahren stehst du dort, hast die Chance, das und das zu machen. Das Cater erst mal sagt, okay, das klingt cool, das ist für mich was, was zu machen ist. Also du musst Spieler ja trotzdem davon überzeugen, dass sie den nächsten Schritt, den sie gehen wollen, in Leipzig gehen wollen. Daran kommst du ja nicht vorbei. Und das ist halt bei Uwe Meccano auch ein Stück weit so gewesen, weil sie ihn erst nach Salzburg holt haben und er dort die Schritte erst in Lieferring Salzburg gemacht hat, sich entwickelt hat. Und sie deswegen deine Chance hatten, den auch nach Leipzig weiter zu holen. Aber in diesen Sachen kommst du ja nicht vorbei. Das ist ja doch was Bernardo auch gesagt hat, als sei er hier schon wieder von Seite zu Seite. Er sagt, ja, ich treffe meine Entscheidung selber, was meine Karriere ist. Und das ist mir völlig egal, was sie erzählt. Ich glaube, man tut sich immer nicht so in richtigen Gefallen dazu, wenn man sagt, die werden da von A nach B verschoben. Früher ist man Neekampel, Rameo etc. Die sind irgendwie in die Bundesliga nach England gewechselt, weil sie keinen Bock hatten, nach Leipzig zu gehen. Wenn man nach Rangney gegangen wäre, wären sie nach Leipzig gegangen. Die Chance hattest du aber damals nicht, die Leute nach Leipzig zu holen. Dafür haben sie ein gutes Geld eingenommen. Schon bevor die nach Leipzig gegangen sind, haben sie gutes Geld eingenommen. Der große Vorteil bei diesen Spielertransfers ist, dass du am Ende des Tages dich nicht mit dem abgebenden Klubs streiten musst, weil der irgendwie sagt, da bleibt nur ein halbes Jahr bei mir. Das ist letztlich der große Vorteil.
Und der große Vorteil ist, dass du fünf Spielerkader hast, die du nutzen kannst, um Trial und Error nach dem Felix-Mangert-Prinzip zu machen. Also, da hast du mir gerade, als du diese Upa-Meccano-Geschichte erzählt hast, Lieferigen, Salzburg, Leipzig, ist mir schon so ein bisschen der Kamm geschwollen, als ich gedacht habe, Alter, euch ist aber schon klar, was ihr da für eine riesige Farm aufbaut und dass ihr da einfach 60, 70 Spieler durch das Raster jagen könnt und euch am Ende dann die besten 18 aussucht. Also das macht Felix sonst mit einem Verein.
Das ist letztlich ein Farnsystem. Es gab letztens einen Kicker-Interview mit irgendeinem Bundesliga-Mann, der gesagt hat, das ist das Modell der Zukunft. Letztlich ist es für mich sowieso die Frage, warum gibt es nicht mehr Vereine, die Kooperationen, was ich in der dritten Liga, auch in der zweiten Liga im Ausland suchen und sagen, wir brauchen eine Station, wo Spieler einen Schritt machen können und wo dann irgendwie zum Schluss drei rauskommen, die gut sind. Dieses Lieferings-Salzburg-Modell, das ist in Österreich noch ein bisschen anders, weil du ja quasi über so eine, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die heißen, Vertragsspieler, die sind beim einen Verein angestellt, spielen aber beim anderen und du kannst sie aber jederzeit für ein Spiel hochziehen. Du hast ja eine viel engere Möglichkeit, Spieler zu entwickeln, weil du sie vom Regelwerk her einfach auch in der Bundesliga einsetzen kannst und dann die nächsten zehn Spiele spielen sie wieder bei dem anderen Verein, also bei unabhängigen Vereinen voneinander, spielen sie wieder in der zweiten Liga. Also das ist ja da viel einfacher und warum man in Deutschland aber irgendwie so wenig Gedanken darüber gibt, wie man Spieler ist. Man bei Chelsea zum Beispiel macht so Spieler in die holländische Ehrendivision schicken und sie dort irgendwie entwickeln lassen. Warum es diese Denkmodelle in Deutschland gibt, das erschließt sich mir tatsächlich nicht und ich klubbe nicht, dass da bei Bayern München und Borussia Dortmund moralischer Erwägungen dagegen sprechen. Das ist für mich eine seltsame Frage. Aber klar, du hast recht, du hast mit so einem System und das haben Jugendspieler hier immer gesagt, dass es für sie total genial ist, dass sie an jedem Schritt ihrer Entwicklung eine Möglichkeit haben, zu einem Verein zu gehen, der zu ihrer Entwicklung passt. Sei es hier in der U19 von RW Leipzig oder du kriegst das Angebot, um Lieferling zu spielen oder in Salzburg. Du hast immer eine Möglichkeit, einen Schritt zu machen, der für dich der nächste ist. Das ist natürlich für Nachwuchsspieler, die auf einer Karriere sind total interessant, so eine Schritte machen zu können.
Aber du verstehst schon, dass man es kritisieren kann. Es gibt ja auch andere Fälle, wie z. Marcel Sabitzer, der vom SK Rapid Wien kommt, der innerhalb der österreichischen Liga nur mit Zustimmung seines Vereins, damals noch unser Manager Andreas Müller, hätte wechseln dürfen und bei dem es dann einfach so gelöst wurde, dass er nach Leipzig wechselt und direkt an Salzburg wieder ausgeliehen wird. Also verstehe ich schon, dass man das jetzt als demjenigen, die nicht diese zwei Vereine gehören und man das hin und her schieben kann, dass das schon ein valider Kritikpunkt ist, weil das einfach Bedingungen aushebelt, schlau und legitim, also nichts davon ist illegal, aber es hebelt halt einfach die Gesetze des Wettbewerbs aus.
Ich glaube, diese Gesabelzernummer, klar, das ist irgendwie eine Lücke in seinem Vertrag gewesen und Dranglik hat hinterher gesagt, mach da nicht nochmal.
Das war keine Lücke, das war eine Barriere.
Nee, der hat seine Lücke im Vertrag, das soll einfach nie gewesen, dass du wieder zurück nach Österreich geliehen werden konntest. Dann musstest du im Vertrag auch ausspielen, dass der irgendwie nochmal in Österreich spielt. Und letztlich haben sie sich geeignet. Dafür hat Andreas Müller hinterher irgendwie einen Spieler für billiger Geld gekriegt. Also das war irgendwie auch so eine Nummer, wo die hinterher auch alle Feiern aus der Sache rausgegangen sind und keiner mit einem anderen gestritten hat. Aber klar, die Nummer liefert mit Bruno ähnlich, oder jetzt nicht mit so einem Vertrag, aber Bruno wurde ja auch nach Leipzig gekauft und dann nach Salzburg in die erste Liga verliehen, was ein bisschen ein absurder Schritt war damals. Und diese Geschichten haben sie ja damals irgendwie gesagt, ne, das ist irgendwie durch, das machen wir nicht mehr. Aber grundsätzlich verstehe ich dieses Prinzip der Wettbewerbsverzeichnung nicht. Grundsätzlich hast du doch die Möglichkeit, jeder Verein hat die Möglichkeit, sich Kooperationspartner oder irgendwelche Modelle zu suchen, wo er sagt, wir entwickeln unseren Nachwuchs jenseits von irgendwie unserer U19 etc. und indem sie bei uns auf der Bank sitzen, in irgendeinem Verein. Also das ist doch kein Wettbewerbsvorteil, nur weil RB Leipzig und Red Bull Salzburg irgendwie nahe zuneinander stehen. Wie gesagt, der Wettbewerbsvorteil besteht daran, dass der Verein im Fall der Fälle nicht ne sagt, wenn irgendwie RB Leipzig sagt, den hätten wir gerne in der Fälle gehört.
Genau, das ist doch der Punkt. Eine Kooperation ist doch was anderes. Eine Kooperation ist jetzt mal zwischen zwei unabhängigen oder zwischen zwei voneinander unabhängigen Menschen oder Gruppenorganisationen, die was aushandeln und dann was machen. Was ja hier ist, ist ja, dass der Sportchef von dem einen Verein oder der Sportchef von dem anderen Verein ja dieselbe Person ist. Oder das Telefon auf dieselbe Leipziger Büronummer umgeleitet ist.
Das ist doch nicht mehr so, also sorry.
Doch, also bis heute war das ja schon, bis heute war das ja noch ganz offiziell so. Und das ist, ich denke schon, dass du das siehst, dass das ein Unterschied ist. Aber du siehst doch schon, dass das ein Unterschied ist, ob ich mir eine Kooperation suche, so wie Chelsea das macht, die ja auch ein sehr gutes Scouting- und Jugendnetzwerk einfach haben, oder ob ich das sozusagen inhouse mache. Und Leipzig hat sich entschieden, das inhouse zu machen. Und da hängen natürlich ein paar Fragen, wettbewerbsrechtliche, durchaus auch moralische natürlich, bei dem ganzen Thema junge Spieler, aber das betrifft die anderen ja genauso dran. Aber das ist doch schon ein Unterschied, den du auch da sehen musst, Matthias.
Ich sehe den Vorteil darin, dass es, wie gesagt, der Vorteil ist, dass du Spieler, dass du nicht den gegnerischen Sportdirektor überzeugen musst. Das ist der Vorteil, ja.
Ja, weil es keinen gibt. Weil es ist ja nicht der Gegner.
Natürlich gibt es den.
Selbst wenn es den gibt. Also wenn dir beide Vereine gehören, dann sieht man da schon einen Unterschied. Ich sehe, wir kommen, wir werden uns nicht immer in Harmonie hier durch die Sendung bewegen. Das ist ja eigentlich auch ganz schön zu sehen. Aber interessantes Thema. Wir werden auch sehen, wie das die UEFA löst und wie viele Konsequenzen das hat. Und natürlich werden wir auch sehen, ob es halt die Gegenbewegung gibt. Also ob jetzt andere große Vereine ähnliche Modelle fahren, ist halt alles dann auch nicht so leicht aufzustellen. Denn man braucht ja auch tatsächlich den Kapitaleinsatz dahinter. Das ist natürlich schon auch der eine große Unterschied. Du hast hier ein milliardenschweres Unternehmen, das sich in den Fußball aus Marketinggründen bewegt hat und deswegen aber auch ganz andere finanzielle Mittel hat, als wenn jetzt zum Beispiel, naja, FC Bayern, Borussia Dortmund, die würden das wahrscheinlich noch hinbekommen, aber wahrscheinlich schon in einer großen Ordnung Werder Bremen zum Beispiel. Ja, wie sollen die das schaffen in dieser Konsequenz, wie das Red Bull durchgezogen hat? Das ist eigentlich nicht zu schaffen.
Ja, aber das ist halt wieder die Frage dessen, was du für Geld einsetzen kannst. An der Stelle sind wir uns glaube ich auch nicht uneinig, weil das ist tatsächlich, aber das sage ich auch die ganze Zeit. Die grundsätzliche Frage ist, wie du Wettbewerb so organisierst, dass es irgendwie nicht die Schere so weit auseinandergeht, dass dazwischen so eine Welten liegen, dass sie nicht zu schließen sind.
Gut, wie das Wettbewerb überhaupt aussehen soll, das ist ja auch, das ist ja die Frage, ihr habt es ja schon angesprochen, also wenn Werder Bremen das nicht machen kann, dann fehlt es natürlich am nötigen Kapital. Und die Frage ist dann natürlich ganz entscheidend, wo soll es herkommen und in welcher Organisationsform soll das ganze Geld sozusagen fließen. Das ist ja auch natürlich ein bisschen das Problem, wenn du 50 plus 1 machst und sagst, damit garantieren wir sozusagen eine gewisse Ausgeglichenheit, geht der international betrachtet möglicherweise dann so ein bisschen auf Kosten des Niveaus und kann da sozusagen als Bremse wirken. Also das ist ja das, so bewegt sich der Fußball ja sozusagen dann im globalen Maßstab und der ist natürlich ja dann auch so letztlich die Richtschnur an dieser Stelle, wie das Ganze organisiert werden soll und welchen Wettbewerb man überhaupt haben möchte. Du kannst natürlich hingehen und sagen, man kippt 50 plus 1, es gibt vielleicht noch rechtliche Bedenken dagegen, also muss das ganze sowieso irgendwann weg und holt sich natürlich dann irgendwelche Investoren ins Haus und gestaltet das ganze schrankenlos und schafft natürlich dann für gewisse Clubs auch nochmal ganz andere Möglichkeiten, macht es natürlich vollkommen schrankenlos, macht es vollkommen oferlos, liefert sich möglicherweise auch Leuten und deren Laune aus, hat natürlich dann aber auch eine ganz andere Form von Wettbewerb, hat eine ganz andere Form von Niveau, hat natürlich auch eine ganz andere, das zieht natürlich auch ganz andere Spieler an. Also das ist natürlich immer auch so eine Sache, wenn du es möglichst, wenn du es auf Kosten des Gleichgewichts organisieren willst, geht das möglicherweise auf Kosten des Niveaus und dann kommen halt bestimmte Spieler nicht oder sie wandern eben ab. Und insofern wird das Ganze natürlich im globalen Maßstab zu sehen sein und entsprechend sich auch die Wege suchen. Und die ganze Diskussion, die ich jetzt geführt habe, ich habe interessiert zurück, weil ich auch das Gefühl hatte, also diese ganzen rechtlichen Geschichten und natürlich sind damit auch moralische Fragen verbunden, berühren ja genau diesen Punkt, welchen Wettbewerb stellen wir uns eigentlich vor, wie soll der eigentlich aussehen? Geht der möglicherweise in Richtung einer geschlossenen Liga, vielleicht einer geschlossenen europäischen Liga oder sogar Weltliga, bei der es gar keinen regulären Auf- und Abstieg mehr gibt, wo man sagt, okay, wir gewährleisten intern, wie es in den USA halt auch der Fall ist, eine gewisse Offenheit des Wettbewerbs und Spannung und Gleichgewicht eben für das Publikum, aber es ist auch vollkommen klar, es gibt da keinen regulären Auf- und Abstieg mehr. Also das sind so Punkte, die wahrscheinlich irgendwann dann auch mal in Europa ankommen und sich möglicherweise durchsetzen werden. Und wo sich mancher von uns möglicherweise noch umschaut und sagt, ok, also das ist der Wettbewerb, den sich hier die Herrschaften vorstellen und der sieht völlig anders aus als das, wie wir uns das vorstellen.
Jetzt machst du das ganz große Fass auf Alex, wobei ich glaube, dass so mancher HSV-Offen jetzt gerade gejubelt haben wird. Kein Abschied mehr, das hört sich ja super entspannt an. Da machen wir auf jeden Fall mit.
Ist dir das nicht so billig gerade auf Leute einzuschlagen, die nicht in der Lage sind, sich zu verteidigen?
Ich habe vorhin gesagt, für die einfache Pointe mache ich alles und ich habe es bewiesen. Okay, machen wir mal den Punkt Wettbewerbsverzarrung zu. Ich glaube, wir haben das ganz gut in alle Richtungen besprochen. Kommen wir zu einem weiteren gerne verwendeten Kritikpunkt an Rasenballsport Leipzig und zwar Jens, der fehlenden Tradition des Vereins, wo ich mich auch so ein bisschen frage, was ist das eigentlich auch für eine Sichtweise? Es kann ja nicht nur traditionsreiche Vereine geben, sonst hätte es ja nie irgendwann einen neuen Verein gegeben. Wie ist denn deine Position hinsichtlich dieses Aspekts?
Ich glaube, mangelnde Tradition ist da vielleicht gar nicht so sehr der Hauptmotor der Kritik. Zumindest kann ich jetzt für mich nicht behaupten, dass ich einen Verein von 2000 cooler oder dober finde als einen von 1900. Was natürlich auf Tradition basiert, ist einfach natürliche Anziehungskraft und natürliche Strahlkraft und Geschichten, die diesen Verein ausmachen und Mythen und Dinge, die einfach für natürliche Anziehung sorgen, die eben nicht einfach durch gekauften Erfolg in Anführungsstrichen oder nicht auf gekauften Erfolg basieren. Und ich glaube, das ist dieses Argument von den Traditionsclubs nach dem Motto, okay, wir mussten uns das Geld, was wir jetzt von Sponsoren geschenkt bekommen, also nicht geschenkt, sondern was wir von Sponsoren bekommen, wir mussten uns das über sehr viele Jahre hart erarbeiten und ihr kommt jetzt einfach daher und kriegt 200 Millionen Euro und auf einmal spielt ihr in der ersten Liga. Ich glaube, das ist viel mehr als die Tradition an sich das Problem.
Wobei man da ja sagen könnte, ihr hattet ja auch Geld, dann setzt es doch einfach besser ein. Also bestes Gegenspiel ist ja dafür der gerade in anderem Zusammenhang zitierte HSV.
Ja, ich bin auch, das ist auch ein Argument, ich glaube, ich sprach eben vom doppelten Boden und du auch. Das ist das ist da das Hauptargument. Ich will überhaupt nicht sagen, dass Traditionsvereine gute Arbeit machen und raba sportlich oder von dem, was sie aus dem Geld gemacht haben, unverdient an der Stelle stehen, an der sie jetzt stehen. Aber sie mussten halt nicht so viel dafür tun. Wenn man in der fünften Liga anfängt, statt in der zwölften, ist das ein Unterschied. Wenn man sich das Geld nicht durch Popularität erarbeiten muss, wenn es nicht darum geht, die mussten keine Zuschauer gewinnen. Überleg dir mal, du fängst irgendwo in der Landesliga an und musst drei Euro pro Person nehmen und kannst dir halt irgendwann nur neue Spieler leisten, weil so viele Leute deine Spiele gucken, dass du so viel Geld einnimmst. Und das gab es halt alles nicht. Dieses harte Arbeit in Anführungsstrichen hatte Raba in dem Fall einfach nicht, sondern da war halt Geld. Und so konnte man sich dann Dinge leisten, die jetzt, würde ich gern Martin Kind sagen, der Markt reguliert sich selbst. In dem Fall hat der Markt es eben nicht reguliert, sondern es wurde quasi außerhalb des Marktes Geld eingekippt. Das Geld kam nicht aus dem Markt. Das Geld kam nicht daher, dass die Begeisterung für Red Bull Leipzig in der 6. Liga so groß war. Das Geld kam aus dem Konzern Red Bull Leipzig.
Aber das ist doch ein Mythos, dass man sich die Dinge erarbeiten muss. Wenn du vollkommen zurecht sagst, letztlich hängt doch alles davon ab, wie die Strahlkraft von einem Verein ist. Dann muss man sich doch mal fragen, wie entsteht denn so eine Strahlkraft? Und so eine Strahlkraft entsteht sicherlich durch irgendwelche Mythen, dass man irgendwie mit schweligen Händen das eigene alles aufgebaut hat und es ganz geschafft hat, von unten nach oben zu kommen. Das ist sicherlich irgendwo auch ganz richtig. Und das Ganze wird dann doch so ein bisschen verklärt. Die ganzen sogenannten Arbeitervereine machen ja – ist ja auch ein Marketinggag und letzten Endes nichts anderes. Aber natürlich entsteht Strahlkraft in erster Linie durch Erfolg. Oder zumindest in vorderer Linie durch Erfolg, ist vollkommen klar. Deswegen hat Borussia Dortmund so viele Fans, deswegen hat Bayern München so viele Fans. Und deswegen hat RB Leipzig in den vergangenen Jahren etliche Tausend und wahrscheinlich Zehntausende von Fans dazu gewonnen.
Das Interessante an der Stelle ist ja – und das sehen wir gerade in Salzburg – die Nachhaltigkeit solcher Fans und solcher Fan-Beziehungen. Das ist ja dann ein Kritikpunkt, den Traditionsvereine auch berechtigt anfügen können. Wir können sagen, die Fans, die zu uns kommen, die kommen halt schon seit 20 Jahren, weil denen ist scheißegal, wie wir spielen. Die identifizieren sich mit uns wie auch immer. Und das ist halt etwas, was Raba dann im Zweifel beweisen werden muss, ob da wirklich jetzt nachhaltig Fans akquiriert wurden oder ob die dann vielleicht in vier Jahren zu Dynamo Dresden gehen, weil das nur 80 Kilometer weit weg ist oder 110, und dann sofort nicht gleich besser dasteht.
Das kann schon sein, dass die dann abwandern, genauso wie sie bei anderen Vereinen auch abwandern können. Die Frage ist, was das besagt. Wir können darüber diskutieren, was sind jetzt echte Fans, was sind irgendwie gute Fans.
Nein, will ich gar nicht, will ich gar nicht. Mir ist die Tradition gar nicht so wichtig. Ich kann halt das einzige Argument, was ich darin sehe, ist, Traditionsvereine mussten sich das hart erarbeiten. Und Raba hat sich's gekauft. Das kann ich ein Stück weit nachvollziehen. Da sind wir wieder bei diesem Finanzdoping, was ich in meinem Eingangsstatement erwähnte. Aber ob der Verein 2009 oder 1909 gegründet wurde, wenn er erfolgreich in Fußball spielt und das auch auf mäßig rechtmäßigem Sinne erreicht hat, dann ist das doch alles in Ordnung. Fans kritisiere ich sowieso nicht, weil wenn ich irgendwo in einer Region aufgewachsen wäre, die nicht NRW ist, wo nicht 100.000 Vereine sind, die ich mir angucken könnte, dann würde ich auch den nehmen, der nah dran ist und erfolgreich. Deshalb sage ich ja, Tradition ist glaube ich nicht das Argument, was dahinter steckt, sondern dieses, ja, hart erarbeiten müssen, Strahlkraft aufbauen usw.
Wobei das natürlich auch so dieses, also ich verstehe, was du sagen willst, das ist auch grundsätzlich richtig, aber wenn du so sagst, das ist so nicht so, das ist mit diesem Markt üblich, oder der Markt findet seine Wege, aber bei RB Leipzig ist das anders. Letztlich ist das genau Teil des Markts. Es gibt ein Unternehmen, das sagt, wenn ich hier irgendwie 200 Millionen Euro reinstecke, dann erreiche ich damit die und die Werbewirksamkeit und das ist super für mich. Letztlich ist es ja nicht so eine Hauptgeschichte, gar nicht negativ gemeint, aber so eine Hauptgeschichte, der sagt, ich habe Bock, irgendwie meinen Vermögen anzulegen, weil, ist eh nicht wohin damit. Also du hast ja letztlich diese Marktlogik von irgendeinem Unternehmen, der sagt, es ist mir wert, das Geld dort zu investieren. Also von daher stimmt das Argument immer nicht so richtig, weil ich verstehe oft das Argument, was du sagst, dass da erst Geld reingesteckt wurde, um dann die Strukturen zu schaffen und erfolgreich zu machen. Ja, das verstehe ich. Und dass es nicht so ist, dass erst die Struktur ist und dann irgendjemand sagt, oh, das ist eine Struktur, da gebe ich mir Geld dazu. Aber trotzdem passiert das ja aus einer Marktlogik heraus. Es ist ja nicht irgendwie so eine Form von, was ist ich, ich heiße Abramowitsch und das ist jetzt irgendwie mein Steckenpferd, irgendwie auf einer Tribüne zu sitzen und zu gucken, was mit meinem Geld passiert. Sondern die Logik dahinter ist ja tatsächlich eine marktgerechte. Das Argument stimmt halt aus meiner Sicht immer nicht so richtig.
Vielleicht ist Mark dann auch insofern falsch formuliert, dass ich diesen Fußballmarkt meinte. Und das Geld kam halt von außen in diesen Fußballmarkt und hat sich nicht in diesem Fußballmarkt entwickelt, wie es halt durch, ich glaube unnatürlich passt das immer noch am besten. Als wir von diesem UFO im Wald sprachen, ich glaube, das trifft einfach das, was ich sagen will. Das Geld, Red Bull hat sich diese, ja, das Vermögen nicht im Fußball natürlich erarbeitet. Popularität führt zu Zuschauer, Zuschauer führen zu Medieninteresse, Medieninteresse führt zu Sponsorenattraktivität, Sponsorenattraktivität führt zu mehr Geld, führt zu mehr Erfolg, führt zu mehr Zuschauern und so weiter. Diese Spirale hatten sie nicht, sondern es gab einen Startpunkt. Hier ist Geld, hier legen wir los. Und alles andere kam erst danach.
Ich denke, wo wir uns alle einig sind, ist ja auf jeden Fall erstmal der Punkt, dass Tradition und Kommerz eine falsche Unterscheidung sind. Niemand hier nimmt das für sich in Anspruch zu sagen, dass das eine ist Kommerz, das andere ist Tradition. Das hatten wir auch schon vorhin bei den Fragen, wie viele Marketing überhaupt im Fußball haben. Interessant finde ich an der Stelle, was ihr beide diskutiert, ist die Frage, aus welcher Motivation ist das jetzt geschehen? Oder woher kam nicht nur die Motivation, sondern eben auch das Geld? Und da ist ja dann schon ein Unterschied zu dem, was vielleicht manche meinen, wenn sie Traditionen sagen, ist ja eben nochmal die Geschichte, ich hatte es vorhin ja schon mal gesagt, oder wir hatten es auch schon am Anfang besprochen in der Gründungsgeschichte, warum man jetzt ausgerechnet hierher gegangen ist. Und da ist ja nicht nur so, dass man gesagt hat, wir machen das irgendwo auf der grünen Wiese auf, sondern dass man sich ja schon irgendwo in so einem Vakuum gesetzt hat, wo auch jetzt nicht, wo eben auch mit Absicht alle Traditionen 100 Kilometer oder eine Autostunde weit weg ist. So alle Traditionen, die jetzt gerade noch akut Menschen zieht. Dann war erster Deutscher Meister und so, 1903. Das ist natürlich alles in Leipzig gegründet, die DFB. Das ist natürlich Tradition, die auch hier ist. Wird aber auch nur von einer Frau, die hier im Archiv arbeitet, da noch so hochgehalten. Ansonsten spielt das ja keine Rolle. Aber da sozusagen zu der Frage, wenn Tradition Kommerz vielleicht nicht die richtige Unterscheidung ist, ist es ja doch immer interessant, noch mal zu gucken, wie wichtig das – oder es wäre jetzt mal meine These, die ich auch zur Diskussion stelle – dass gerade RB Leipzig sehr schon versucht, nicht nur eigene Tradition aufzubauen oder solche Sachen zu imitieren, sondern eben auch dann allein mit der Gründung hier der Sache auch ein bisschen aus dem Weg gegangen ist. Und deswegen natürlich dieses Handeln auch von, in Anführungszeichen, Tradition oder so auch geleitet ist. Also der Wert an sich, der scheint doch eine Rolle zu spielen.
Du meinst jetzt der Wert des Ortes, an dem es gemacht wurde?
Der Wert dieser Tradition. Sie sagen ja selber mit Stolz, braucht man ja gar nicht, schaut mal, wie gut wir es machen. Aber das Handeln, gerade noch mal im Hinblick auf die Frage, wo geht man hin und wie verhält man sich zu sowas wie Tradition, von dem man sich ja sonst abgrenzt, scheint ja doch eine Rolle zu spielen. Sonst wäre man ja vielleicht nach Berlin oder eben in Pott gegangen oder nach St. Pauli oder so.
Ja, vielleicht hast du da schon einen interessanten Punkt gebracht. Denn ich finde, alles, was wir bisher zum Thema Tradition gesagt haben, hat so viel von einer Neiddebatte. Also, die mussten sich das nicht mit Schwien an den Händen erarbeiten wie wir. Deswegen mögen wir das nicht. Das ist ungerecht. Das kenne ich auch von meinen Zwillingen. Die sind jetzt drei. Aber das andere ist, dass es ja bei Leipzig auch damit verknüpft wird, dass Red Bull als Unternehmen offensiv damit umgeht. Wir haben es vorhin beim Beispiel Red Bull Salzburg schon gehört, dass man tatsächlich gesagt hat, es gibt keine Tradition, wir machen das jetzt neu. Und auch bei Leipzig wird das strapaziert, dass man sagt, wir wollen auch gar nicht der Traditionsverein sein, sondern wir wollen ja für den neuen Fußball stehen, für die neue Fußballkultur. Und vielleicht ist das auch das, was dann dieses Traditionsargument, was eigentlich nur eine recht inhaltliche Debatte ist, wie ich finde, dann so auflädt. Vielleicht geht es dann auch eher darum, über diesen Anspruch, den Leipzig vor sich hertritt, als tatsächlich über das Fehlen einer 50-jährigen bewegten Vereinsgeschichte.
Ja, natürlich eine schöne, wie sagt man, schöne Kommunikationsgeschichte. Ich finde, auf manche Sachen muss man dann aber auch nicht so reinfallen. Hier wächst nicht die neue Speerspitze der besseren Fußballwelt, also aus meiner Sicht. Also ich finde es auch mal so mühselig, darüber zu reden. Was genau ist der Punkt? Was sollte hier der Vorschein der neuen Fußballwelt sein? Es ist letztlich einfach eine weitere Fußballstruktur, die lokal funktioniert. Da unterscheidet sie sich nicht so sehr in anderen lokalen Fußballstrukturen.
Ich finde es schön, dass du das sagst, weil das ja wirklich als USP auch so ein bisschen von der lokalen Franchise vor sich her getragen wird. Ich würde auch denken, dass auch viele der Artikel, die um RB Leipzig entstehen – ich meine, es ist ein anderes Thema sozusagen, die Logik der Medien ist irgendwie nochmal eine ganz andere Sache und wo da die Aufmerksamkeit hingeht – aber ist ja schon auch ein bisschen daraus gespeist, dass man eben sagt, hier laufen Dinge anders und hoppla, schaut mal, wie schnell das hier geht und auch so ein bisschen dieser inszenierte Fight zwischen Watzke und RB Leipzig. Also das ist ja auch so ein Stellvertreterkrieg für diese Pseudo-Unterscheidung, von der wir eigentlich alle gesagt haben, dass es die jetzt nicht so richtig ist. Aber ich würde sagen, dass schon ein Großteil der Aufmerksamkeit und auch der Sachen, die zum Beispiel auf RB Live oder so laufen, also diesen lokalen Portalen, wo das viel berichtet wird, natürlich eigentlich dann doch auch im Grunde aus dieser Konstellation motiviert sind, dass man eben sagt, wir machen hier was anderes und auch viel besser.
Ja, aber das ist auch, ich sag mal, das ist halt so dieses Hoffen-Nein-Phänomen auch. Also die erste Bundesliga-Saison, wo dann irgendwie die Winterpause irgendwie das beliebteste Team Deutschlands waren oder das angesagte, heißeste, haste nicht gesehen. Und zwei Jahre später haben alle drüber geschrieben, was haben die denn für ihn an der Waffel? Also das hängt ja auch so sehr an Entwicklungen, an was ist neu, was ist nicht neu, also geht zwei Jahre weiter und die scheitern, keine Ahnung, sind neunter in der Bundesliga und du hast die ganzen, ganzen gegenteiligen Artikel. Also ich glaube, das ist so mühselig, sich da ranzuhängen, weil das sind so Wellenbewegungen, von da wird es gehypt und drei Jahre später wird es irgendwie in den Grund und Boden geschrieben. Also das ist so, also ich persönlich, ja, kann man gerne so überreden, aber ich persönlich finde das eher so, dass eines der mühseligen Themen, die es so rund um RB Leipzig gibt, dass ich tatsächlich auch wenig Lust habe, mich irgendwie dann so auf so einen Sportbild-Traxlerzug mitzuwerfen, von alles ist ja super, weil RB Leipzig fordert die Bayern heraus. Also das ist so Quatsch. In zwei Jahren schreibt er, RB Leipzig macht alles falsch, weil die spielen da mit jungen Leuten und damit kann man ja schämbeziehend gehen. Also das ist so, was soll ich damit? Damit kann ich wirklich null anfangen.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist deswegen interessant. Das ehrt ich, diese Haltung. Aber ich glaube, es ist deswegen interessant, weil das, glaube ich, schon einer der wesentlichen Punkte ist, was die Diskussion auf beiden Seiten emotional sehr auflädt. Zum einen, dass eben dieser sportliche Erfolg von Leipzig jetzt auch nicht in der allergrößten Bescheidenheit registriert wird, sondern es gibt da immer wieder Leute, die sich hinstellen. Also gerade Ralf Rangnick ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich nicht der Held darin, bescheiden mit Erfolg umzugehen, sondern er stellt sich halt hin, wir machen das halt anders, wir machen das schlauer und wir sind halt einen Ticken weiter und unser Nachwuchsleistungszentrum ist halt geiler und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist natürlich eine sehr zurückgelehnte und sachliche Haltung, wenn du sagst, naja, also auf diesen Zug da springe ich nicht auf. Aber das setzt natürlich ein Trigger bei Fans anderer Vereine, über die ja dann im Subtext immer gesagt wird, bei euch ist es ja schlechter, wir machen es übrigens geiler. Und ich finde auch, dass man das, auch da gibt es kein richtig und kein falsch. Und Leipzig macht auch Dinge besser als andere Vereine, aber auch nicht alles. Aber ich glaube, das ist einer der wesentlichen Punkte, warum diese Debatte so emotional aufgeladen wird. Vor allem, wenn wir noch einen weiteren Aspekt mit reinnehmen. Das eine ist ja quasi der sportliche Erfolg, wo es ja auch dieses vollkommen aus jeder Kausalität genommene Argument gibt, ja Moment mal, es ist doch erfolgreich, warum beschwert ihr euch alle, als ob man nur Dinge kritisieren dürfte, die nicht erfolgreich sind. Aber wir können ja nicht immer nur über den HSV sprechen. Nein, jetzt wird es zu viel. Oh je, das gibt wieder Twitter-Replies. Aber das ist ja das eine, dass man eben quasi sagt, der neue Fußball und der zweite Aspekt, der in diesem sowieso schon sehr emotionalen Themenkomplex, Tradition und Zukunft des Fußballs mit drin hängt, ist ja auch das Thema der Fußballkultur. Auch ein sehr emotionales Thema. Und auch hier stellt sich Leipzig oder auch die Red Bull Franchises auch außerhalb von Leipzig hin und sagen, wir leben eine neue Fan-Kultur. Da sagt zum Beispiel ein Sprecher, Gewalt wird bei Red Bull nicht akzeptiert, erinnert an die Übernahme der traditionsreichen, aber bankrotten Salzburger Austria vor Jahren. Die Ablehnung von Gewalt sei, Zitat, der Grund gewesen, warum wir uns in Salzburg von der alten Fanszene getrennt haben. Dort haben wir kurzfristig 1.000 Anhänger verloren und mittelfristig 10.000 dazu gewonnen. Also wir lernen, die Fans von Red Bull Salzburg, also der Austria Salzburg, sind nicht etwa gegangen, weil sie Red Bull und den Farbenkrieg usw. doof fanden, sondern weil es alle gewaltbereite Schläger waren. Ich überspitze jetzt genauso, wie es der Sprecher gemacht hat. Und ohne jetzt einzelne Aussagen überhöhen zu wollen, trägt ja Leipzig dieses Bild schon vor sich her. Unter anderem ja auch nach dem, was in Dortmund passiert ist, beim nächsten Heimspiel, hängt ein riesiges, nicht handgemaltes und meiner Meinung nach, na gut, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht von Fans produziert, aber sah eher nach einer Vereinsaktion aus oder zusammen mit Fans. Banner in der Kurve.
Nach Aussage der Leute handgemalt.
Okay, gut, dann ist es handgemalt. Aber was stand drauf? Gegen Menschenverachtung für eine neue Fußballkultur, oder? So ähnlich ungefähr. Also das trägt man ja schon vor sich her. Und das ist ein hoch emotionales Thema. Und da kann ich auch ehrlich gesagt ganz viele Leute verstehen, die sich auch engagieren im Fußball zum Teil, dass sie sagen, ne, also das lassen wir uns nicht gefallen, dass da jetzt so eine Franchise kommt. Ein Marketing-Instrument. Ich glaube, die Argumentationslehnen liegen da bei den meisten Leuten recht eng beieinander, die uns dann auch noch erzählen wollen. Wir machen aber auch wirklich alles in allen Bereichen besser.
Dazu kommen wir noch jetzt zum Matteschitz-Interview vom Wochenende, wo er auch nochmal ganz klar austeilt und sagt, es gibt eine gewaltbereite, alkoholisierte Minderheit im Fußball, die nur Spaß dran hat, Feuerwerke zu zünden. Ich glaube, es kam noch ein Attribut dazu, weiß ich nicht mehr. Aber dieses alles in einen Topf schmeißen. Also sozusagen Gewalt und Pyro und Alkohol, das ist alles eins. Und das ist auch übrigens synonym zu engagierter Fankultur. Und wir machen das anders, weil bei uns gibt es keine Mitbestimmung. Das war schon sein Subtext, wenn es nicht sogar sein Originaltext war. Und das ist auch nicht etwas, was ein- oder zweimal passiert ist. Das will ich nur sagen, um deine Frage oder deine These zu stützen. Das ist schon etwas, was offenbar zum Markenkern von Red Bull dazugehört. Und da kann ich auch sehr gut verstehen, dass das vielen Leuten gegen den Strich geht, weil das ja schon einfach nur anmaßend ist und auch verkennt, was viele Leute rund um Vereine, das was Matthias selber vorhin gesagt hat, lokale Fußballkonstrukte oder Fußballstrukturen, diese Arbeit, die Leute über Jahrzehnte reinstecken, viel von ihrer Lebenszeit, das wird mit solchen Aussagen aktiv abgewertet. Und das finde ich einfach nicht gut.
Fußball für alle statt Menschen für alle. Das ist ein beachtender Krawalle, stand auf dem Transferentbringens. Ich hab's jetzt nachgelesen. Ja, natürlich sind wir da auch alle dafür. Keine falsche Anfrage. Natürlich nicht. Nee, weißte ich. Ich will jetzt gerade ein Plädoyer dafür halten, dass man sich auf die Fresse gibt. Endlich. Auch in der Darstellung zum Beispiel, also wir müssen jetzt aufpassen, dass wir jetzt an der Stelle auch nicht zu viele Argumente miteinander verquicken, aber dieses Argument kam ja auch zum Beispiel, als es darum geht, warum das jetzt für die Region ganz toll sein müsse. Es kann ja toll sein, aber es muss toll sein, weil jetzt gibt es ja nicht mehr nur die beiden Schlägervereine in Leipzig. Überspitzt gesagt. Aber dieses, wir machen jetzt einen neuen Fußball, wir machen eine neue Fußballkultur, das wird sehr offensiv von Red Bull vor sich hergetragen und das trotz all der Dinge, die wir schon besprochen haben, trotz einer Rücksichtslosigkeit gegenüber Traditionen von Vereinen, umgehend juristische, juristische Bestimmung und so weiter und so fort. Das ist halt einfach, ich finde, das ist eher so eine Frage des Auftretens eigentlich. Und ich glaube, das ist eins der wichtigsten Themen, wenn wir darum sprechen, werden wir auch später nochmal kurz drüber sprechen, warum auch die Kritik an Leipzig dann häufig den Rahmen des Ertragbaren verlassen hat. Ich glaube, da spielt auch diese Haltung eine Rolle.
Aber ist das nicht so ein Claim, den ganz viele haben, irgendwie anders zu sein? Na ja, der erste FC Köln, der mit spürbar anders auftritt. Und ich finde, das hat auch so ein Claim. Den haben viele Vereine, die sagen, unsere Fans sind das ganz Besondere, wir machen dieses und jenes anders als andere. Also das unterscheidet sich dann doch auch nur in Növenzen. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, ja, mit dem ganzen Modell, das RB Leipzig auszeichnet, kommt das irgendwie nochmal anders rüber. Das mag schon alles sein, aber dass man sich da versucht, zu positionieren und irgendwie so eine moralische Höherwertigkeit für sich in Anspruch nimmt, ich finde, das ist kein Alleinstellungsmerkmal von RB Leipzig, noch nicht mal besonders penetrant, ehrlich gesagt. Klar, dass man das nochmal so ein bisschen ins Zentrum rückt vor dem Hintergrund, dass man ja selbst kein Traditionsverein ist, sondern irgendwie was Neues vielleicht erfinden will oder sowas. Klar, aber das scheint mir dann also bestenfalls auch ein gradueller Unterschied zu sein. Aber ehrlich gesagt halte ich das in gewisser Weise auch bloß für eine Form von Marketing-Gag, wie ihn andere auch haben und kann da jetzt nichts besonders Anstößiges daran erkennen, ehrlich gesagt. Also da lache ich bei anderen auch drüber. Wenn ich hier durch Köln gehe und sehe, dann spüre ich bei anders die Plakate und gucke dann teilweise zu, was dann eben auch dahinter steht. Wenn sich die wilde Horde mal wieder daneben benimmt, denke ich auch, okay, ist der Claim halt auch ins Leere gelaufen. Wenn ich irgendwie echte Liebe sehe und denke, Leute, das ist halt wirklich nur ein Marketinggag oder mir sein mir oder was auch immer dann noch so ist. Ich meine, selbst das Image für das FC St. Pauli ist ja wahrscheinlich der beste Marketinggag schlechthin, ob er nun so geplant gewesen ist oder nicht. Letztlich ist es auch egal, er verkauft sich hervorragend. Da wird es dann immer was geben, was irgendwie dem entgegensteht, wo man sagt, das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen lächerlich, aber ist das wirklich ein signifikanter und grundlegender Unterschied zu anderen Vereinen oder ist das nicht irgendwas, was ihr dann sogar irgendwie auch ein Stück weit normal macht an der Stelle?
Ich glaube, wir machen das neu und besser, ist halt wirklich eine explosive Kombination, weil wir machen das besser als alle anderen, ist eigentlich ein Monopol des FC Bayern. Die sind die Einzigen, die mit ihrem Claim sagen, mir san mir heißt, wir sind besser als ihr und alle anderen, du sagst, es ist ja spürbar anders oder keine Ahnung, die wollen sich halt irgendwie natürlich selber darstellen und sagen, wir sind anders als ihr, aber da ist nicht automatisch dieses, neu ist immer besser drin, was How I Met Your Mother geprägt hat. Also, wir sind neu und besser als ihr.
Ja, es gibt schon so, ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen komplexer, wie immer. Also, ich glaube, es gibt schon eine Ebene in der Vereinskommunikation auch, kommt ja mal drauf an, wann, wo man so über andere redet, wo es nicht bei diesem, wir wollen anders sein. Also, was ich völlig okay finde, wenn man sich einen Anspruch stellt, wie man sein will, obwohl ich die Latte, die man sich da selbst legt, für relativ hoch halte, gibt es dann noch so eine Ebene von über andere zu reden. Also, so dieses, vor allem nach den Köln-Geschichten, nach der Busblock-Halle, war das so relativ präsent, wo man dann so recht offensiv rausgegangen ist und gesagt hat, wir haben ein Problem in Deutschland, wir müssen was dagegen machen, wir werden dem Fußball helfen. Also, wenn man sich in eine ganz seltsame Spährspitzenrolle selber gestellt hat, gegen Probleme im Fußball. Und ich glaube, das ist so eine Kommunikation, mit der tut man sich nicht wirklich einen Gefallen, weil es einfach tatsächlich ein Stück weit auch ein bisschen anmaßend ist. In der Neuigkeit der Rolle, in der man als erstmalig in der Bundesliga spielend ist. Aber so mit diesem Selbstanspruch, wir wollen ein gewaltfreier Verein sein, wie pathetisch und – quatsch ich das erstmal klingen mag – finde ich jetzt irgendwie erstmal nicht falsch. Ich finde, das ist eher eine Frage, wo löst sich das ein. Und das ist für mich immer noch eine offene Frage, weil es ein junger Verein ist, weil es ein junger Verein in der Großstadt ist, weil es ein junger Verein ist, der als in der Großstadt existierend in den nächsten Jahren klassische jugendkulturelle Phänomene kriegen wird, was auch – ja, tatsächlich dann ja auch geweiht immer beinhaltet ein Stück weit. Also die Frage ist, an welcher Stelle man dann wie auf Phänomene reagiert und wen man in der Fanszene mit dem Boot hat, um tatsächlich auf die Probleme reagieren zu können. Und das ist eher so die Frage nach zukünftigen Entwicklungen. Bis jetzt ist man da relativ konsequent gewesen, wenn sich irgendwelche Gruppen angebahnt haben, die irgendwie mehr Bock hatten als nur Fußball gucken. Ist auf Dauer jetzt nicht absehbar, wohin sich das entwickelt. Von daher, wenn man sich so eine Latte legt, dann kann man die auch durchaus mal gut reißen. Bietet sich dann natürlich auch immer gut an, besonders da reinzustochern, wenn bei so einem Verein mal was passiert, wenn der sich so nach außen präsentiert, dass man der sauber hinten an den Schlechthin ist und dort eine gewaltfreie Fußballkultur entsteht, wo irgendwie nie was Stimmes passiert. Ich finde, solange man bei sich bleibt, bei allem, was man da sich vielleicht zu hoch steckt, dann ist das noch okay, wenn man dann irgendwie so anfängt, dass das, was man selber ist, irgendwie als Prototyp für den Rest der Welt zu proklamieren, da bin ich dann irgendwie, das ist mir dann zu much.
Zum einen mir auch kein Fußballfunktionär einfällt, der gesagt hat, hey, Gewalt ist Teil unserer Identität.
Der russische Sportminister vielleicht noch, der gesagt hat, guten Job haben wir da gemacht bei der EU in Frankreich.
Der Vorwurf ist ja immer so ein bisschen so viel in der Konsequenz und dann ist es halt so, ja, du bist dann relativ schnell in so einer Debatte, worüber in Deutschland reden wir. So die Argumentation bei RB ist ja immer so, es gibt nur so eine Minderheit, die gegen RB Leipzig ist und der Rest ist ja gar nicht. Und dann ist halt die Minderheit, die dann irgendwie die Grenzen überschreitet und deswegen sind dann die diejenigen, die dann so in den Fokus geraten. Und das ist natürlich relativ plakativ und ich verstehe irgendwie so eine Grundidee dahinter, weil ich glaube, ich weiß, woher sie kommt, dass man irgendwie sagt, okay, sehe ich glaube ich auch so die Masse von Fußballfans in Deutschland, die vor der Sportschau sitzen etc. Also wir reden ja irgendwie von 30 Millionen Länderspielfans. Die haben tatsächlich kein Problem mit RB Leipzig. Für die ist das völlig wurscht, für die ist das ein Fußball-Thema und wenn es gut Fußball spielt, dann ist es super, wenn schlecht Fußball spielt, dann ist es irgendwie doof. Und dann hast du aber tatsächlich so diese, ich sag mal, diese Stadion-Fan-Kultur und da sieht das Thema dann schonend irgendwie ein bisschen anders aus und dann macht es auch keinen Sinn irgendwie zu sagen, das handelt sich irgendwie in jedem Stadion um irgendwie 100 Leute und die sind das Problem und mehr nicht. Also du machst da irgendwie so Fronten auf, das war halt nach diesem Köln-Spiel, aber ich fand das relativ extrem, weil du so mit diesen Vorfällen von der Bus-Pokal und vor allem mit den zerstochenen Reifen bei den Guest-Fans, hattest du so eine Situation, wo du gemerkt hast, okay, in Köln beginnt so eine, fangen die an nachzudenken, auch so von den Funktionären her, okay, was passiert hier, wie müssen wir da eingreifen, was müssen wir irgendwie machen, damit das irgendwie nicht mehr passiert, weil so soll es natürlich auch nicht sein, so. Und dann hattest du so diese Spitze aus Leipzig von, dagegen muss man das was machen, wir helfen gerne, wir sind hier irgendwie neu und gehen voran und tralala. Und dann hat sich das so binnen drei Stunden so komplett gedreht und Köln kam nur so sehr, so, sorry, wir kriegen unsere Sachen schon selber hin. Und das war halt so eine völlig, völlig unnötige Geschichte, wo du so Fronten offen machst, die eigentlich gar nicht da sind, weil du so grundsätzlich eine Idee hast von Leuten, die sehen, okay, wir haben ja gerade ein Problem gehabt. Was müssen wir damit machen? Und die dann plötzlich so zurückgegangen sind, ey, sorry, aber das ist uns hier, wenn ihr uns jetzt dafür antastet, das ist aber wirklich ein bisschen zu much. Ja, das ist dann nicht besonders clever, sagen wir's mal so.
Ja, vor allem fällt es dir natürlich, wenn du dich auf so einen Sockel stellst, auch besonders schnell vor die Füße, wenn dann bei dir im Stadion mal was passiert, wie es ja offenbar beim Heimspiel gegen den HSV durch Ordner und angeblich auch einige Polizisten, die sich nicht richtig verhalten haben, der Fall war. Ich glaube, dieser ganze Aspekt, fehlende Tradition, Anspruch auf einen neuen Fußball und eine neue Fußball- und Fankultur ist vor allem auch deshalb sehr wichtig, weil er von einigen, ja, von einigen auch Medien, wie zum Beispiel den Elfreunden, sehr strapaziert wird. Also die Elfreunde schreiben zum Beispiel in ihrer viel beachteten Titelgeschichte über Leipzig, Zitat, letztlich verdichtet sich die Suche nach einer Position im Fall von Red Bull in der Frage, wie eine lebendige Fußballkultur aussieht und wie sich RB Leipzig dazu verhält. Über die Fußball- und Fankultur ist in den vergangenen Jahren häufig gestritten worden und sie kommen selber zu dem Schluss, denn letztlich ist das, was sich da alle zwei Wochen in Leipzig abspielt, nur eine leidlich ausgefeilte Simulation von Fankultur. Das heißt, wenn du eben diese Argumentationslinie einnimmst und die Fußball- und Fankultur über alles andere hebst, dann kommst du eben zu so eine radikalen These, wie sie die Freunde haben. Und ich glaube aber, wir haben jetzt schon in den vorausliegenden Stunden gezeigt, dass es aber durchaus noch andere Aspekte gibt. Aber deswegen glaube ich, ist das ein Argument, von dem man sich nie so ganz lösen kann. Egal, auch wenn man selber zum Beispiel – ich gebe euch da eigentlich in allem, was ihr gesagt habt, total recht – ich finde es auch nicht so wichtig, mich nervt manchmal so die öffentliche Darstellung, aber das ist für mich auch eher ein Darstellungsproblem als quasi inhaltlich falsch. Aber ich glaube, in der Debatte schwingt das zumindest im Subtext häufig mit.
Und worum es dann auch auch häufig – Die Freunde haben ja auch die schöne Geschichte geschrieben, wo man geschrieben hat, dass man RB-Fans an ihren Haaren und Brillen erkennt.
Ja, das war Christoph Biermann. Wir wollen jetzt nicht auf eine populistische Zuspitzung mit einer populistischen Zuspitzung reagieren. Ja, ich stelle mir auch die ganze Zeit die Frage, wie deine Haare gefärbt sind und welches Dünngespräch ist.
Ich muss erstmal fragen, wie ich meine Haare machen muss.
So wie Guido und Schäfer, glaube ich.
Und dann gehen wir zu Lizzi. Ich freue mich. Ein weiteres Argument, wenn wir um Leipzig sprechen, ist natürlich auch die Region. Wir haben vorhin schon über den 1. FC Kaiserslautern gesprochen. Das ist ja das Sinnbild geworden für dieser Verein, ist wichtig für die Region. Und dieses Argument wird immer mal wieder auch von Leipzig Befürwortern strapaziert, mit dem Stichwort Ostdeutschland, mit dem Stichwort Leipzig, Fußball-Verrückte und große Stadt. Und gleichzeitig haben wir ja schon vorhin gesehen, Leipzig war da eine von vielen Städten, die in der Auswahl waren. Würdest du denn sagen, Matthias, dass das ein wesentlicher Pro-Punkt ist, wenn man über RB Leipzig spricht, dass man sagt, naja, sie haben den Fußball dahin gebracht, wo er vorher nicht stattfinden konnte? Hochklassik aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Also es ist letztlich eine Entscheidung gewesen, die rationalen Kriterien wahrscheinlich gehorcht hat und die den hübschen Nebeneffekt hatte, dass es in einer Region bloß nicht gab, jetzt was gibt. Also die Struktur hätte hier niemand anders hinstellen können. Von daher ist es jetzt nicht so eine Wohltat, von zu sagen, wir müssen Leipzig was hinstellen an Strukturen, sondern aus den bekannten historischen Gründen, dass es hier am besten der Einstieg möglich war, ist es halt so entstanden. Also ich glaube, es ist halt immer so, ich glaube, man tut sich nicht so wirklich ein Gefallen, wenn man anfängt, so zu tun, als hätte Red Bull hier die Region gerettet, weil sie nicht losgegangen, um Regionen zu retten, sondern sie wollten einen Fußballverein gründen. Und dass es Leipzig geworden ist, ist da in gewissem Sinne Zufall gewesen. Aber für Leipzig, oder für die, die dem anhängen zumindest, ein schöner Zufall.
Und auch für die, die ein Geschäft daraus machen oder ihre Daseinsberechtigungen daraus beziehen oder auch Wählerstimmen, eben mit dieser Identität zu arbeiten. Also das spielt ja auch ganz anderen als dann jetzt den Leuten, die Red Bull machen oder Rasenball Leipzig machen, in die Hände. Ich habe ein Beispiel aus der lokalen Zeitung hier, aus der LVZ, gibt es so eine Rubrik, die heißt Leitartikel. Das sind aber eigentlich Kommentare, die dann auch so auf der ersten Seite sind. Da hat, als diese ganze Timo-Werner-Geschichte war, als dieses Schalke-Spiel war, hat der eine Redakteur – ich weiß gar nicht, ob er auch Chefreporter ist, so wie Guido Schäfer, aber auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Redakteur – eben so ein Leitartikel geschrieben. Und an dem kann man das, glaube ich, auch so ganz gut ablesen, wie eben dieses, was Matthias gut geschildert hat – ja, das war am Ende ein Entscheidungsprozess auf rationalen Kriterien – dann eben überhöht wird zu diesem, wir bekommen hier was, was uns von dunklen Mächten quasi vorenthalten wurde. Also darin gipfelt das dann am Ende tatsächlich so ein bisschen, wenn man das liest. Also erstmal kommen da so Sachen wie, drücken wir also Ralf Hasenhüttl und dem Team die Daumen. Es geht schließlich um die Tabellenführung in der Fußball-Bundesliga und inzwischen auch um die Ehre Leipzigs. Also das ist so, das ist im ersten Absatz der letzte Satz, dann geht es immer so weiter und so. Ist natürlich auch ein leichtes Spiel. Matthias auf Twitter kritisiert uns ja schon immer für, dass er sagt, es ist ein leichtes Opfer, die LVZ, aus dem das jetzt ist. Aber es gipfelt dann tatsächlich, dann nimmt der Autor so ein Gegenargument auf gegen RB und sagt, wortwörtlich, wörtlich ist Zitat, da kommen einem ja die Tränen, weil es ja im Kapitalismus grundsätzlich immer um Gerechtigkeit geht. Als in den 90er Jahren beim Zusammenbruch der Ostindustrie hunderttausende ihren Job verloren, da wurden sie belehrt, beides könne man ja nicht haben, Bananen und soziale Sicherheit. So, wörtliches Zitat, wörtliches Zitat und quasi sozusagen der Kapitalismus hat den Osten einst fallen gelassen oder entvölkert gewissermaßen und jetzt kommt RB, also so eine Überidentifikation, natürlich wird die von außen herangetragen, das würden selbst jetzt Oliver Menzlaff oder Ralf Rangling nicht machen, aber diese RB-Überidentifikation, die es hier gibt, das ist schon ein ziemlich spezifisches und auch gruseliges Phänomen. Also geboren aus dem Gefühl, irgendwie etwas zu verdienen, das einem von anderen vorenthalten wurde und jetzt ist das endlich da und das ist schon, also ich kann gar nicht anders, als das nicht auch mit so Sachen wie Pegida und was überhaupt so in Sachsen sonst so abgeht, mitgeistig mitlaufen zu lassen, wenn ich so was lese. Also es ist echt so so ein Großmannzucht aus so einer Opferrolle raus, finde ich ganz furchtbar.
Aber das ist ja jetzt kein Attribut, was da ein Verein sich selbst auch zuschreibt, oder?
Nein, nein, das ist nicht zuschreibt.
Also dieses Ostdeutsche und der erste Tabellenführer seit 1991, Hans Rostock, der aus Ostdeutschland kommt, das wird jetzt eher dem Verein zugeschrieben.
Aber wirklich auch in einem lokalen Milieu. Also das kommt ja nicht irgendwie aus einer Zeitung aus den Niederlanden oder so.
Es ist tatsächlich so, dass diese Ost-West-Geschichten tatsächlich so habe ich das Gefühl, seit Anfang der Saison noch mal so reinprojiziert werden. Also vom Gefühl her war das davor eigentlich überhaupt nie ein Thema, also für mich nicht, habe ich nie wahrgenommen so. Aber so seit Anfang der Saison hat man schon das Thema, dass so dieses Ostding schon noch mal mehr thematisiert wird, jetzt wie gesagt nicht vom Verein selbst unbedingt, aber schon so darüber hinaus, aber auch so vom Verein, der mal betont, dass so und so viele Dauerkartenbesitzer aus dem Umkreis von 100 Kilometer kommen, da wird schon so eine regionale Ostkomponente und nicht bloß eine Leipziger bemüht, aber das machen sie jetzt nicht so offensiv und ja, aber so diese Aufladung mit Ostwesten, die ist schon durchaus da. Seltsam, dass das jetzt doch so passiert. Also es gibt ja auch so diese immer viel kritisierten Studien und selbst wenn man da irgendwie so Zahlengrundlagen etc. irgendwie extrem schwierig sind, aber ich glaube, dass man selbst über diesen schlechten Zahlen irgendwie rausziehen kann, ist eine extrem große Differenz in der Zustimmung zu RB Leipzig zwischen so Ost und West. Also es wird da so ein Gebiet unterteilt und Ost ist halt die 5 neuen Bundesländer und du hast wirklich eine Differenz, keine Ahnung, von so 15 zu 1 zwischen diesem Ostgebiet und dem Westen. Also das wirklich tatsächlich kannst du schon so in so einem Umgang mit RB Leipzig schon auf so eine alte gedachte Mauer ziehen, an der so ein bisschen dann tatsächlich die Grenze verläuft und ich finde es sehr schräg und ich glaube, das hat wirklich so auch mit so was zu tun von egal wo der Verein jetzt herkommt in seiner Gründungsgeschichte, ist er doch irgendwie in Leipzig und das ist doch irgendwie unser, also fragt nicht im K-Block in Dresden, aber so ich glaube in so in relativ vielen Regionen in Ostdeutschland, ich kenne es auch für den Cottbus, ist das schon noch so ein bisschen so der Fall, dass man da überhaupt so besonders hinguckt, egal was jetzt der Hintergrund von dem Verein ist und ich glaube, das wird da schon gerade so ein bisschen mit aufgeladen und das ist schon so was, wenn man so mal so denkt so, hu, why?
Aber auch da ist es doch so dieser ganze lokalpatriotische Müll, der da mit drin steckt, macht den Verein dann auch wieder normal. Ich meine, das ist ja nun wirklich was Gott nicht der Einzige und wie viele Clubs gibt es ansonsten, die sich irgendwie – du hast ja schon Kaiserslautern genannt, Max – wie viele Clubs gibt es sonst, die da irgendwie mit genau solchen Punkten natürlich auch versuchen, sich so ein, ja, sich dazu positionieren. Selbst bei den Bayern läuft das ja so, dass sie sagen, na gut, dieses Ding von Laptop und Lederhose, auf der einen Seite ist man ein internationaler Verein, auf der anderen Seite mir san mir und die ganze, die ganze, dieser ganze bayerische Quatsch, der da irgendwie noch mit reinspielt, das ist im Prinzip auch nichts anderes. Da kann man dann über die je konkreten Ausprägungen kann man dann von mir aus diskutieren und man kann darüber sprechen, wie sympathisch oder auch weniger sympathisch die einzelnen Proponenten sind, die das vertreten. Ich meine, ich lebe hier in der Stadt wie Köln und also hier ist das ja in ganz extremer Weise der Fall. Da wird sich dann so ein bisschen das Mäntelchen der Toleranz natürlich umgehängt und wenn dann die Gäste kommen, heißt es, wir kommen in der schönsten Stadt Deutschlands. Aber da ist das ja im Prinzip nicht großartig anders als in Leipzig auch. Und dass man das da versucht und sich da im Grunde genommen sogar einen ähnlichen Anstrich zu geben, versucht, wie das bei anderen Vereinen auch üblich ist, und sich da lokal und regional zu positionieren versucht, das ist genauso klebrig wie normal. Also man könnte sagen, das ist eine schlechte Normalität und ja sicherlich nichts, was jetzt an Leipzig irgendwie im Prinzip besonders kritikabel wäre. Höchstens, dass es von der Ausprägung vielleicht nochmal hier und da irgendwie eine besonders schaurige Note annimmt. Ihr habt es ja jetzt auch schon gesagt, aber definitiv nichts Ungewöhnliches.
Ja, ich glaube, ich finde es tatsächlich eher, es gab ja damals die Solymter Bewerbung für 2000. Wann war die eigentlich? Für 2006 muss man irgendwie Anfang 2000er so nennen.
2012 war das für London.
Aber die Bewerbungszeit war 2004 oder so, ne? Und dann gab es ja so diese, da gab es so Demonstrationen in Leipzig für Olympia. Und wo dann tatsächlich so die Sprecher aufgetreten sind und gesagt haben, die Presse im Westen will uns das kaputt machen und weil wir hier, ja, weil wir im Osten sind, etc. Das ist wirklich tatsächlich so eine seltsame Ebene hast von, wir werden ja immer so kaputt gemacht, so dieses, ja, dieses immer im Vergleich mit dem Westen so, wir werden so runter gemacht. Und jetzt hast du mit RB und dann mit Olympia wäre genau so eine Chance gewesen, mit RB so einen Verein, an dem so manche Sachen da so rangepapst sind. Ich glaube, das ist nicht wirklich ein ganz großes Massenphänomen, aber es ist tatsächlich so ein Phänomen, was da tatsächlich irgendwie inzwischen so ein bisschen entsteht, steht auch an so einen Geschichten wie in Dortmund, so eine Ausschreitung. Ich glaube, sowas befördert das natürlich auch noch so ein ganzes Stück weit, wo dann so irgendwie so diese Geschichten auch so nochmal reingebracht werden. Von denen lassen wir uns das jetzt nicht mehr wegnehmen, kaputt machen, etc. Also, wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie jetzt das Massenphänomen ist von 40.000 Leuten, die ins Stadion gehen. Aber es ist tatsächlich so eine Ebene von Diskurs oder Rechtfertigung, die da irgendwie gerade reinkommt, die seltsam ist einfach.
Es stellt sich halt die Frage, ob, wenn wir jetzt davon sprechen, dass dann das ganze Konstrukt gar nicht vom Verein selber befördert, aber ideologisch aufgeladen wird oder zumindest emotional und mit einer regionalen Bedeutung, die dann quasi sich in so einer Ost-West-Trennung dann durchaus auch ablesen lässt, ob das nicht auch die Fallhöhe für das Szenario erhöht, dass der Standort Leipzig irgendwann nicht mehr die Rolle im Konstrukt Rhetol spielt, der jetzt spielt. Denn ich möchte euch mal ein Zitat aus dem Jahr 2005 von Dietrich Mataschitz vorlesen. Zitat, aber eines ist klar. Wir machen unser Fußballengagement nicht aufgrund des österreichischen Marktes oder der österreichischen Bundesliga. Das wäre nicht notwendig. Durch die Champions League, die den Werbenutzen des Fußballs dramatisch geändert hat, gibt es für uns internationalere Möglichkeiten. Wir müssen schauen, dass wir uns davor oder für den UEFA Cup qualifizieren. Und das ist mit einem Club in Österreich einfacher als in England, Spanien oder Deutschland. Das war ja im Jahr 2005. Und jetzt sind wir im Jahr 2017. Und es ist möglich, sich mit einem Club in Deutschland für Champions League usw. zu qualifizieren. Und es könnte ja aber auch durchaus sein, dass eine ähnliche Entwicklung in ein paar Jahren zum Beispiel mit einem Verein in England passiert. Das ist ja durchaus ein nicht unvorstellbares Szenario, wenn wir uns die Strahlkraft der Europäischen Ligen miteinander vergleichen.
Also das geistert auch immer mal wieder durch die Timelines und so. Und gab es jetzt auch wieder – was war es denn diesmal, der Winterpause, Matthias?
Englische Zweitligisten, sämtliche osteuropäische Staaten. Also such dir das aus.
Also es ist immer mal da. Ich halte es aus zwei Gründen für unwahrscheinlich. Der erste ist der Erfolg jetzt in Deutschland. Ich glaube, so wie das die letzten fünf Jahre gelaufen ist für Red Bull hier in Leipzig, das hätte eigentlich gar nicht besser laufen können. Also seit dem Rangnick am Tritt. Man kann sich das wirklich nicht besser vorstellen. Selbst die eingebauten Rückschläge sind ja jetzt quasi im Rückblick Erfolge.
Aber so kann es doch auch nicht weiter laufen. Diese Erfolgsgeschichte wird sich nicht weiterschreiben lassen.
Genau das ist der Grund, warum ich denke, dass es unwahrscheinlich ist, dass sie dann noch mal die Aufbauarbeit noch mal in einer neuen Liga anfangen. Zumal auch die handelnden Personen ja alle nicht jünger werden. Und dass ja auch noch mal so eine Frage ist, wie das weitergeht, wenn irgendwann der Lebensquell des Patriarchen versiegt und auch noch Ralf Rangnick irgendwann, ich weiß nicht, wann der irgendwann mal ruhig wird. Ralf Rangnick, der wird vermutlich nie mehr ruhig werden in seinem Leben. Das ist ja auch Teil seines Erfolgs. Aber so, dass jetzt diese Person – und ich glaube, es lässt sich doch immer noch zurückführen auf diese Personen auch. Es ist noch nicht so ein System, was sich irgendwie selber trägt. Und dass die jetzt gerade noch mal gemeinsam einen Anlauf in England nehmen, ich kann es mir im Moment schlecht vorstellen, dass die das noch gemeinsam noch durchziehen.
Andererseits kannst du dir in England den Club ja auch einfach kaufen. Also da musst du ja nicht so weit unten starten. Das ist ja auch ein deutsches Phänomen gewesen.
Ja, da musst du dich aber tatsächlich von Leipzig komplett trennen. Also das ist ja auch organisatorisch schwierig zu – ja, weil du – also du machst AB Leipzig von Red Bull unabhängig. Lustiges Projekt. Ja, aber ich glaube, es ist halt – es ist Geist hat ja wirklich seit fünf oder sechs Jahren in regelmäßigen Abständen durch irgendwelche Presse, wer da gerade wie im Gespräch ist. Und das wir doch schon verhandelt haben und gleich geht es los. Und bis jetzt ist nie was draus geworden. Und tatsächlich wird es nicht realistischer geworden in den letzten Jahren. Weil, wenn du in England Strahlkraft abgreifen willst, welchem Club müsstest du dich zuwenden, um das zu tun, um mehr Strahlkraft zu kriegen als mit RB Leipzig? Das wäre wahrscheinlich nicht der, keine Ahnung, der FCs VfMten, sondern dann müsste es wahrscheinlich schon eher ein großer Club sein mit einem Namen. Und dann wird die Auswahl schon relativ gering oder sehr teuer. Und dann die Möglichkeit zu haben, was ist ich, einen namhaften Zwootligisten zu nehmen und den in einer Liga, wo diverse Leute rumrennen, die viel Geld haben, den dann irgendwie in eine Position zu bringen, um dieselbe Strahlkraft abzufassen. Ich kann es mir tatsächlich auch eher schwierig vorstellen, ich würde sowas auch nie ausschließen, aber ich halte es gerade nicht für – also ich glaube nicht, dass das in irgendeiner Form auf der Tagesordnung steht, ich glaube sowieso nicht, aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass das irgendwie ein sinniger und rational sinniger Schritt wäre.
Ich hätte mir mal aufhören, meine letzten Hoffnungen auf ein baldiges Ableben von RW Leipzig zu nehmen.
Naja, ich kann sie noch ein bisschen befreuen, Jens. Ja, in England ist gerade schon viel Geld. Das heißt, dein Wettbewerbsvorteil in England kann nicht sein, dass du durch Geld den Wettbewerb dominierst oder dir zumindest das wirtschaftliche Risiko dadurch nimmst und damit hochkommst. Aber ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass Ralf Rangnick sich als nächstes Projekt, wenn man jetzt in die Champions League gekommen ist und die nächste Saison dann erstmal etwas ernüchternder wird, und man sich dann irgendwann darauf verständigt, ja, das Ziel ist, irgendwie unter die Top 4 zu kommen. Und das ist ja irgendwie auch alles ganz nett, aber nicht ganz so die Sterne, nachdem man sonst so greift. Vielleicht sagt sich Ralf Rangnick dann, naja, dann gehe ich in die Liga, in der die Nachwuchsleistungszentren, in der die Trainingslehre noch am rückständigsten ist. Es ist ja kein Zufall, dass die Premier League im europäischen Vergleich in der Champions League jetzt schon so viele Jahre auf Erfolge wartet, die man früher mal hatte. Das hat ja ganz viel damit zu tun, wie dort drüben Fußball gelehrt und gespielt wird. Vielleicht entdeckt er schon nochmal den Fußballlehrer in sich und sagt, ja, jetzt gehe ich da rüber und er zeigt es mal den Engländern. Und dann ist der Wettbewerbsvorteil da drüben nicht die Kohle, denn das kann es nicht sein, sondern, dass wir da zum einen aus unserem Pool aus bis dahin wahrscheinlich 200 Spielern schöpfen und zum anderen wir haben die Trainingslehre, wir haben die wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse und und und. Also ich will es jetzt auch nicht heraufbeschwören, aber ich sehe da schon Argumente, die das möglich machen. Und ich finde es schon interessant, was gerade in Salzburg passiert. Da gibt es große Wut unter den Fans, zum Teil auch unter den Trainern und Verantwortlichen. Ein offener Brief der Fans, in dem sie geschrieben haben, wir sind eine Lachnummer im Clubfußball. Ich zitiere, wir sind diejenigen, die in Regen, Wind und Sturm und Schnee, das ist ein Ausdruck aus einem ihrer Gesänge, trotzen und unsere Mannschaft in guten und schlechten Zeiten unterstützen. Doch woran, Matthias – also Matthias ist jetzt nicht zitiert – doch woran, Matthias, sollen wir noch glauben? Hinter wem sollen wir stehen? Eingespielte Mannschaft werden fast schon traditionell in Anführungszeichen ständig zerrissen, was unsere Elf ständig an höheren sportlichen Erfolgen scheitern lässt. Da ist der Frucht groß in Salzburg.
Das ist natürlich auch eine Folge des völlig anderen Konzepts seit 2012. Wir sind ein Ausbildungsklub. Wir holen die Leute über Lieferungen rein und bilden sie hier in zwei Jahre aus und wenn sie fertig sind, dann verlassen sie den Verein. Wie gesagt, die sind ja am Anfang nicht nach Leipzig gekommen. Dann kamen irgendwie die Bankspieler vielleicht nach Leipzig, die in Salzburg hin haben wollten. Die Guten sind ja dann irgendwo anders hingegangen. Das ist ja das Konzept von Salzburg seit 2012, dass die Leute ausbilden. Ich sage mal, wenn du dieses Konzept als Idee nimmst, dann machen sie das extrem gut, weil sie sind in der Bundesliga in Österreich immer noch mit großem Abstand Erster trotz irgendwie einer extrem jungen Mannschaft. Sie haben irgendwie in den letzten vier Jahren 100 Millionen Euro in Transferplus erwirtschaftet. Also das, was sie konzeptuell machen, machen die extrem gut. Da kannst du dich dann als Fan auf den Kopf stellen vielleicht und sagen, gefällt mir nicht, obwohl sie zur Youth League dann irgendwie 5000 Leute ins Stadion kriegen, wo ich dann auch denke, was ist der Unterschied zwischen eurer Nachwuchsmannschaft, die in der Youth League spielt und eurem Profi-Team, was letztlich auch so eine Nachwuchsmannschaft ist, wo ausgebildet wird. Das ist halt das Konzept des Vereins. Das ist aber das Konzept des Vereins in der Zielstellung schon seit 2009 oder Ewigkeiten, als noch niemand daran gedacht hat, dass die Spieler zu RB Leipzig gehen könnten. Einfach klar war, du kannst das in Österreich nicht durch. Außer du machst das so ewig wie in der Anfangszeit, dass du dir irgendwie Trapatoni an die Linie stellst und irgendwelche abgreifenden Leute aus Deutschland holst. Das rechnet sich halt nicht. Da pumst du halt von Jahr zu Jahr Geld rein. Und Drangnick war der erste, der diese Idee wir bilden junge Leute aus und verdienen damit auch Geld umgesetzt hat. Und das Konzept haben sie jetzt zu Ende umgesetzt. Und in dem Konzept verdienen sie gerade Geld und sind trotzdem sportlich erfolgreich. Also was wird zu einer grundlegenden Idee von Vereinsarbeit in einem kleinen europäischen Land mehr erreichen? Also das ist halt so, ja, verstehe die emotionale Ebene. Vor allem, weil auch Leute weggegangen sind, an denen tatsächlich das Herz hing. Ja, irgendwie, gerade der Il-Sanker, der dann irgendwie nach Leipzig gekommen ist. Und für den aber der Zeitpunkt dran war, dass er einfach den nächsten Schritt macht, wenn er irgendwie in seiner Karriere nochmal machen will. Oder den Hinterelger, der dann weggegangen ist als Integrationsfigur. Klar ist das emotional irgendwie vielleicht nicht fetzig. So, wenn du irgendwie 2005 mit dem Anspruch gestartet bist, demnächst gewinnen wir irgendwie die Champions League. Was natürlich immer Quatsch war. Aber das ist die Realität des österreichischen Fußballs. Also ohne dazu despektierlich sein zu wollen.
Aber das heißt, fühlt man sich da auch nicht solidarisch mit den Salzburger Fans? Weil das kann doch jeder nachvollziehen, wie schlimm diese Situation für die sein muss.
Dass Spiele weggehen? Aber wie gesagt, das ist das Los, wenn du tatsächlich das Konzept hast, Spiele auszubilden und damit Transferlöse zu erzielen. Und in einer kleinen europäischen Liga spielt, ist das irgendwie dein Los. Gepragt beim FC Basel verkaufen auch permanent ihre besten Talente.
Also keine risikosale Tät. Aber das war doch nicht das Konzept, als der Verein irgendwann mal aus der Salzburg übernommen hatte. Sondern das entstand ja jetzt erst durch Leipzig. Und vor allen Dingen hat das ja auch dieses Gefühl mit sich gebracht. Nicht nur, hey, wir sind ein cooler, hipper Ausbildungsclub, wie es der FC Porto ist oder sowas. Der, der seit Jahrzehnten Spieler aus Südamerika holt und nachher in Europa verteilt. Sondern wir sind die fucking zweite Wahl von Red Bull. Das ist doch das, was rüberkommt. Und das finde ich dann, also damit könnte ich mich auch schwer arrangieren, selbst wenn ich dann immer noch ein hipper Ausbildungsclub bin.
Ja, ich wüsste wahrscheinlich, ich glaube, ich könnte mit so einer Perspektive von hipper Ausbildungsclub ohne anfangen. Aber guck drei Jahre weiter, vielleicht sieht es dann schon wieder anders aus und man ist mit der Perspektive total fein. Also keine Ahnung, da bin ich tatsächlich, das ist mein Empathievermögen mit Salzburg, da bin ich einfach auch nicht nah genug dran oder es ist auch nicht mein emotionales Thema. Ich verstehe, wo es herkommt, weil es irgendwie in den letzten Jahren ein extremer Durchlauferhitzer war für Talente und bis auf so ein paar, drei, vier andere Personen da irgendwie viel einfach durchgewälzt wurde. Von daher verstehe ich, wo das herkommt, weil das ist jetzt Fan-Emotion, aber das ist ein Salzburger Thema. Das ist nicht meins. Ohne das abwertend zu meinen, aber das müssen die mit sich austragen, das müssen sie als Konzept irgendwie auskämpfen. Da bin ich Fan von Red Bull Salzburg.
Hast du denn überhaupt keine Befürchtung, dass das Leipzig irgendwann mal blühen könnte?
Kannst du Jens nicht doch Hoffnungen machen?
Ich würde sagen, nein, nein, mich interessiert das einfach so als Fan, weil das ist ja, wie ich eben bei 50 plus 1 sagte, ich glaube, was da bei vielen Traditionsvereinen so ein bisschen auch auf Fanseite der Antrieb war, 50 plus 1 zu erhalten, war immer diese Angst, dass man gesehen hat, was in England oder keine Ahnung dann auch in Salzburg passiert, wenn einfach ein Investor kommt, den Laden auf links dreht und die gesamte Identität, mit der du dich immer über Jahre oder Jahrzehnte verbunden gefühlt hast, einfach wegfällt. Und die Gefahr sehe ich jetzt bei RB. Ihr sagt jetzt aktuell vielleicht nicht, ist nicht super akut. Ich sehe sie ja schon trotzdem irgendwie vielleicht auch durch die Hoffnung getrieben, dass dieses Furunkel weiterzieht nach England, wo eh schon alles den Bach runtergeht. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, gibt es da diese Angst gar nicht, dass der Verein, der jetzt so hingepflanzt wurde, wirklich nur Mittel zum Zweck ist und dann irgendwann, wenn der Zweck erfüllt ist, auch einfach wieder fallen gelassen wird, weil es ein cooleres Spielzeug gibt?
Also tatsächlich gibt es die Angst bei mir nicht, aber ich hänge auch nicht so daran, jedes Jahr um die deutsche Meisterschaft mit spielen zu müssen. Das ist mir wahrscheinlich, weil ich noch nie an der Situation war, in solchen Sphären zu schwimmen, sondern eigentlich immer mit unterklassigem Fußball zu tun hatte. Tatsächlich habe ich die Angst nicht und so diese Zukunftsidee, was passiert mit dem Verein, irgendwann ist aus meiner Sicht eine völlig offene Frage, was passiert in zehn Jahren, zwanzig Jahren, selbst wenn sich Red Bull mal vielleicht irgendwann denken, das machen wir nicht mehr. Ich finde, es gibt viele, die die These haben, dass entsteht eine Struktur, die sich vielleicht doch irgendwann ohne Red Bull trägt. Vielleicht nicht auf erste vier Plätze, aber auf so einem normalen Niveau, was Bremen oder Hannover auch haben.
Zweite Liga ist gut, macht Hannover.
Leipzig dann irgendwann in zehn Jahren eine Fußballstruktur mit einem funktionierenden Sponsor jenseits von Red Bull, auf den du auch anders aufbauen kannst, falls es irgendwann Red Bull nicht mehr gibt und sie sagen, wir machen jetzt was in Neuseeland oder so. Weil da sind gerade Extremsportler und sie spielen nur Fußball. Keine Ahnung. Aber ich persönlich habe auch keine Angst davor, gegen den Abstieg zu spielen. Von daher ist mir das doch relativ wurscht.
Okay, wir haben hier einen Furchtlosen in der Runde. Aber ich meine, der Punkt ist insofern ja schon interessant, dass es ja auch auf dieses Thema der Abhängigkeit abzielt. Und das hat Jens vor einiger Zeit, als wir darüber gesprochen haben, dass Leipzig als Marketinginstrument Red Bulls verstanden werden kann, gesagt. Das eine ist, ob du einen bestehenden Verein für Marketing nutzt oder ob du einen Verein mit dem Ziel des Marketings gründest. Und ihr hängt natürlich schon an der ganzen Strategie Red Bulls. Und das ist eine Fußball-Fernestrategie. Hier geht es um Marketing. Und Dietrich Matteschitz, der macht auch mal Servos TV, den eigenen Fernsehsender, dicht, weil die im Betriebsrat gründen wollen. Zwei Tage später sagt er, ach nee, jetzt haben sie sich das mit dem Betriebsrat anders überlegt. Dann können wir doch weiter senden. Er kokettiert mit einem Formel-1-Ausstieg. Also, ich will jetzt einfach nur sagen, da gibt es ja schon eine Abhängigkeit. Und das hat ja Jens gerade angedeutet. Das ist der wesentliche Punkt, wenn man auch über sowas wie 50 plus 1 redet und um Sorgen, die andere Fans haben, dass sie eben in eine solche Abhängigkeit geraten. Und jetzt wäre meine Frage an dich, wobei ich glaube, jetzt die Antwort aus deiner Gelassenheit schon heraus zu hören. Sorgen macht dir das keiner. Aber bist du da auch stellvertretend für die Leipzig-Fans? Ich kann mir das fast nicht vorstellen, dass man sich darüber keine Gedanken macht.
Ich kenne das tatsächlich nicht wirklich als großes Thema. Von daher sage ich, das ist kein großes Thema. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, die interessantere Frage ist tatsächlich, was aus dieser Fußballstruktur auf Perspektive entsteht. Also das, was ja die Idee von Minster ist, ist, diesen Verein trotz allem die Red Bull-Beteiligung auf unter 30 Prozent zu senken. Und je weiter du so eine Beteiligung senkst, und je mehr du diesen Verein tatsächlich lokal verankerst und andere Partner mit ins Boot kriegst und den Verein auf breitere Füße stellst, hast du ja sowieso muss, wenn du dein Ziel hast, irgendwie jedes Jahr Omni-Champions-Sieg mit spielen zu wollen. Weil das pumpt dir nicht jedes Jahr Red Bull in den Verein. Du brauchst einfach einen Verein, der breiter aufgestellt ist, über TV-Einnahmen, Ticketing, neue Sponsoren. Und das ist ja sowieso ein Thema. Und diese Fußballstruktur wächst ja auch gerade. Und ich sag doch mal, wenn du zehn Jahre weiter guckst, bist du bei einem Verein, wo Red Bull vielleicht da noch 30 Prozent trägt und du einfach über einen neuen Stadion und die Ticketing-Einnahmen und über eine andere Verankerung einfach viel mehr andere Einnahmen hast. Also ich finde so diese Prognose, Red Bull steigt in zehn Jahren aus und dann ist der Verein tot, finde ich halt schwierig, weil es ist nicht, es ist nicht, keine Ahnung, es ist nicht Hoffenheim, es ist Leipzig, es ist eine Großstadt. Du hast ja einfach auch nochmal andere Möglichkeiten der Verankerung in der Stadt, die du woanders so vielleicht nicht hast.
Also ich finde deine Prognose, ich finde die Prognose genauso schwierig. Ehrlich gesagt, für mich sind das so zwei Extreme von der Selbstrichtweise. Ich meine, du extrapolierst halt jetzt sozusagen den bestmöglichen Fall. Ich sehe erstens total kritisch, dass sich andere Unternehmen überhaupt engagieren in dem Maße als Sponsoren neben so einer starke Marke wie Red Bull. Und der Verein heißt ja nun mal fast so, wie diese Marke. Und zum Zweiten würde ich das Argument mit, es ist eine Großstadt und hier ist wirtschaftliche Kraft da. Anders als vielleicht da in Sinzheim. Auch sehr schwierig, weil hier ist ja kein originär produzierendes Gewerbe von hier ansässig, sondern die zwei großen produzierenden Automobilhersteller, die sponsoren schon andere Vereine aus den Städten, wo auch die Kapitalgesellschaften sitzen von denen, nämlich in Stuttgart und in München. Und ich sehe hier nicht die anderen an der Tür kratzen. Und ich glaube, so ein Sponsorenmodell wie ein Aue, dass irgendwie jeder mit 15.000 Euro dabei ist, jeder Elektromeister, das sehe ich irgendwie auch nicht so richtig hier kommen, weil das sich nämlich alles mit dem beißt, was du ganz am Anfang gesagt hast, dass nämlich Red Bull immer den Anspruch hat, selber die Struktur zu sein. Und deswegen glaube ich schon, dass wenn die irgendwann keinen Bock mehr haben, ist hier der Stecker gezogen. Also ich sehe wenig andere realistische Szenarien. So ein Übergang in so eine Mischkalkulation kann ich persönlich mir aus meinem jetzigen Wissen ganz schlecht vorstellen.
Ja, war heute. Also ich denke es auch als Struktur weiter. Also es ist halt schon klar, mit Stand heute ist das unmöglich. Wenn sich Red Bull rauszieht, ist der Stecker gezogen. Ohne Zweifel. Aber ich halte das für so eine prognostische Debatte, die extrem schwierig ist. Tatsächlich kannst du verschiedene Szenarien spinnen, aber ich halte es tatsächlich in einer Stadt wie Leipzig nicht für unmöglich, dass man eine Red Bull-Struktur in eine andere Struktur überführen kann, wie sie Hannover oder Bremen hat. Also das ist halt auf einer ähnlichen Größe der Stadt vergleichbar, halte ich es nicht für unmöglich. Eine Struktur, die besteht und die da ist, von den ganzen Infrastrukturen etc. halte ich es nicht für unmöglich, so eine Infrastruktur in etwas anderes zu überführen.
Ich bin da möglicherweise etwas skeptischer, aber das liegt auch in den Strukturen des Vereins und so begründet, weil das ist halt einfach 100% Red Bull. Wenn du jetzt von Bremen oder Hannover redest, das sind alles eingetragene Vereine, die darunter stehen, wo zigtausend Mitglieder sind, die halt auch noch da sind. Red Bull hat 17 Mitglieder, die Stimmrechte haben und das sind alles Red Bull-Angestellte oder Red Bull-Nahleute. Also ich weiß nicht, wo diese Struktur herkommen soll, weil ich mir einfach auch Matty Jitt, so wie ich ihn jetzt erleben durfte, via Interviews und was auch immer, der wirkt mir dazu radikal und zu straight. Der sagt dann einfach, ich follow dann gar, also ganz oder gar nicht.
Wir bewegen uns sehr im Bereich der Spekulation. Deswegen würde ich gerne diesen Punkt an der Stelle dicht machen. Nee, jetzt können wir nicht auch noch mit dem Trinkspiel anfangen. Dafür ist es viel zu weit fortgeschritten. Liebe Leute, aber ich finde, es gibt noch einen großen Themenkomplex, den wir noch kurz ansprechen sollten. Und das zeichnet sich schon ab, dass wir jetzt auch gar nicht alle Details angesprochen haben werden, was kaum vorstellbar ist aufgrund dieser Sendungslänge. Aber der große Punkt der Kritik und zwar zum einen in den Medien an Red Bull Leipzig. Jetzt sage ich selber schon Red Bull Leipzig. Wahnsinn, wie ihr mich versaut habt. Das gibt es ja nicht. Aber liebe Hörer, es ist auch tatsächlich gerade sehr spät. Vielleicht ein Noise. Die Sonne scheint bei Tag und Nacht Maurizio Gardino, sage ich dazu. Also in den Medien auch fehlende Kritik. Es gibt auch sehr kritiklose Medienberichterstattung über Leipzig. Dann natürlich die Kritik von Fans an Leipzig und welche Ausformungen wir da gesehen haben. Und dann interessiert mich aber auch der Umgang mit Kritik von Seiten Leipzigs und der große Komplex, den wir wahrscheinlich jetzt nur anschneiden können. Generell Kritik an Red Bull und auch an der Person Mathe Schütze. Das ist jetzt auch immer wieder so indirekt durchgeklungen schon vorher. Aber lasst mal vielleicht bei der Medienberichterstattung über Leipzig anfangen. Und da würde mich tatsächlich deine Meinung Matthias als Erste interessieren. Wie nimmst du das denn wahr? Ja, lass es gerne mal unterscheiden. Beginnen wir doch mal lokal und dann darf Andreas auch gerne was dazu sagen.
Der muss speigen.
Speigen oder speien? Speigen.
Vielleicht muss er auch speien. Ja, es hat sich zumindest deutlich gewandelt lokal. Du hast gerade in der Anfangszeit einen durchaus distanzierten Umgang mit dem Verein gehabt. Gerade was so den lokalen MDR und so angeht, auch LVZ. Mal abgesehen von Guido Schäfer. Da gab es schon immer so eine recht distanzierte Berichterstattung, die aber auch so mit einem eher distanzierten Verhalten des Vereins gegenüber der Stadt zu tun hatte. Der war ja schon in der Anfangszeit immer noch in so einer Dienstleisterposition von wir sind gekommen, um euch was Gutes zu tun. Und in so einem Umgang war das dann tatsächlich auch in den Medien. Und ja, tatsächlich ist das dann über die Jahre, ich glaube so 2011, 2012 war dann so ein Wendepunkt, wo man alle auch gemerkt haben, dass RB Leipzig irgendwie die Klicks bringt, wo es doch so einen deutlichen Wandel hin dazu gab, dass der Verein irgendwie in der Stadt angekommen war und auch von den lokalen Medien als lokaler Verein anerkannt und ich sage mal begleitet wurde. So und ja, inzwischen ist das das meiste recht belanglos, was so lokal passiert oder recht eng an dem, was sportlich passiert, sagen wir es mal so. Und ich sage mal jenseits. Ich glaube so der Wandel besteht ein bisschen daran, dass gerade so, was ich immer spannend finde, dass so Fan, also wenn so mal so Fan-Themen so ein bisschen oft ploppen so im Hintergrund, dass du eigentlich relativ wenig Zeitungen hast oder Presse hast, die das tatsächlich nochmal oft greifen. Also generell abstraktere Themen. Also es gibt eine sehr nahe Berichterstattung an den sportlichen Dingen, aber so auf so einer Meterebene gibt es relativ wenig an der Auseinandersetzung. Das ist mir auch nicht so richtig klar. Das verstehe ich auch nicht. Also kann ich dir tatsächlich auch nicht wirklich erklären. Also es gibt die Mitteldeutsche Zeitung, die macht das schon immer noch ab und zu auf so Metathemen aufgreifen und so ein bisschen Sachen von allen Seiten zu versuchen zu beleuchten, aber so. Ansonsten ist das schon eher inzwischen ja, ich sage Sportberichterstattung. Lokale und wir für Leipzig. Einmal Leipzig, immer Leipzig. Aber ja, keine Ahnung. Also ich finde es manchmal, manchmal finde ich es ein bisschen erstaunlich, bei welchen Themen dann tatsächlich nicht vorkommen, weil ich finde, die wären vielleicht vor drei Jahren noch gekommen.
Andreas, möchtest du da was ergänzen?
Ich finde das bestimmt.
Darf ich wieder reden?
Ach so, ja, aber nach den Gründen. Ich finde, das liegt relativ auf der Hand. Also ich meine, ich habe auch mal selber ein Jahr in einer Lokalredaktion gearbeitet. Und wenn man weiß, das und das war vor zehn Jahren. Und wenn man weiß, wie jetzt der Personalschlüssel da ist, die haben einfach die Leute nicht dafür. Also hier Leipzig, die LVZ, das wird ja produziert von der Mazak-Gruppe. Und die haben ja die Desks so zusammengelegt. Also da kommt ja irgendwie, da kommt auch ein Teil der Hanoverischen Allgemeine, wird hiermit gemacht und umgedreht und so. Und in diesem Untergang, in diesem wirklich grandiosen Piratengefecht, wo du so ein brennendes Schiff noch irgendwie seine letzten Kanonenkugeln verschießt, das betrifft jetzt den Print-Journalismus. Da ist für die Red Bull Leipzig natürlich ein Asset, mit dem sie nochmal jetzt auch wieder eine lokale Relevanz erzeugen können, für sich auch und für ihre Leserschaft. Und die haben auch so einen Online-Portal, den Sport-Buzzer und so. Und wenn es hier keinen Erstliga-Fußball oder Zweitliga-Fußball zumindest gäbe, dann sähe das alles noch schlimmer aus. Und deswegen sehe ich die weder wirtschaftlich, noch – ja, ich sehe die einfach gar nicht in der Lage, da irgendwie so breitere Themen auch mal aufzugreifen und vielleicht nochmal was Kritisches zu recherchieren. Da können die gar kein inkrementelles Interesse dran haben. Journalismus hin oder her. Und vielleicht ist deswegen auch die MZ, wo der Uli Krömer ja auch arbeitet, die das mit ein bisschen Abstand dann auch eher machen. Aber ich kenne das auch aus vielen noch anderen so Zwischenstationen. Leute, die freie Journalisten sind, aber vielleicht mal für den Bullenfunk auch mal was gemacht haben oder was machen. Spitzenname übrigens für ein Online-Radio, für einen Fußball-Sendung, Bullenfunk, das finde ich wirklich klasse.
Ich finde auch, dass das ein super Name ist. Da bin ich jetzt mal nicht schlecht dran. Rabafunk wäre noch besser, finde ich.
Ich meinte natürlich wegen der Assoziation zur Kommunikation von der Polizei.
Ach so, da habe ich jetzt nicht drin gedacht.
Aber wie auch immer. Ich glaube einfach, da erwartet man zu viel. Dass einzelne Journalisten wie Guido Schäfer, den ich hochgradig sympathisch finde im direkten Umgang... Du wurdest gerade aus dem Podcast gelöscht durch. Ich muss auch sagen, mein persönlicher Umgang mit ihm war auch immer mit Schnaps und im Dunkeln. Von daher ist es vielleicht auch relativ leicht, ihn sympathisch zu finden. Dass einzelne Personen profitieren davon, wenn ein Profifußballverein vor der Haustür ist und sie eben mal eingeladen werden in das schöne Flughafenhotel Kempinski nach München und so. Dass die quasi davon kompromittiert werden, das kann man denen ja gar nicht übel nehmen. Da würde ich mich jetzt auch selber gar nicht ausnehmen. Da glaube ich auch nicht, dass ich da moralisch irgendwie besser oder anders wäre, wenn ich so ein Sportjournalist wäre und hätte so eine Chance vor der Nase.
Sollte das nicht der Anspruch sein, wenn du Journalist wirst? Also ja, natürlich ist Praxis und Theorie was anderes, aber…
Ja, aber ich… Ja, also natürlich, da gibt es diesen Anspruch und es gibt auch Leute, die den verfolgen. Gibt ja auch Redaktionen. Die werden aber auch im eigenen Haus dann angefallen, zum Teil. Also was… Ich mache ja das mal kurz ganz weit, sorry, aber auch vielleicht der Urteil, was der HU. Zeppelt sich anhören musste, als er damals bei der Biathlon-WM über vermeintliche Dopingverstrickung der deutschen Biathletinnen, was der sich live und er von seinem WDR-Kollegen anhören musste, ja, wie der in der Live-Sendung auseinandergenommen wurde von einem Kollegen, obwohl der Sachverhalt noch gar nicht geklärt war. Man braucht sich doch keine Illusionen hingeben. Der Sportjournalismus, wenn du da investigativ bist, da bist du schmerzgeil. Da willst du es nicht anders. Da willst du am Katzentisch sitzen, da willst du nicht mit Wolf-Christoph Fuss beim Herbert Award am Montagabend noch in Hamburg bis halb zwei saufen, sondern da hast du Bock dran, dicke Akten durchzuwälzen, um zehn nach Hause zu gehen und keiner gratuliert dir dafür. Dann bist du investigativ im Sportjournalismus.
Ich glaube übrigens auch, dass Red Bull und da kommen wir jetzt, das klingt jetzt unfassbar doof, weil das, was in Dortmund vor dem Stadion vorgefallen ist, halt auch einfach nicht zu entschuldigen ist. Ich glaube trotzdem, dass Red Bull da sehr viel Macht ausspielt, auch im Hintergrund. Ich kann jetzt leider keine Namen nennen, aber ich habe Bekannte, die in Mitteldeutschland für Zeitschriften gearbeitet haben und entsprechend dann auch Probleme mit ihrem Chef bekamen, als sie sich kritisch über Raba geäußert haben, also kritische Artikel veröffentlicht haben, weil Raba entsprechend Druck auf diese Zeitung ausgeübt hat. Und das war auch so ein bisschen mein Eindruck in dieser gesamten Affäre rund um das Dortmund-Spiel, dass da einfach sehr viel Druck auch politisch aufgebaut wurde, weil, glaube ich, Raba einfach gut vernetzt ist. Und viele – Guido Schäfer hat das, ich weiß nicht, ob er das getwittert hat oder im Doppelpass gesagt hat, wo er gesagt hat, natürlich würde ich gerne bei denen auf der Payroll stehen. Wer nicht? Und genau das ist, glaube ich, auch so ein Ding, wenn du einfach so ein riesiger Konzern bist, der immer mal jemanden fürs PR gebrauchen könnte, dann kannst du halt auch Druck ausüben und dann kannst du den Leuten auch sagen, schreib doch mal das und das in deinen Text und guck mal, wie schlimm das und das ist. Und ich glaube, genau das machen sie dann auch. Nicht nur, weil ich glaube, dass der Sportjournalismus die gerade festgestellten Probleme in sich selber hat, weil da viel zu viel Gefährlichkeitsjournalismus gemacht wird, um eben weiterhin eingeladen zu werden zu irgendwelchen Veranstaltungen oder Sonstiges. Und ich glaube, dass das Raber dann auch noch aktiv Druck macht. Einfach im Hintergrund.
Also so ein paar Sachen dazu, glaube ich. Also um Guido Schäfer auch mal in Schütz zu nehmen, die Geschichte, dass er gerne auf der Peru bei RB stehen würde, die erzählt er seit sieben Jahren. Und seitdem es den Verein gibt.
Das macht es doch nicht besser.
Oder?
Ich kann noch nicht zu meinem Bericht ergeben.
Ist eher auch ein Witz darüber, was man bei RB verdient und was man seiner Meinung nach als Journalist nicht verdient. Also, dass Guido Schäfer bei RB Leipzig anfangen könnte und anfangen wollte, ist tatsächlich in diesem Leben nicht vorstellbar. Das passt tatsächlich überhaupt nicht in seine Lebensperspektiven und auch in sein Selbstbild, was er als Chefreporter von sich hat und als Marke in der Stadt. Von daher, ich glaube gerade bei Guido Schäfer…
Dafür kriecht er dem Club aber ganz schön in den Arsch, wenn ich das so sage.
Nein, Guido Schäfer ist eine spezielle Person. Wahrscheinlich ist es genauso die Sonne. Den kennt man halt nur hier. Guido Schäfer schreibt seit 16 Jahren jeden Leipziger Verein in die Bundesliga. Seitdem er ein Leipziges ist, will er irgendwie, dass irgendein Verein in die Bundesliga aufsteigt. Und das ist völlig wurscht, ob der damals FC Sachsen hieß, Lok Leipzig hieß oder inzwischen RB Leipzig heißt. Also, das ist eine völlige Wahllosigkeit. Und auch so klassischer lokaler Sportjournalismus in meiner Stadt sollte ein Fußballverein in der Bundesliga sein. Und das ist natürlich für ihn super, weil er natürlich dann dadurch auch bei Sky und so oft taucht und nochmal irgendwie anders als Marke erscheinen kann, als er es früher in der vierten Liga in wahnwitzigen Duellen mit irgendjemanden tun konnte. Also, bei allem, was man an Guido Schäfer komisch finden kann und so ganz, dass sie sich mir immer noch nicht erschlossen, warum sie ihn bei Sky ausgerechnet zu derseits nur Engel anahm, muss man bei ihm auch immer mal so ein bisschen die Kirche im Dorf lassen. Ich glaube, er war der einzige Journalist bis jetzt, der es geschafft hat, dass ihm auf der Presse, auf der Internetseite von Erbe Leipzig eine Gegendausstellung gewidmet wurde. Also, er hat schon seine Geschichten gemacht in den letzten Jahren und sich dafür auch immer mal wieder gerne in die Nesseln gesetzt. Das kann man ihm tatsächlich nicht vorwerfen, aber er ist tatsächlich ein herzerfrischender Streiter für die Sache. Das gehört aber zu lui zu seinem Markenkern dazu. Also, nur das zu Schäfer, die muss man auch mal ein bisschen verstehen. Ich glaube, was mir bei diesen Dortmund-Geschichten immer so ein bisschen in der Nähe zu aufschüttet, ist halt so dieses, das hat immer so einen leicht verschwörungstheoretischen Touch, weil ich habe das glaube ich vorhin schon mal gesagt, wenn du Erbe Leipzig-Themen hast und wenn die nicht sportlich sind und wenn die irgendwie noch etwas dazu mit Gewalt zu tun haben, das ist sofort und auf jeden Fall für jede Redaktion in diesem Land, wo sie sagen, das ist unser Thema, dann machen wir etwas dazu. Egal von woher wir eine Stimme kriegen, egal was los ist, das müssen wir irgendwie drin haben, weil das bringt Klicks. Und du hast einfach in dieser Dortmund-Geschichte, wo du sofort noch am Tag, du hast eine klare Mitteilung der Polizei, du hast klare Stellungnahmen der Fanprojekte, du hast klare Stellungnahmen von Vereinen, du hast am nächsten Tag offene Briefe von Fans im Netz, du hast eine derart explosive Mischung, wo dieser Medienfuhrohr, der in den nächsten Tagen getruppt ist, eine völlig logische Konsequenz ist. Mag sein, dass das irgendwie Erbe Leipzig nicht schlecht getan hat in so einer Geschichte. Aber irgendwie so zu tun, als hätten die irgendwie den hervorher raufbeschwemmt, das verkennt so ein bisschen die Realitäten dessen, wie Mediengeschäft in dem Land funktioniert. Und ich beobachte das jetzt seit sieben Jahren. Und ich glaube, ich weiß relativ genau, wie so Aufregungsgeschichten rund um Erbe Leipzig passieren und wie sie nicht immer zum Nutzen des Vereins auch ausgeschlachtet wurden. Also das hält sich dann schon auch durchaus die Waage.
Da würde ich jetzt mal zwei konkrete Gegenbeispiele bringen. Am Tag nach dem Dortmund-Spiel sind in Frankfurt Darmstadt und Frankfurt-Fans aufeinander getroffen. Und ich würde behaupten, da ist deutlich mehr passiert, als das, was in Dortmund war. Da gab es keinen Anruf vom Bundesinnenminister beim Geschäftsführer der Eintracht. Und das Zweite ist, Max sprach es eben an Übergriffe von RB-Ordnern auf Hamburg-Fans und Polizisten. Auch das wurde nicht so breit getreten, wie das in Dortmund. Ich glaube schon, dass da auch, dass man sich so ein bisschen von RB-Seiten, diese Opferrolle, das war, passte einfach ganz gut. Dortmund hat immer laut Kritik geübt, auch Aki Watzke, wobei das im Gegensatz zu Uli Hoeneß zum Beispiel im Intro wunderschön bei Aki Watzke, bei Raba immer sehr sachlich war. Der hat da auch immer gesagt, ey, die bringen viele Fans mit, ist voll in Ordnung, aber RB ist halt nicht so cool. Da wurde nie Öl ins Feuer gekippt von Aki Watzke oder sowas, was er bei Hoffenheim zum Beispiel, da hat er noch viel, viel lauter gepoltert seiner Zeit. Und ich glaube, das passte einfach ganz gut, das jetzt einfach mal zu nutzen, um sich nochmal so richtig zu inszenieren. Vielleicht interpretiere ich da zu viel rein, aber ich habe so im Vergleich zu den anderen Geschichten, die rundherum passiert sind, dass eine Woche später die Hamburg-Fans von Ordner verprügelt wurden und du in der überregionalen Presse nichts davon gelesen hast. Du hast das Video irgendwo bei Facebook finden können. Dass sich in Frankfurt die Ultra-Gruppierungen auf offener Straße und dass da Cafés auseinander genommen werden. Hey, auch das war relativ kleine Meldungen und hat keine Innenminister-Anrufe beim Geschäftsführer verursacht. Ich habe mir schon vorstellen, dass da ein bisschen Kampagne gemacht wurde.
Ja, ich glaube gerade in dem Fall nicht wirklich. Aber ich kann es noch mal sagen, ich beobachte das seit sieben Jahren und du hast einfach, was RB Leipzig angeht, wenn du irgendein nicht sportliches Thema hast und sei es, was es will, hast du einfach eine andere Aufregungskultur als bei irgendeinem Thema, wo ich sage mal, Leute sich in Frankfurt zwischen Frankfurt und Darmstadt auf die Nase hauen. Das interessiert tatsächlich vielleicht an einem Wochenende schon ein bisschen mehr. Aber das ist einfach Medienaufregungspolitik. Du machst, was Klicks bringt. Und das ist einfach im Normalfall bei solchen Themen immer RB Leipzig. Und das Spiel wird dann tatsächlich weitergespielt. Und ich sage mal, in den letzten Jahren waren es nicht immer Themen, die irgendwie RB Leipzig zum Vorteil kriegen. Und auch in Dortmund wäre die Geschichte viel cooler gewesen, wenn man irgendwie mit einem 1-1 nach Hause fährt, dass es nicht passiert. Und man kann sich hinterher als super sportlicher Club und was für ein geiler Auswärtsauftritt. Und der war mit 8000 Leuten da verkauft. Und das wäre für die Identität des Vereins und für seine Auswirkung sehr viel produktiver gewesen. Und ich finde es auch so ein bisschen schwierig, gerade nach dieser Dortmund-Geschichte, dann anfangen darüber zu reden, was die Medien gemacht haben. Weil es letztlich kein Medienvorkommnis gewesen ist, weil irgendwie real was passiert ist. Und dann kann man irgendwie sagen, wuppo, jetzt ganz schön viel Aufregung. Ich ziehe vier Tage den Kopf ein und dann geht es weiter. Aber so dieses dann irgendwie einen Tag später darauf zu schimpfen, dass irgendwie der Innenminister sich jetzt auch dazu äußert, bei allem, was man da dran komisch finden kann, dass der Innenminister sich dazu äußert, vielleicht dann auch so ein bisschen Ablenkung vom eigentlichen Thema, aber so grundsätzlich zu dieser Pressegeschichte von RB Leipzig. Natürlich hast du bei RB Leipzig Leute zu sitzen, die irgendwie Kommunikation als ihren Job haben. Natürlich telefonieren die Journalisten hinterher. Natürlich versuchen die irgendwie Einfluss zum Thema. Natürlich versuchen die irgendwo ihre Geschichten unterzubringen. Natürlich machen die ihren Job und versuchen irgendwie, dass die Themen so gesetzt werden, dass es dem Verein entspricht. Natürlich steht es in jeder Zeitung, dass die Umfragewerte gut sind. Oder nie im Interview mit einem Spieler. Aber das ist ihr Job. Und wenn irgendwie Redaktionen, was du als Beispiel gebracht hast, irgendwie nicht schaffen, ihre Redakteure davor zu schützen, dann ist es ein Problem der Redaktion und nicht von der Presseabteilung von RB Leipzig. Und das ist – Ich kann auch anders sehen, die Stelle. Nein, also meiner Meinung nach ganz klar, und ich kenne den Fall zufällig, das ist einfach. Entweder du hast als Redaktion einen bestimmten Punkt und sagst, okay, das ist unsere Linie, und hier stehen wir zu den Leuten, die bei uns arbeiten. Dann musst du das durchziehen. Und dann von der einen Seite, dass die irgendwie ihr Ding versuchen, und irgendwie versuchen, Sachen unterzubringen.
Aber ich kann jetzt auch aus Pressearbeit mit dem BVB behaupten, dass uns noch nie bei Schwarz-Gelb-DE gedroht wurde, dass die Akkreditierung wegfliegt und so was, weil wir nochmal einen kritischen Artikel schreiben und wir schreiben sehr kritische Artikel über den BVB. Also das ist schon Einflussnahme, die nicht nur auf – ja natürlich, telefoniert mal dahinter her. Wir wurden auch schon von Spielern angerufen, weil wir Artikel geschrieben haben. Dann haben die uns gesagt, finde ich scheiße, haben wir denen gesagt, ja, es ist unsere Meinung und gut ist, aber Akkreditierungen entziehen und so. Das ist schon ein bisschen Druck, der über das hinausgeht, was ja gute Pressearbeit ist. Das ist wirklich massive Einflussnahme und die passiert halt nicht von Seiten der Redaktion. Du sagst ja selber, RB bringt Klicks und dann zu sagen, okay, ey, ihr könnt gerne sowas weiterschreiben, aber dann berichtet ihr halt nicht mehr aus unserem Stadion. Da ist doch klar, wie jede Redaktion reagiert. Das ist schon massive Einflussnahme.
Kannst du dir als Redaktion auch bauen, wie du es brauchst? Das ist, ja, wüsste ich nicht. Also es gibt ja in England immer wieder so Fälle, wo dann irgendwie so Akkreditierungen entzogen wurden und für viele Redaktionen, glaube ich, auch von Vorteil war, dass sie irgendwie in eine Position gekommen sind, wo sie unabhängig Berichterstatten konnten. Und halt nicht mehr den Circus mitmachen mussten. Also ich glaube, es ist halt letztlich eine Frage, wo du dich positionierst und was du dir davon versprichst. Aber ich verstehe den Punkt. Klar gibt es da Grenzen. Aber genau bei diesen Grenzen müssen dann die irgendwie auch sich hinstellen und dafür einstehen, die davon betroffen sind.
Jetzt sagt mir doch die beiden Leipziger bitte einmal ganz kurz, wie viel Geld würde man mit kritischem RB-Journalismus verdienen und wie viel Geld würde man damit verdienen, wenn man den Verein Lob reißt und das schreibt, was der Verein geschrieben haben will.
Ich glaube, so ganz und so wird es auch nicht. Aber ich sage mal, für eine mitteldeutsche Zeitung macht es wahrscheinlich keinen Unterschied, was du für ein Konzept herst. Also ist der Markt, was RB-nahe Richterstattung, kritiklos angeht, schon jetzt genug.
Ich hätte es nicht gedacht, dass ich ein Thema mal abkürzen müsse in diesem Tribünengespräch. Ich hätte eigentlich ganz gern auch noch über die überregionalen Medien gesprochen, aber jetzt wird es dann doch etwas lange für alle Beteiligten. Und wir müssen auf jeden Fall das Thema der Fan-Kritik an Leipzig noch hervorstellen, denn Alex hat davorhin schon vor einiger Zeit angefangen, einen Punkt zu machen. Er hat schon Aktionen aufgezählt, Schädlingsbekämpfung, Union Berlin und so weiter und so fort. Und Alex, ich weiß, dass das für dich ein wichtiges Thema ist und dass du da auch einiges dazu zu sagen hast. Deswegen bekommst du jetzt nochmal zwei Minuten zum Umgang der Fans mit Raba Leipzig. Jetzt sage ich es doch. Vielleicht gebe ich dir auch vier.
Das gibst du mir auch vier. Nein, ihr könnt mir ja gerne auch jederzeit ins Wort fallen. Das ist ja überhaupt nicht der Punkt. Wir hatten ja vorhin schon drüber gesprochen. Das ist möglicherweise so ein bisschen vom – davon abhängt, was man jetzt am meisten mitbekommt eigentlich so an Kritik. Ob es jetzt die mediale Kritik ist, oder ob es die von Fans ist, oder ob man in Leipzig sitzen das Gefühl hat, da wird irgendwie alles rosarot gemalt. Und wirklich bin ich da auch so ein bisschen versaut von den Social Media, aber natürlich auch über das, was ich mitbekommen habe, was wirklich in Aktionen gelaufen ist. Und da scheint sich mir doch gerade in diesen wirklich sehr demonstrativen Aktionen eine hochgradig ideologische Note auszuzeichnen. Und ich schicke natürlich vorweg, dass es hier überhaupt nicht darum geht, dass es keine plakativen Aktionen geben soll. Und dass die natürlich notwendig immer so ein bisschen verkürzend ist, und wir natürlich auch vollkommen klar, weil man die Dinge ja auf den Punkt bringen muss. Aber da hat sich so ein spezieller Code dann eingespielt, der ziemlich oft zu beobachten ist, der natürlich zu beobachten war jetzt in Dortmund bei der Aktion. Also vielleicht fangen wir einfach mal damit an. Ich habe jetzt nicht alle transparente Präsent, die da gezeigt worden sind, aber das eins der größten, ich glaube, das war auch das, was da ganz unten in dieses Banner war für den Volkssport-Fußball gegen die, die ihn zerstören. So und dieses Motiv der Zerstörung, dieses Motiv, dass da AB Leipzig jemanden schädigt oder dass es Schädlinge sind, die sozusagen auch so ein bisschen wie die Heuschrecken über uns herfallen und irgendwas, was Grund, Gutes und Gesundes kaputt machen. Dieses Motiv kann man, glaube ich, in diesen Fanprotesten ziemlich häufig beobachten. Und Volkssport-Fußball zeigt ja auch so was an, das kommt jetzt irgendwie, das ist irgendwie was, was für das Volk ist, was für die Basis ist, was für uns alle da ist. Und da haben wir so ein bisschen dieses auch sehr problematische Occupy-Motiv drin. So we are the 99% und ganz, ganz schlimm ist eigentlich nur dieses eine Prozent, was es da gibt, was irgendwie alles kaputtmacht. So und man merkt so, man merkt ziemlich viel aus dieser ganzen No-Global-Bewegung, ob sich die Fans jetzt konkret darauf beziehen oder nicht, ist es erstmal zweitrangig, was sich so in der Motivik irgendwie da auch widerspiegelt. Also dieses 99% gegen 1% ist de facto daran aufgehoben. Auch so diese ganze Debatte um die Heuschrecken, das hab ich ja eben schon angesprochen, findet man da eigentlich auch wieder. Also so, wenn es nicht wörtlich ist, dann doch zumindest dem Sinn nach eben beispielsweise in dem Vorwurf, dass seien Schädlinge. Ich hab's vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen, bei dieser Aktion in Karlsruhe war es so, dass von einer Bullenseuche gesprochen worden ist. Also haben wir auch wieder dieses Krankheitsmotiv drin. Dass es irgendwie den Fußball vergiftet findet man beispielsweise darin. Oder wie in Heidenheim, auch das ist nichts Ungewöhnliches, wo halt Fans hingehen. Der Treppenwitz ist daran, dass es ausgerechnet die Heidenheimer Ultras waren. Das ist ja auch nicht gerade ein Verein, der schon wahnsinnig lange existiert und jetzt da irgendwie nur auf ehrenamtliche Arbeit gründet, um das mal so zu sagen. Die den Leipziger Bus mit Geldscheinen eindecken, auf den dann Matteschitz, das sind natürlich auch noch Dollarnoten, da haben wir dann auch noch diesen USA-Bezug, besser gesagt den Anti-Amerikanismus da drin, wo Matteschitz drauf abgebildet ist mit einer Hakennase. Ich glaube, dass das alles kein Zufall ist. Ich unterstelle noch nicht mal, dass die Leute das wirklich ganz bewusst getan haben, aber ich glaube, dass es wirklich gerade in Deutschland einen Code gibt, auf den man zurückgreifen kann in diesen Protest, der ja so ein bisschen antikapitalistisch oder Kapitalismus, kritisch besser gesagt, daherkommt und das Ganze natürlich extrem verkürzt und immer so ein bisschen nach Schuldigen sucht, nach Schuldigen sucht, Schädlinge ausmacht, Leute, die irgendwas eben was Authentisches, was uns irgendwie allen gehört, was Grundgutes, Natürliches und Überzeitliches irgendwie so kaputtmacht und das Ganze natürlich auch noch von außen. Und das ist der pathetische Gehalt, der dem ganzen innewohnt und natürlich auch die Politisierung, die daran liegt, ist für mich so das eigentliche Problem, weil es natürlich die – man kann schon gar nicht mehr von Kritik sprechen – es ist dann extrem resentmentgeladen und für mich da natürlich dann auch einfach ein erkennbares Problem, weil das teilweise auch eine Motivik umfasst, wie man sie auch im Antisemitismus findet. Das heißt natürlich überhaupt nicht, dass die gesamte Ablehnung, die sich gegen Rasenballsport Leipzig äußert, antisemitisch grundiert ist. Ich glaube, unser stundenlanges Gespräch hat das irgendwie hinreichend klargemacht, dass das nicht so ist und dass es eben sehr, sehr differenziert ausfallen kann. Aber so sehr ich das auch respektiere, dass man bei plakativen Aktionen natürlich verkürzen muss, sind da sehr, sehr viele Sachen passiert und passieren sehr, sehr häufiger Sachen in dem Protest, die wirklich weit übers Ziel hinausschießen und wie gesagt auch eine Motivik bedienen, die eigentlich ganz woanders ein Zuhause hat. Und ich glaube, dass das kein Zufall ist, sondern wirklich auch der Tatsache geschuldet ist, dass sich in diesem, wie ich es nennen würde, regressiven Antikapitalismus da was was widerspiegelt, was eben sehr typisch ist eigentlich tatsächlich für den Antisemitismus. Und das habe ich in dieser ganzen Ablehnung von RB Leipzig sehr häufig beobachtet. Und das finde ich tatsächlich auch ein gravierendes Problem, weil es natürlich auch jede Form von rationaler, vernünftiger Kritik auch völlig entwertet und in eine völlig falsche Richtung zieht.
Danke nochmal für diese Einordnung. Alex, es war mir wichtig, dass wir diesen Aspekt der Kritik an die Kritik an der Kritik, dass wir das noch mit reinnehmen, denn das gehört auch zu diesem Themenkomplex dazu und das habe ich bisher im ganzen Diskurs rund um Raba Leipzig nicht so häufig gehört. Ich versuche das Unmögliche und versuche, zusammenzufassen, was wir die letzten 18 Stunden besprochen haben. Und da darf jeder von euch noch ein Abschlussstatement geben, denn wir sind hier immer noch im Markus-Land-Setting. Wir haben sehr, sehr lange darüber diskutiert, ob Leipzig nicht nur ein Marketing-Instrument Red Bulls ist und es ist durchaus kaum anders zu formulieren, als das das eigentliche Ziel des Engagements im Fußball und auch im deutschen Fußball Marketingzwecke sind. Wie immer man das auch selbst dann einorten möchte. Wir haben geredet über Wettbewerbsvorteile, die Red Bull Leipzig, die Rasenballsport Leipzig, meine Güte, durch seine – Raba, Raba, sag einfach Raba. Ja, ich sag ab jetzt wirklich immer nur noch Raba. Allein damit mir dieser Football nie wieder passiert. Ich sage ernsthaft, ich sage ab jetzt einfach immer weiter Raba, damit mir das nie wieder passiert.
Sag am besten nur Leipzig.
Ich möchte mich gerade duschen. Nicht mal um diese Uhrzeiten. Es ist sehr spät Uhr nachts und wir alle müssen morgen früh arbeiten. Nicht mal jetzt, würde ich. Naja, also wir haben herausgearbeitet, dass Raba Leipzig einen Wettbewerbsvorteil hat in verschiedener Hinsicht, wirtschaftlich, aber auch durch die Konstruktion, dass man auf einen größeren Pool an Spieler zurückgreifen kann. Aber dass dieser Wettbewerbsvorteil auch nach jetzigem Stand legitim erarbeitet ist und legal ist, könnte höchstens sein, dass die UEFA da dann noch etwas zur Integrität des Wettbewerbs zu sagen hat. Das werden wir alles beobachten müssen. Dann haben wir das Thema Tradition und Zukunft der neue Fußball, die neue Fankultur angesprochen. Und ich würde sagen, festgestellt, dass das vor allem ein emotionales Thema ist und gar nicht so sehr faktisch einfach zu diskutieren ist. Da gibt es gar nicht so viele klare Indizien, die man da nehmen könnte, außer so eine gewisse Haltung, die Leipzig vor sich her trägt, genauso wie ganz viele andere Vereine und Fans auch eine Haltung vor sich her tragen. Aber das lädt dieses Thema emotional sehr auf. Wir haben über die Region und die Rolle Leipzigs gesprochen, auch im ganzen Konstrukt Red Bull Fußball. Wie könnte sich das entwickeln? Da haben wir dann nette und nicht so nette Zukunftsszenarien entworfen und uns etwas im Land des Konjunktivs bewegt. Und jetzt am Schluss haben wir noch über die Kritik in den Medien an Raaber Leipzig gesprochen und wir haben auch über den Umgang der Fans mit Leipzig gesprochen, etwas verkürzt. Was jetzt hinten runter gefallen ist, ist generelle Kritik am Unternehmen Red Bull oder auch an Dietrich Mateschitz. Da gab es unter anderem jetzt ein Interview in der neuen Voralberger Zeitung, was für einige auch gesorgt hat, auch durch politische Äußerungen zu Red Bull. Als Sponsor gibt es eine ARD-Dokumentation, die ich auch verlinken werde in den Shownotes. Die dunkle Seite von Red Bull, da geht es um das Engagement im Extrem und ja doch im Extremsport und um den Tod einiger Sportler, die in jeweils im direkten Zusammenhang mit Sponsoring-Aktionen von Red Bull. Das alles werde ich verlinken. Das war im Groben das, was wir besprochen haben. Und jetzt würde ich jedem von euch noch die Möglichkeit geben, nochmal, ich gebe jedem nochmal sein Eingangsstatement und jetzt könnte ich sagen, ob sich da irgendwas dran verändert hat. Fangen wir doch einfach mal bei Alex an, denn er hat das offenste Eingangsstatement gegeben. Alex, du hast gesagt, Raba ist für mich eine ambivalente Angelegenheit. Nein, ich glaube, du hast Rasenballsport Leipzig gesagt. Daran wird sich vermutlich jetzt nichts geändert haben, sondern das wurde eher noch ambivalenter durch diese Diskussion.
Das würde ich auch so sehen. Das bleibt für mich auch eine ambivalente Geschichte. Das ist ja auch entsprechend kontroversiert diskutiert worden und sehr vernünftig, wie ich finde. Es bleibt mir, wie gesagt, weiterhin wichtig, die Kritik der Kritik auch einer Kritik zu unterziehen, weil ich glaube, dass das natürlich auch zielführend sein kann. Mich ist auch nochmal klar geworden, man muss sich wirklich die Frage stellen. Zum einen, welche Form von Wettbewerb wollen wir eigentlich? Wie entwickelt sich das Ganze weiter? Ich hatte ja versucht, so ein bisschen anzusprechen. Dass das Ganze natürlich auch einer Veränderung unterlegen hat in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten und auch was so das Sportsponsoring betrifft natürlich einer Veränderung unterzogen worden ist. Dass die ganzen rechtlichen Geschichten sich damit geändert haben. Dass immer wieder natürlich auch die Gerichte angerufen worden sind, zumindest in früheren Jahrzehnten, wenn das nicht so weiterging, sozusagen wie das mit diesem hässlichen Wort Marktteilnehmer heißt. Dass das wollten und ich glaube, dass das auch weiter eine Geschichte sein kann, die uns beschäftigt. Also wir haben ja über 50 plus 1 gesprochen und ich würde ihm mal die Prognose abgeben, dass das nicht mehr allzu lange Bestand hat. Ich glaube, da lindt man sich auch nicht allzu weit aus dem Fenster, ob das dann irgendwie eine Geschichte ist, die sozusagen von innen heraus gekippt wird oder ob das dann doch um ein Gericht geht, der das darüber befindet. Lass ich mal dahingestellt sein. Aber ich glaube, über die Frage, welche Art von Wettbewerb das eigentlich sein soll, den wir da sehen wollen, muss man sich wahrscheinlich Gedanken machen. Man muss sich, glaube ich, auch Gedanken machen, wie das Ganze dann organisiert werden kann. Man muss sich überhaupt, glaube ich, Gedanken darüber machen, wie ist professioneller Sport im Kapitalismus überhaupt aufgestellt und welchen Mechanismen ist er da unterworfen. Da sind schon auch einige Antworten darauf gegeben worden. Auch das, denke ich, ist in vielerlei Hinsicht ambivalent. Ich sehe einfach die Vorzüge nicht, die darin bestehen. Aber das ist, glaube ich, auch weitgehend unstrittig gewesen. Ich sehe die Vorzüge nicht, die darin bestehen sollen, dass man die Dinge nur um ihre Selbstwillen tut, weil das auch ganz, ganz fürchterliche Konsequenzen einfach haben kann, sodass man sich da schon weiter entwickeln muss. Natürlich soll man da kritisch bleiben. Natürlich geht es überhaupt nicht um eine Apologie des Bestehenden. Ich glaube, das ist auch hinreichend klar geworden. Aber mit einer hochgradig ideologisch motivierten Kritik darf man da, glaube ich, überhaupt nicht dran gehen. Denn das zeigt wirklich ganz, ganz fürchterliche Ergebnisse und tatsächlich auch welche, die ich deutlich schlimmer finde, als alles, was irgendwie der moderne professionelle Sport im Kapitalismus hervorbringen kann. Das ist immer so ein Grund, warum mir das auch besonders wichtig ist, an der Thematik dran zu bleiben, weil das wirklich nicht nur ideologisch versaut ist, sondern weil das Anleihen bei wirklich ganz, ganz finsteren, ganz, ganz finsteren Warnwelten nimmt und glaube, dass das ein Punkt ist, den man definitiv im Auge behalten sollte. Aber professioneller Sport ist ein Wandel unterzogen und ich glaube, dass auch diese ganze Diskussion um Europa-Liga beispielsweise umgesetzte Teilnehmer, um keinen geregelten Auf-Abstieg mehr, dass das Diskussionen sind, die uns noch ziemlich lange beschäftigen werden und ich bin auch da an dem Punkt überhaupt nicht glücklich damit, wie die Diskussionen laufen. Ich bin auch überhaupt keiner von denen, die sagen her damit, ich will diese europäische Superliga haben, ohne Auf- und Abstieg, nur mit den ganz großen. Das schaltet dieses Überraschungsmoment im Sport und ich glaube, auch dafür lieben wir ihn ja auch alle. Nicht zuletzt schaltet dieses Überraschungsmoment völlig aus, das kann überhaupt nicht sein. Also das darf natürlich nicht nur nach diesen Prinzipien laufen, aber ich glaube, dass man sich trotzdem eine relativ ergebnisoffene und gründliche und rationale Diskussion antun muss, um zu überlegen, wo soll das Ganze überhaupt dahingehen. Und ich glaube, dass RW Leipzig in dieser Hinsicht überhaupt auch nur ein Sinnbild davon ist. Sicherlich auch in gewisser Weise ein Vorreiter, aber einer, an dem man, glaube ich, eher nüchtern rangehen muss als mit totaler Wut im Bauch. Und ich glaube, dass man damit weiterkommt. Und denke, die Diskussion hat das hier auch gezeigt.
Sie hörten Alex Feuerherdt von Kolinas Erben at Lisas Welt auf Twitter. Vielen Dank, Alex, für dein Schlussstatement. Noch kurz zehn Themen angerissen, die wir jetzt noch nicht ausgespürt diskutiert hatten. Aber das ist ja auch eine Kunst. Nach so vielen Stunden. Das zeigt ja auch, dass...
Ich bin wieder munter geworden. Jetzt habe ich den Toten Punkt überwunden.
Ich dachte, den Toten Punkt hattest du, als du am Anfang eineinhalb Stunden die Klappe gehalten hast. Aber das freut mich ja, dass der...
Da war ich noch taufrisch.
Andreas, du hast vorhin gesagt, Rasenballsport Leipzig ist für uns ein ganz normaler Verein. Was habt ihr denn? Ja, keine Ahnung, was wir haben, Andreas. Ich wollte einfach mal so fünf Stunden über den Verein reden, weißt du?
Ich finde, das ist ja auch gut aufgegangen. Und ja, unser Statement war jetzt nicht so inhaltreich, sondern hat versucht, eben erstmal so ein bisschen was zu spiegeln. So einer Situation, der wir uns manchmal ausgesetzt sehen und fand das eigentlich sehr schön von allen Seiten hier. Ganz explizit einschließlich Matthias ja aufgelöst. Ich denke, wir haben das ganz oft in Bezugsrahmen gesetzt, sei es jetzt, wie Medien funktionieren, wie aber auch Medien meinen, dass die Leser und Leserinnen funktionieren. Alex hat auch immer wieder den großen Bezugsrahmen klargemacht. Was für ein Gesellschaftssystem leben wir eigentlich? Das wird einem ja manchmal heutzutage schon, wenn man allein mit dem Wort mit K um die Ecke kommt in dem Zusammenhang von dem Thema, gesagt, das war naiv, denkst du denn, die anderen bezahlen nicht auch Geld? Und ja, aber die Frage ist ja immer ein bisschen, wie das läuft und unter welchen Bedingungen. Und ich finde, das ist uns auf vielen Ebenen sehr gut gelungen. Ich fand das eine sehr schöne Diskussion. Keine Ahnung, was ich jetzt hier noch groß an Botschaft mitgeben will.
Du hast uns schon alle gelobt, deswegen ich gehöre da nicht rein.
Gut, da klingt mich direkt aus. Was ich noch sagen will vielleicht an die Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich finde bemerkenswert, ich glaube, und das hat jetzt weniger was mit der – das nehme ich mich jetzt vom Selbstlob aus, weil das stinkt ja, aber man findet solche Diskussionen und auch sozusagen mit diesem Abstraktionsgrad, und das haben wir auch schon öfter in der Diskussion gesagt, man findet das leider nicht überall. Das ist eben kein Thema für einen Doppelpass und selbst wenn Sky jetzt mal eine Sky90-Sendung zu einem Thema macht, was ja irgendwie auch schon mal gut ist, 90 Minuten zu einem Thema zu reden und nicht zu allen Themen aus der Woche, ist es glaube ich schon bemerkenswert, dass sowas in Blogs und in Podcasts stattfindet und da will ich einfach nur alle Hörerinnen und Hörer nochmal ganz explizit ermuntern, sich breit zu informieren, sich divers zu informieren, die Blogs vor allem auch zu lesen, weil offenbar findet diese Art von Öffentlichkeit eben nicht unbedingt in diesem klassischen Mediensystem statt, was wir bisher kennen und ja, auch da kann man sich breit einbringen, da kann man selber Fragen stellen, da kann man selber Blogs machen, selber Podcasts machen, kann man unterstützen. Diese Möglichkeiten sollten insbesondere die Sportfans, glaube ich, noch mehr auch in Deutschland nutzen.
Rasenfunk.de slash Podroy, da gibt es alle Fußball Podcasts, die es so gibt, hoffe ich zumindest. Und ihr hört Andreas Bischof von Zwangsbeglück.de auf Twitter at analog unterstrich a. Und jetzt darf Jens uns erzählen, ob sich an seinem Statement irgendwas geändert hat. Rasenballsport Leipzig ist für mich die Perversion des modernen Fußballs, Regelumgehungen, Finanztoping in Anführungszeichen und Sport als reine Marketingmaßnahme.
Ne, das habe ich ja vorher mit Bedacht gewählt und auch wenn ich sicherlich ein paar interessante Einblicke gewinnen konnte und durfte, die ich vorher nicht so hatte, hat sich an meiner generellen Position gegenüber diesem Verein nicht unbedingt viel verändert. Was mir aber im Laufe der Diskussion nochmal ein bisschen klar geworden ist, was ich dann leider aufgrund der Vielzahl der ausschweifenden Wortmeldungen der andere Diskussionsteilnehmer nicht mehr ganz platzieren konnte, ist, dass, also Fans sind außen vor, das finde ich voll in Ordnung und ich glaube, jeder der Fußballfan geworden ist, ist das mehr oder weniger unfreiwillig und willkürlich geworden und da konnte man nicht unbedingt eine Wahl treffen. Ist ja so wie Liebe, hat Rondi immer gesagt. Auf wen ich aber so ein bisschen mehr Wut gewonnen habe, ist einfach wirklich DFB und DFL, auch wenn wir deren Rolle jetzt zwar oft ansprechen wollten, aber es dann irgendwie so ein bisschen hinten übergefallen ist, weil da einfach vermasselt wurde, gerade wenn ich jetzt vom KVNB, KNVB, Königliche Niederländische Fußballverband, was auch immer, lese, dass die das verboten haben, dass die keinen RB-Club erlaubt haben. Wenn ich zurückdenke an blumige Worte von Andreas Rettig, als er noch nicht bei St. Pauli war, sondern noch in einer Liga-Vorstandsrolle, dass man da alles Mögliche tun wollen würde und die einzige Änderung war, dass das Logo einen Fußball haben musste, statt einer gelben Sonne. Dann bin ich da nach wie vor ziemlich enttäuscht, wie 50 plus 1, was ja wirklich lobenswert ist. Nicht nur von Rabah, sondern dann auch Leverkusen, Wolfsburg, Ingolstadt und wie sie noch alle heißen, dass das so ausgehöhlt wird. Dann ist Rabah vermutlich nur das Symptom, und die Krankheit sitzt irgendwo bei DFB und DFL, um mal dieses Bild zu bemühen, ohne jetzt von einer solchen sprechen zu wollen.
Gerade noch die Koffer gekriegt. Jens Buschmann von schwarzgelb.de und auf der Ohren einem sehr empfehlenswerten Borussia Dortmund Podcast bei Twitter die Ed Baumwollhose konsumiert ihn in jeglicher Form. Es lohnt sich. Das hört sich auch irgendwie falsch an, diese Formulierung. Und außerdem Matthias Kießling, der vorhin gesagt hat, vor einigen Stunden Rasenballsport ist das Beste, was mir passieren konnte. Ich vermute auch daran hat sich nichts geändert, Matthias.
Jetzt nach sechs Stunden Podcast. Ja, nicht so richtig.
Das ist das Zweitbeste, weil jetzt hattest du ja hier ein Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Ja, ne, hat sich grundsätzlich nichts dran geändert, weil die Dinge immer noch sind so, wie sie am Anfang geschrieben wurden. Ja, das ich glaube, was es nett macht, ist, dass man, als ich angefangen habe in der RB Leipzig, war es ja immer so Fußball und man kam relativ schnell an viele, viele Punkte, von Verbandsregularen über Baurecht bis hin zu irgendwelchen Geschichten, wo man sich immer wieder neu abstellen, neu informieren, neue Debatten aufnehmen und neue Informationen verarbeiten musste. Das ist tatsächlich über die Jahre mal abgesehen von dem großen medialen Kram, der in der Bundesliga so tobt und manchmal ein bisschen anstrengend ist, schon eine recht spannende Geschichte gewesen und auch eine sehr lehrreiche Geschichte. Ich extrem viel gelernt habe, wo ich nicht gedacht hätte, dass man das im Rahmen von der Beschäftigung mit einem Fußballverein lernen konnte. Das hat noch nicht mal was mit Taktik zu tun. Ich glaube, wo man ein bisschen aufpassen muss in diesen ganzen Debatten und Zeug, ist, dass man auf so eine Ebene rutscht von Red Bull ist unser Unglück. Also so eine Projektion, wie es in Dortmund rüberkam, dieses Volksbordschützen gegen Dienstzerstörer. Es passiert dann schon manchmal, dass manche das vielleicht auch allzu wörtlich nehmen. Ich glaube, da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen, wo man Grenzen auch um der Bahn zieht. Ich fand eigentlich in den letzten Wochen immer jene Debatten am spannendsten, wo es nicht zentral um RB Leipzig ging, sondern generell um so Phänomene. Und wo dann RB Leipzig eher in so Randbemerkungen als Beispiel herangezogen wurde oder mit so einem Verweis versehen wurde. Das macht dann, glaube ich, in so einer generellen Debatte mehr Sinn, als das ganze Elend von dem, was man so im Fußball sieht, auf so einen Club zu stecken und dann zu glauben, dass man, wenn man den irgendwie so bekämpft, dass das dann irgendwie etwas löst. Das wird nicht passieren und führt dann letztlich nur zu einer Radikalisierung, die man auch nicht braucht. Also es ist halt so, es gibt so den Tropfen, der das Fass zum Überlaufen bringt und es macht keinen Sinn, sich den Tropfen jetzt irgendwie 30 Jahre lang anzugucken und über Zähne diskutieren, wenn man eigentlich nicht besser über das Fass reden sollte oder das Wasser, was im Fass ist.
Sehr schön. Und ich meine, der Rasenfunk ist ja das perfekte Beispiel, dass dann Raabe-Leipzig auch wirklich nur am Rande vorkommt. Vielen lieben Dank, Matthias Kießling, der Ad-Rote-Brause-Blogger bei Twitter. Sein Blog heißt rote-brause-blogger.de und der Podcast dazu ist Champagner statt Bier. Vielen Dank, Matthias, dass du mit dabei warst. War ja auch durchaus mutig, sich diese Konstellation hier in die Höhle des Löwen zu begeben. Das freut mich und das bringt mich auch zu meinem Anfangsstatement, mein Statement. Denn ich habe ja gesagt, Rasenballsport Leipzig ist für mich das perfekte Beispiel dafür, warum es manchmal so anstrengend ist, über Fußball zu diskutieren. Und das war jetzt ein sehr langes Setup für diese Pointe, aber das hat sich natürlich komplett verändert. Ich bin der Einzige, der seinen Statement komplett revidieren muss, denn ich empfand diese Diskussion als sehr, sehr gewinnbringend. Wirklich vielen, vielen Dank an euch alle vier, dass ihr euch nicht nur die Zeit genommen habt. Liebe Hörer, wir haben jetzt nach 2 Uhr nachts und wir haben um 20 Uhr begonnen. Das ist an einem Wochentag absolut herausragend. Also wirklich vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Und dann auch, dass ihr so diskutiert habt, wie ihr diskutiert habt mit Respekt dem anderen gegenüber, mit genügend Zeit für den anderen, mit Humor. Es hat mir großen Spaß gemacht. Es war ein Mammutprojekt, dieses Tribünengespräch. Also vielen, vielen lieben Dank. Und man sieht mal wieder, ohne die Gäste wäre der Rasenfunk so rein überhaupt gar nichts. Deswegen danke euch, war wirklich eine schöne Diskussion. Und jetzt freue ich mich, wenn die Diskussion dann weitergeht in den sozialen Netzwerken bei youtube unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de Ich glaube, das Ding ist immer noch nicht ganz durch, aber ein paar Fragen haben wir hoffentlich beantwortet. Also vielen Dank an euch alle, vielen Dank auch an die Hörer, alle Hörer, die sich das hier in voller Länge reingezogen haben. Ihr könnt den Rasenfunk unterstützen unter rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Vielleicht gründe ich auch irgendwann den Rabafunk und werde mich komplett vermarkten. Ich überlege mir das sorgfältig. Hört auch in die Schlusskonferenz, hört in den Kurzpass, bewertet uns bei iTunes, abonniert uns bei Twitter und folgt uns bei Facebook. Andersrum, egal. Macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Tribünengespräch. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.